THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SOMEONE
HEARING.
ON MONDAY APRIL NINTH.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH OUR
INFORMATIONAL ISSUE MENTAL
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA ISSUE ONE
WE GET OUT THE FIRST PANEL COME
FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU TO A CHAIR ARAMBULA
ON MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'M CATHERINE TEAR I'M ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF HIGH VALUE CARE AT
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION. AND I'M VERY HAPPY
TO BE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOUNDATION AND TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER SOME BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN CALIFORNIA. TO START OFF
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IS A NONPROFIT
INDEPENDENT PHILANTHROPY WITH
OFFICES IN OAKLAND IN
SACRAMENTO.
OUR FOCUS IS GRANT MAKING TO
IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND SPECIFICALLY WE'RE
DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
MEANINGFUL MEASURABLE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE WAY THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
PROVIDES CARE TO PEOPLE. IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH LOW INCOMES AND THOSE WHO
WERE POORLY SERVED BY THE STATUS
QUO.
IN MARCH WE PUBLISHED MENTAL
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA FOR TOO
MANY CARE NOT THERE AND I HAVE
COPIES OF THAT FOR A MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY. THIS IS
A REPORT IN OUR ALMANAC SERIES
OF PUBLICATIONS WHICH COMPILED
COMPILE THE MOST RECENT
AVAILABLE DATA ON DIFFERENT
TOPICS.
TO SHINE A LIGHT ON THE STATUS
OF HEALTH CARE IN THE STATE.
MY FOCUS TODAY WILL BE ON THE
FOLLOWING AREAS FROM THE REPORT
PREVALENCE OF MENTAL ILLNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACCESS TO CARE.
AND I FIRST WANT TO CREDIT THE
REPORT'S AUTHOR WENDY HOLDS OF
DMA HEALTH STRATEGIES FOR HER
WORK IN PUTTING THE REPORT
TOGETHER.
WE LAST PUBLISHED A VERSION OF
THIS ALMANAC IN THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN.
THE DATA FOR THE REPORT COMES
FROM A WIDE VARIETY OF SOURCES
FEDERAL SOURCES LIKE THE CENSUS
IN THE SAHARA SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION. STATE PROGRAM
DATA FROM DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES OFFICE POD
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MANY OTHERS.
AND WHILE THE SOURCE IS VERY
MUCH OF THE DATA IN THE REPORT
IS FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN.
SO WE ALL KNOW THERE BEEN VERY A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT CHANGES
SINCE THEN INCLUDING EXPANSION
ABOUT A CAL FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY.
THOSE DEVELOPMENTS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY REFLECTED IN THE
DATA WE SEE AND AS WE MOVE ALONG
I'M ALSO GOING TO OFFER A FEW
BITS OF INFORMATION FROM A
STATEWIDE POLL THAT WE SUPPORTED
THAT WAS DONE BY UNIVERSE OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
SO.
TO START THE PREVALENCE STATE
OF THAT I'M GOING TO PRESENT IS
FROM AN ANALYSIS THAT SO OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE.
FOUNDATION COMMISSION FROM
CHARLES HOLZER.
THESE RESEARCHERS ARE WELL KNOWN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEY
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED ESTIMATES TO
THE FORMER DEPARTMENT MENTAL
HEALTH TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
IN ITS CALIFORNIA MENTAL THE
METS AND ESTIMATES FOR SUB
POPULATIONS ARE UNCHANGED FROM
THE LAST TIME THEY WERE DONE
THAT USED TWO THOUSAND NINE DATA
SO WERE. USING DATA FROM FIVE
YEARS LATER.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ONE IN TWENTY
FOUR ADULTS THAT'S ABOUT FOUR
PERCENT OF ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA.
EXPERIENCEDA SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS DEFINED AS A DIAGNOSABLE
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL OR EMOTIONAL
DISORDER RESULTING IN A
FUNCTIONAL IMPAIRMENT THAT
INTERFERES WITH OR LIMITS MAJOR
LIFE ACTIVITIES.
A MUCH LARGER PERCENTAGE IN THAT
TOP STRIPE OF ORANGE ABOUT ONE
IN SIX CALIFORNIANS OR FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF OUR STATE ADULT
POPULATION EXPERIENCED ANY
MENTAL ILLNESS. IN OTHER WORDS
THEY ALSO HAD A MENTAL
BEHAVIORAL OR EMOTIONAL DISORDER
REGARDLESS OF THE LEVEL OF
IMPAIRMENT SO THIS INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHOSE MENTAL ILLNESS
CAUSES. SERIOUS OR MODERATE OR
MILD FUNCTIONAL IMPAIRMENT.
AMONG CHILDREN IN THE GREEN
FIGURES MORE THAN SEVEN PERCENT
OR ONE IN THIRTEEN HAD A SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCE THAT'S A
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL OR EMOTIONAL
DISORDER THAT SUBSTANTIALLY
LIMITS FUNCTIONING. IN FAMILY
SCHOOL OR COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES
AND THERE IS NO ACQUITTAL AND.
CATEGORY FOR CHILDREN OF OF THE
ANY MENTAL ILLNESS DISORDER IN
ADULTS AND THAT'S WHY WE DON'T
SEE THE. LARGER PERCENTAGE IN
CHILDREN AND AGAIN AS I SAID
THESE NUMBERS ARE ESSENTIALLY
UNCHANGED FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINE.
SO I NOW WANT TO DIG INTO A
LITTLE BIT THE VARIATION THAT WE
SEE ACROSS THE STATE.
THE FIRST SLIDE SHOWS US SOME
REGIONAL VARIATION.
THE RATE OF SERIOUS EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE AMONG CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA VARY FROM A HIGH OF
EIGHT POINT ONE PERCENT SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. TO A LOW OF
SEVEN POINT ONE PERCENT IN THE
BAY AREA.
THOSE OF THE GREEN BARS THOSE
ARE CHILDREN THERE AND THE
AVERAGE AGAIN IS ABOUT SEVEN
POINT SIX
PERCENT.
AMONG ADULTS THE PREVALENCE OF
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
WHICH IS THE ORANGE BARS RANGED
FROM A HIGH OF FIVE POINT FOUR
PERCENT IN THE NORTHERN SIERRA
REGION. TO A LOW OF THREE POINT
FOUR PERCENT IN THE GREATER BAY
AREA BAY AREA.
THERE'S ALSO THAT.
.
THERE'S ALSO VARIABILITY WHICH I
DIDN'T INCLUDE ON THE SLIDE BY
GENDER AND BY AGE SO WOMEN A
CALIFORNIA WOMEN WERE MORE
LIKELY THAN MEN TO EXPERIENCE
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AT A RATE
OF FOUR POINT EIGHT PERCENT
VERSUS THREE POINT SIX PERCENT.
AND THE AGE RANGE SHOWS A.
A SORT OF A.
A STANDARD DISTRIBUTION WITH
LOWER RATES IN THE YOUNGEST VERY
YOUNGEST ADULT AGE GROUPS AND
ALSO THE OLDEST TO DATE DULLED
AGE GROUPS ON THE PEAK IN THE.
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY FOUR AGE
GROUP.
PREVALENCE VARIES BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY AS WELL YOU'LL SEE A
MUCH GREATER OF DIFFERENCE AMONG
ADULTS ON THE RIGHT HAND.
CHART THAN AMONG CHILDREN.
THE.
IT'S TRUE THOUGH THE CHILDREN
YOU DO SEE SOME DIFFERENTIAL
WITH. LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN
NATIVE AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER CHILDREN OF HAVING
RATES OF SERIOUS EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE CLOSER TO EIGHT
PERCENT WITH.
WHITE ASIAN AND MULTI RACIAL
CHILDREN CLOSER TO SEVEN
PERCENT.
FOR ADULTS AS I SAID
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER
VARIABILITY NATIVE AMERICAN
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND MULTI
RACIAL ADULTS HAVE THE HIGHEST
RATES OF SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
ASIANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS THE
LOWEST RATES
AND AGAIN THESE NUMBERS ARE
ESSENTIALLY UNCHANGED FROM TWO
THOUSAND NINE DATA SO WE HAVE
SEEN THESE BEFORE AND WE.
WE DON'T SEE MUCH DIFFERENCE.
LAST SLIDE ON PREVALENCE ON
QUICKLY IS BY INCOME.
AND AGAIN THIS LOOKS VERY
SIMILAR FOR ADULTS IN ORANGE AND
CHILDREN IN GREEN IT'S IS FAR
MORE COMMON TO SEE SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS IN ADULTS SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCE IN
CHILDREN. ARM AMONG PEOPLE AT
THE LOWEST INCOME LEVELS UNDER A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
I NOW WANT TO SHIFT FOCUS TO A
TOPIC THAT I KNOW IS OF
PARTICULAR INTEREST TO EVERYONE
ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THAT'S
ACCESS TO CARE.
THE DATA I'M PRESENTING COMES
FROM A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
SOURCES SO I DO WANT TO CAUTION
THAT NOT EVERYTHING THAT'S
PRESENTED HERE CAN BE DIRECTLY
COMPARED. FOR INSTANCE ACROSS
AGE GROUPS
BUT IT IS DIRECTIONALLY.
I THINK.
ALL LINES UP AND WHAT IT SHOWS
IS THAT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION AS A WHOLE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND CONCERNING GAPS
IN ACCESS TO CARE. AND THAT BY
AND LARGE THAT SITUATION HAS NOT
IMPROVED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE.
SO THIS LIVE SHOWS THAT ONLY
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA ADULTS THAT'S THE
PORTION OF REFLECTED IN BLUE ON
THIS CHART.
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS RECEIVED
TREATMENT OR COUNSELING DURING
THE PRIOR YEAR THIS IS A
COMPOSITE OF FOUR YEARS OF DATA
BUT THEY'RE LOOKING BACK A YEAR.
THAT'S A HOLLOW LOWER THAN THE
NATIONAL RATE WHICH IS ABOUT
FORTY THREE PERCENT AND IS ABOUT
THE SAME THAT WE SAW IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE.
IT'S NOT SHOWN HERE BUT THERE'S
SOME INTERESTING DATA TO THAT'S
IN THE ALMANAC OF THE REPORT
ITSELF. THAT SHOWS THAT EVEN
AMONG THE CALIFORNIA ADULTS WHO
REPORTED THAT THEY HAD SOUGHT
CARE TREATMENT FOR THEIR MENTAL
ILLNESS SEVENTEEN PERCENT
REPORTED THAT THEY DID NOT GET
IT.
AND THAT LINES UP WITH.
SURVEY DATA THAT WE GOT FROM
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY POLL WHICH SIMILARLY
FOUND BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
PERCENT OF PEOPLE. SAYING THAT
THEY HAD SOUGHT CARE FOR
THEMSELVES OR A FAMILY MEMBER
FOR A MENTAL HEALTH CONCERN AND
HAD BEEN UNABLE TO RECEIVE IT.
AND THE MOST COMMON COMPLAINTS
WITH THAT THEY COULD NOT FIND A
COUNSELOR OR A DOCTOR WHO WOULD
ACCEPT THEIR INSURANCE OR THEY
COULDN'T AFFORD THE COST.
NOW WHEN WE LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT
ADULTS WHO REPORT MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE EPISODES VERSUS THE
PREVIOUS SLIDE WHICH WAS ANY
MENTAL ILLNESS. WE SEE US LATE
WE SEE SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER FUND
OUTCOME IN THIS CASE ABOUT CHART
ON THE RIGHT THE BLUE. IS THE
PROPORTION OF ADULTS REPORTING
MAJOR DEPRESSIVE DISORDER WHO
DID GET TREATMENT.
SO THAT'S ABOUT TWO THIRDS.
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER.
AND.
.
AT THE SAME TIME THOUGH IS NOT
WHAT IT SHOULD BE I THINK THE
NATIONAL STANDARD FOR THAT IS
MORE LIKE SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
SO CALIFORNIA'S STILL BEHIND. IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
RECEIVING CARE EVEN FOR A VERY
SERIOUS ILLNESS LIKE MAJOR
DEPRESSION.
BUT THIS IS A SLIDE THAT I
THINK.
IS PROBABLY.
THE MOST CONCERNING OF ALL THE
NUMBERS EVER IN REPORTING TODAY
SO THESE ARE ADOLESCENTS.
ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE THE
ORANGE BAR A CALIFORNIA NUMBERS
AND THAT IS THE OF. PROPORTION
OF A PERCENTAGE OF ADOLESCENTS
WHO REPORT HAVING HAD A MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE EPISODE IN THE PAST
YEAR.
AND.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE AMONG THE
ONLY ONCE WE SEE THAT HAVE
CHANGED FROM TWO THOUSAND NINE
AND THEY HAVE NOT CHANGED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. SO THE NUMBER
OF ADOLESCENCE REPORTING MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE EPISODE IS UP TO
TWELVE POINT THREE PERCENT OR
ONE IN EIGHT ADOLESCENTS FIVE
YEARS AGO.
IN IN THE.
EIGHT OH NINE YEAR THAT WAS
EIGHT PERCENT SO THAT'S NEARLY A
FIFTY PERCENT INCREASE. IN THE
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE REPORTING
MAJOR I'M DEPRESSIVE EPISODE AND
THEN ON THE RIGHT.
.
THIS IS REALLY THE REVERSE OF
THE CHART I JUST SHOWED FOR
ADULTS THE GREEN IS THE
PROPORTION OF ADOLESCENCE WITH
MAJOR DEPRESSIVE EPISODE REPORT
HAVING RECEIVED TREATMENT.
THAT'S ONLY ABOUT A THIRD.
AND LOWER THAN THE NATIONAL
RATE.
JUST WANT TO MAKE.
A COUPLE OF COMMENTS ABOUT THE
ROLE OF THE PUBLIC SYSTEM.
IN PROVIDING CARE IN OF THE
AREA OF MENTAL HEALTH SO THE
CHART ON THE LEFT IS FOR ALL
HEALTH CARE AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT.
THE PURPLE AND THE TEAL.
BANDS WHICH ARE MEDICAID
FUNDING AND OTHER PUBLIC FUNDING
AT UP TO ABOUT A THIRD OF ALL
FUNDING THAT'S FOR ALL HEALTH
CARE.
AS COMPARED TO MUCH BIGGER
PORTIONS FOR PRIVATE AND
MEDICARE.
BUT FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
MEDICAID AND OTHER PUBLIC
DOLLARS MAKEUP OF MORE THAN
HALF.
OF THE SPENDING ON HEALTH CARE
NO THESE ARE NATIONAL NUMBERS
NOT CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE
THEM FOR CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE THINK THAT THAT PROBABLY
TRACKS HERE AND IT JUST LEADS
I'M.
REALLY TO MY FINAL POINT WHICH
IS THAT. ARE IN CALIFORNIA THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IS.
IS IS OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
SYSTEM BY AND LARGE AND YOU ALL
KNOW THAT AND.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THE FOCUS OF
TODAY'S HEARING I'M I WANTED TO
THE FLAG OF THESE NUMBERS JUST
AS AN ILLUSTRATION OF THE
OUTSIZE ROLE THAT THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM PLAYS. IN THE DELIVERY OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS THIS IS THE NUMBER
THE USE OF MEDI CAL SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
INCREASE. OF FROM I THINK THAT'S
TWENTY TWELVE THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FIFTEEN. OBVIOUSLY A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY AND TO RETURN TO A
THEME FROM EARLIER REFLECTS THE
IMPACT OF MEDI CAL EXPANSION.
FROM THE MUCH GREATER ACCESS
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD
TO PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
SO FOR OUR FOUNDATION GOING
FORWARD WILL BE LOOKING AT THE
IMPACT OF THIS ELIGIBILITY
EXPANSION OF EXPANSION OF
BENEFITS OF THE WORK THAT.
THE STATE AND THE COUNTIES HAVE
DONE TO OUR BRING NEW PROGRAMS
ONLINE TO PROVIDE MORE
INTEGRATED CARE TO LOOK AT NEW
WAYS OF PROVIDING SERVICES. AND
SEE WHAT ALL OF THOSE CHANGES.
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO TO AFFECT
HEALTH OUTCOMES ACCESS TO CARE
AND OF COURSE BECAUSE.
SO I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT THIS AFTERNOON I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AND.
TO SHARE MORE MATERIAL SINCE AS
IS HELPFUL GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION I'VE.
WANTED TO SUMMARIZE A FEW OF THE
DATA POINTS IF I COULD AND THEN.
REALLY WANTED TO ASK YOU A A
LEADING QUESTION IF I MAY.
BUT WHEN I'M LOOKING AT THIS
INFORMATION YOU'RE SAYING A SIX
OF ALL ADULTS.
IT HELPS US TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US.
IN THIS HEARING TODAY AS WE
START ADDRESSING. ISSUES THAT
AFFECT
ONE OF US WHO ARE ON THIS DIET
RIGHT HERE.
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR US TO
MAKE SURE WERE ADEQUATELY FACING
THE INFORMATION THAT'S BEFORE
US.
THE DATA POINTS I'M INTERESTED
IN IS YOU'RE SAYING THAT THERE'S
A THIRTY PERCENT INCREASE IN
INPATIENT HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
THAT TWO THIRDS OF ALL ADULTS
ARE NOT GETTING. OUT WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS ARE NOT GETTING
TREATMENT THAT TWO THIRDS OF ALL
ADOLESCENTS ARE NOT GETTING
TREATMENT FROM A MAJOR.
DEPRESSIVE EPISODES THOSE ARE
CONCERNING STATISTICS FOR ME AND
A SYMPTOM THAT OUR SYSTEM MAY
NOT BE PERFORMING AS EFFICIENTLY
AS WE MAY BELIEVE IT IS.
AND THE LEADING QUESTION IF I
MAY IS ON PAGE FOURTEEN.
AND IT'S REGARDING THE.
PERCENTAGE OF POST NATAL AND
PRENATAL DEPRESSION.
AND WHEN WE RECOGNIZE THAT
TWENTY PERCENT OF ALL OF OUR
MOTHERS.
ARE EXPERIENCING SOME FORM OF
PRENATAL OR POST NATAL
DEPRESSION WHAT ARE WE AS A
SYSTEM OR A STATE DOING TO HELP
TO PREVENT THAT TOWARDS TO HELP
EDUCATE. OUR YOUNG MOTHERS AND
AND I'M JUST GONNA MAKE A
PERSONAL.
PITCH CHAIR WHEN MY WIFE WAS
PREGNANT IT WASN'T ALWAYS EASY.
AND WHERE A TWO.
HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD FAMILY AND
HAVE OUR FEET BELOW US AND
UNDERSTAND THE STRESS THAT OUR
YOUNG MOTHERS GO THROUGH. AND
REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE DOING AS THE STATE'S TO
ADDRESS THIS BEST
VIC ISSUE.
THANKS AND I'M GLAD YOU RAISED
THAT AND I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY NO ONE IN THIS ROOM WHO
IS AND WHO ISN'T FAMILIAR WITH.
THOSE ISSUES OF MENTAL. HEALTH
DISORDERS AROUND PREGNANCY AND
POST PARTUM PERIOD OR FRANKLY.
OR IN GENERAL SO.
I CERTAINLY I I CERTAINLY I
HAVE LIVED THAT AS WELL. I
THINK.
THERE HAS BEEN INCREASED
ATTENTION AND THERE IS QUITE A
BIT OF NEW WORK THAT IS FOCUSING
ON PERINATAL DEPRESSION I'M AND
ANXIETY. A GENERAL PERINATAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS I THINK
SOME OF THE PANELS I'M COMING UP
WERE FOLLOWING ME WHO ARE MUCH
MORE. CLOSE TO THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE.
IN THE COUNTIES A AND AT THE
STATE CAN PROBABLY SPEAK TO THAT
QUESTION AS WELL. ON THAT IS ONE
WHERE.
ON THAT SLIDE FOURTEEN.
.
I THINK AND IT'S ANOTHER PLACE
WHERE IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO NOTE A SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES BY OF IN THIS CITY.
IN THE RATES OF PEOPLE REPORTING
OF. OF POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION I
THINK IN THAT CASE I DON'T HAVE
IT IN FRONT OF ME.
SO IT IS AN AREA WHERE WE
REALLY NEED TO BE FOCUSING A NOT
ONLY ON IDENTIFICATION.
POST THE BIRTH OF THE BABY BUT
REALLY WORKING THAT INTO OUR
PRENATAL CARE AND I KNOW THAT A
NUMBER OF THE HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
IN CALIFORNIA.
A NUMBER OF OUR COUNTIES ARE
WORKING ON INITIATIVES LIKE THAT
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO GET MORE
DETAIL ON THAT AND BRING IT
BACK.
RICK.
WITH THAT WANTED TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY MORE COMMENTS OTHERWISE
I BELIEVE IT WAS A WONDERFUL
FRAMING FOR TODAY'S. A COMMITTEE
HEARING AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO
.
SERGEANTS AYE COMPORT DONE WITH
THE.
SLIDESHOW SEMANSKY IF WE CAN TO
MOVE SOME OF THIS EQUIPMENT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU RECORD OR RENT WHEN
YOU'RE READY DIRECTOR.
GREAT SO I GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER CAN'T WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
WANTED TO JUST TAKE A COUPLE OF
QUICK MOMENTS JUST TO KIND OF
GIVE PRIDE.
.
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW THE
DEPARTMENT OPERATES BOTH WITH
THE COMMISSION AS WELL AS WITH
THE COUNTIES AS IT PERTAINS TO
MENTAL HEALTH.
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WORK
THAT SIEGE CF.
JUST RECENTLY SPOKE OF WE
PARTNER WITH THEM.
FOR A VARIETY OF INITIATIVES.
AND THEY HAVE CERTAINLY BEEN
QUITE INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING US
DO A LOT OF WORK AROUND ARE
ORGANIZED DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEM
WAIVER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WORKING WITH AND COUNTIES AND
PROVIDERS AND HOW WE STRUCTURE A
LOT OF OPIOID DISORDER STUFF AND
SO. YOU KNOW THEY HAVE BEEN AND
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR.
PARTNERSHIP AND SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE IS THE
DEPARTMENT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
THE DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA ON IT IS
A FAIRLY.
INTERWOVEN AND TIGHTLY.
.
COMPLICATED I IMMEDIATELY
COMPLICATED DISCUSSION FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT IT'S A STATE
DEPARTMENT THAT OVERSEES THE
DELIVERY OF SYSTEMS THROUGH A
COUNTY BASED ORGANIZED SYSTEM
AROUND SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
BOTH FOR PEDIATRIC AND ADULT
POPULATIONS.
WE WILL.
PROBABLY TO THEY USE THE TERM
BRAIDED FUNDING A LOT FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT WHEN COUNTIES
ARE DELIVERING SERVICES TO ON
EITHER.
PEDIATRIC OR ADULT POPULATIONS
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF FUNDING
SOURCES THAT THEY CAN USE TO
HELP DELIVER THOSE SERVICES ON
IN MEDI CAL.
OBVIOUSLY THE FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION IS A SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE COUNTIES
BUT THEY CAN USE.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
FUNDING THEY CAN USE THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUB ACCOUNT
THAT WAS.
DEDICATED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THEY CAN USE THEIR MHSAA
FUNDING THERE'S A SMALL AMOUNT
OF FEDERAL SAP DE BLOCK GRANT
AND SO WHEN COUNTIES HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL.
THAT IS SEEKING TREATMENT
DEPENDING ON WHO THEY ARE THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
WHATEVER'S MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE
THEY CAN USE A VARIETY OF
FUNDING SOURCES IF NOT ALL OF
THOSE AND SO IT GETS.
.
PRETTY DIFFICULT SOMETIMES TO
KIND OF PULL OUT CERTAIN FUNDING
SOURCES AND SAY WELL IS THIS.
YOU KNOW PARTICULAR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MHSAA TODAY ON IT
IS ONE FUNDING STREAM THAT
HELPS.
AUGMENTS AND OBVIOUSLY IS AN
IMPORTANT FUNDING SOURCE BUT
IT'S NOT THE ONLY FUNDS ARE SO I
JUST WANTED TO KIND OF. LAY THAT
OUT BEFORE WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME FOCUS JUST ON THE MHSAA.
THE AUDIT THAT.
WAS CONDUCTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR I'M YOU KNOW WE.
AGREED WITH A NUMBER OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE AUDITOR
MADE THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
ITEMS THAT WE EITHER DISAGREED
WITH ARE PARTIALLY AGREED WITH.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE.
BOTH
UNDERTAKEN AND CONTINUE TO SEEK
WAYS TO IMPROVE BOTH THE
DELIVERY AND USE OF THOSE.
SERVICES AND THOSE FUNDING.
STREAMS IN A WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE COUNTIES WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMISSION BUT
ALSO IN BROAD BRUSH STROKES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
THE ACT YOU KNOW APPROXIMATELY.
THIRTEEN AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN EXPENDED BY
THE COUNTIES AND A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SERVICE.
BUCKETS.
LEAVING THAT TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
SUBJECT TO REVERSION BUT WHEN
YOU START TO KIND OF LOOK AT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN SPENT THEY ARE. BEING
USED TODAY THEY ARE IMPOVING
LIVES AND HELPING.
EASE SOME OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND ILLNESS THAT IS PRESENT IN
THE STATE OBVIOUSLY CAN MORE BE
DONE. ABSOLUTELY ARE WE
COMMITTED TO WORKING YOU KNOW
AND I'M YOU KNOW MORE EITHER
EFFICIENT OR EFFECTIVE WAY.
ABSOLUTELY BUT I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF ALSO JUST PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE IN THAT IMAGE TO SAY
IS A VERY IMPORTANT. FUND SOURCE
AND FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN ON
DEDICATED THROUGH THIS REVENUE
SOURCE THE COUNTIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY USING THEM ALL THE
DIFFERENT APPROPRIATE WAYS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
HELPFUL FOR LEAN THE GROUNDS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY BUT ALSO WOULD DEFER
TO.
EITHER THE COUNTY USER ARE
MISTER YOU MEAN FOR.
FOR FURTHER CLARIFICATION.
NEXT WE'LL HAVE BRENDA GREENISH
IF YOU WANTED TO COMMENT
OTHERWISE WE'RE MOVING ON TO
TOBY EWING AND WE'LL COME BACK
WITH QUESTIONS AT THE END RENDON
MY.
GET SHE'S MY.
WHEN EIGHT HUNDRED DIAL IT
EXPERT LINE UP FOR TODAY.
FAIR ENOUGH W..
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU W. M.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE HOUSE
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
I I THINK YOU KNOW AS AS.
EVIDENCED BY THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS DONE OVER THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS YOU KNOW
THERE IS A LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION.
AROUND FISCAL TRANSPARENCY WE'VE
WE'VE REALLY TRIED.
PUSH HIM THREE COMPONENTS IN THE
FIRST ONE IS MAKING IT EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND THE FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THE FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN SPENT AND HOW MUCH MONEY IS
STILL IN THE BANK.
WE ARE WORKING TO DO THE SAME IN
TERMS OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE THIRD PIECE OF
THAT IS TO REPORT ON THE
OUTCOMES AT LEAST THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH. THEM THE
METRICS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
HOUSE SERVICES ACT REDUCING
SUICIDE.
HOMELESSNESS INCARCERATION
REMOVAL OF CHILDREN FROM THEIR
HOMES ETCETERA.
AND.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF REASONS
FOR THAT. THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FOR THE PRIORITIZE
IS MAKING SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE.
CHANCE TO WEIGH IN ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING INTO THE LOCAL A WHOLE
SYSTEM AND HOW RESOURCES ARE
BEING SPENT AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT IF YOU'VE EVER TRIED
TO PARTICIPATE IN A LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULAS.
DISCUSSION ON AB ONE A NINE
DISCUSSION IT'S IT'S.
NOT EVEN SOMEONE LIKE MYSELF WHO
SPENT MANY YEARS WORKING
GOVERNMENTS VERY HARD TO
UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEMS.
THE COMMISSION'S BEEN TRYING TO
MAKE IT VERY EASY FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE IN THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THAT PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. IS PART OF THE
FOUNDATION THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT.
AND ALONG THE WAY WE'VE RUN INTO
A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES INCLUDING
LIMITATIONS AND REPORTING AND SO
FORTH. BUT IN IN RECOGNITION
INSTRUCTOR CAN SAYS IN AND MY
COLLEAGUE TO THE RIGHT ARE ON
BEHALF OF CITIES CA KIRSTEN WILL
TELL YOU THAT. WE'VE MADE A LOT
OF PROGRESS WIN I THINK WE
STARTED THIS CONVERSATION. A
REPORTS WERE LESS LIKELY TO BE
AVAILABLE TO MUCH MORE AVAILABLE
NOW.
WE HAVE NOT JUST IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS RELEASED AN UPDATE WHAT WE
CALL A FISCAL TRANSPARENCY TOOL.
AND THAT WHEN WE STARTED THIS
WORK AND THERE WERE THERE WERE I
THINK I THINK ONE COUNTY REPORT
FOR THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FISCAL
YEAR BUT I THINK WE'RE UP TO
ABOUT THIRTY SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES. SO THAT THE SPEED
WITH WHICH THE COUNTIES ARE
RESPONDING IN THE SPEED WITH
WHICH THE DEPARTMENT IS ABLE TO
MAKE THIS INFORMATION AVAILABLE
HAS INCLUDE HAS IMPROVED
DRAMATICALLY. IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS I WOULD SAY AND SO I I I
THINK. I'M THE COMMISSION HAS
BEEN WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO
TO TRY TO MAKE IT CLEAR WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT.
IT'S IT'S A MANDATE UNDER THE
LAW BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT IF
THE COMMISSION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO. ESTABLISH THE SYSTEMS OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT ARE NECESSARY.
PART OF THE STRATEGY FOR THE
COMMISSION IS THAT IT'S LESS
ABOUT THE COMMISSION BEING ABLE
TO SORT OF PASS JUDGMENT ON THE
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF WHO OF WHAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING. AND MORE
CONSISTENT WITH THE DESIGN OF
REALIGNMENT BE ABLE TO ENABLE
THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND TO PARTICIPATE
SO THAT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO I THINK AS YOU SAID YOU SAW
ON THE AUDIT. AND DIRECTOR
KENNETH APSLEY RIDE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF FUNDS HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED IN HAVE BEEN SPENT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ALTHOUGH HAVING SAID THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND IN TWENTY HONOR TO
COURT NEARLY A QUARTER BILLION
DOLLARS UNSPENT FUNDS.
ANNA IS A LOT OF MONEY AND
THEY'RE SUCH TREMENDOUS
FRUSTRATION ON THE PART OF
PROVIDERS AND PART OF FAMILY
MEMBERS AND COMMUNITIES.
THE THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE NOT
BEING DEPLOYED IN WAYS THAT ARE
THAT ARE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE ACTUALLY SEE THIS IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTY
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY ANOTHER
COUNTIES WHERE WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING CALLS FROM COUNTY
SUPERVISORS WHO ARE ASKING US.
TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND ONE OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS.
THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR ANALYSIS
IS WIERD THE FUNDS BEING SPENT
AND WE'VE HEARD LOTS OF COMMENTS
ABOUT THAT WE WE WE ARE NOT IN
THE BEST POSITION TO REALLY.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION BUT WE'RE
FRUSTRATED AS WELL. THAT THE
INTENT OF THE IMAGE JUST SAY
VERY CLEARLY WAS PROVIDE MORE
FUNDS FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
TO ENSURE IMPROVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES THAT THE SERVICES ARE
OUTCOME ORIENTED RECOVERY
ORIENTED
THAT THEY'RE ENGAGING PEOPLE
WHERE THEY ARE AND AND THAT
THEIR DECEMBER DESIGNING
SERVICES THAT ARE PREVENTION
ORIENTED.
I THINK WE HAVE MADE A MAKING
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
BUT THERE'S AN EQUAL LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION.
THAT THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO AS
WELL.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALEJO NEW
ATTENDANT.
KIRSTEN BARLOW'S NEXT.
I HAVE A NUMBER OF COMMENTS
RELATED TO BOTH FEAR ISSUES IN
THE AGENDA RELATED TO COUNTY
REPORTING. AS WELL AS UNSPENT
FUNDS BUT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE PLANNING TO GO INTO THE
ACTUAL SET OF QUESTIONS OUR FOES
WERE JUST SORT OF A GUIDE FOR
CONVERSATION BOY WORLD IF YOU
WOULD PREFER TO ADDRESS ISLAND
AREA. AND I'M CERTAIN START
THERE SO ON THE ISSUE OF COUNTY
REPORTING I THINK.
A LOT OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
AND I THINK THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT AND SEE BE HDA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES UP WHO ARE DELIVERING
MINIMAL SERVICES ACT.
FUNDS ALONG WITH THEIR
PROVIDERS HAVE HAVE COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT THAT WE'VE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THERE HAD BEEN
DELAY IS NOT ONLY ON THE PART OF
COUNTY SUBMITTING THEIR REPORTS
BUT ALSO ON THE PART OF THE
STATE AND PROVIDING
INSTRUCTIONS.
AND FORMS FOR COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AYE WE HEAR THAT
THAT'S REALLY ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON REASONS AND I THINK EVEN
THE CHART THAT'S ON THE AGENDA
AROUND THE FISCAL YEAR SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN. ARI OURS REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURE REPORTS IS A GOOD
ILLUSTRATION OF THIS.
SO AS YOU NOTE IN YOUR AGENDA
EACH YEAR THE COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE TO THE STATE
A REVENUE AND EXPENDITURE
REPORT.
DESCRIBING WHAT THEIR PRIOR
YEAR AND EXPENDITURES WERE FOR
THEM IN A WHOLE SERVICES ACT.
AND THAT'S DUE TO THE STOCK TO
THE STATE BY THE DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF EACH YEAR.
AND WHILE THERE ARE CERTAINLY
STANDARD PIECES OF INFORMATION
AND THAT ARE COLLECTED IN
REPORTED EVERY SINGLE FISCAL
YEAR THE DEPARTMENT DOES.
AT TIMES TEND TO A REVISED ITS
INSTRUCTIONS ARE POTENTIALLY
REVISE THE FORM.
AND IN SOME CASES THAT DOES
RESULT IN DELAYS IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TED TO PROVIDE THOSE
INSTRUCTIONS TO COUNTIES AND IN
SOME CASES LIKE THIS PAST YEAR.
ERRORS WERE NOTED IN THE FORM
AND THEN AT AN UPDATED VERSION
WAS MADE AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES
IN JANUARY A MONTH AFTER THE
FORM IS ACTUALLY DUE TO THE
STATES THAT THERE IS SORT OF A.
A DOMINO EFFECT THAT HAPPENS IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND SEE BEACH TO
HAVE DISCUSSED THE POSSIBILITY
OF A SETTING UP.
SORT OF A DATE BY WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT AND US CAN WORK
TOGETHER IN ADVANCE ABOUT
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE DEADLINE TO
ENSURE THAT THE INSTRUCTIONS
FORMS AND ALL OF THAT. ARE
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES IN ENOUGH
TIME TO MAKE SURE WE CAN RELIEVE
ME ARE DEADLINE AS WELL.
AND THEN THE OTHER COMPLICATION
IS THAT.
AS WAS POINTED OUT BY DIRECTOR
CAN'T WE HAVE A VARIETY OF
FUNDING SOURCES MANY OF WHICH
ARE REQUIRED TO BE BLENDED
TOGETHER FOR EXAMPLE IN A WHOLE
SERVICES ACT. COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED TO MAXIMIZE THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THEY CAN DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL MATIC MEDICAID MATCHING
FUNDS WITH THOSE EXPENDITURES.
AND SO ONE OF THE CHICKEN AND
EGG THINGS THAT HAPPENS WITH OUR
REPORTING IS THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE MHSAA REPORT DUE DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST COUNTIES ALSO
SUBMIT A SEPARATE REPORT TO THE
STATE ABOUT THEIR MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH EXPENDITURES. AND WE
ACTUALLY USE A NUMBER OF THOSE
DATA POINTS TO COMPLETE THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
REPORT TO BE ABLE TO SHOW HOW
MUCH MHSAA IS BEING USED TO
DROUGHT ON FEDERAL DOLLARS SO.
AGAIN DELAYS IN EITHER OF THOSE
SETS OF INSTRUCTIONS OR CHANGES
THAT GET MADE FROM AND THE
COUNTIES TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. I REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURE REPORT IS IN FACT AN
AUDITABLE DOCUMENT AND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE COUNTY AUDITOR
CONTROLLER NOT EMPLOYEE OF THE
DEVELOP DEPARTMENT BUT THE
ACTUAL COUNTY AUDITOR
CONTROLLER.
MUST SIGNED UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY LA THAT THE INFORMATION
THEY'RE SUBMITTING TO THE STATE
IS TRUE AND FACTUAL TO THE BEST
OF THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND WHEN
THEY'RE ISSUES AROUND.
DEFINITIONS OF THE FORMS.
AND WHETHER THEY CAN ACCURATELY
PRESENT THE INFORMATION THEY
SOMETIMES ARE.
DELAYED AND AND BEING ABLE TO
ADD TO GET THE INFORMATION THEY
FEEL THEY NEED. AND I THINK IN
TERMS OF SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WE HAVE DISCUSSED THIS A BIT
WITH THE STATE.
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THE
MEDICAL SERVICES ACT WHEN
FIGURING OUT WAYS TO MAKE SURE
THE DOLLARS COULD BE. TRANCE.
TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC AND
TAXPAYERS.
THE COUNTIES HAVE LONG.
HOPED THAT THE COST REPORT THAT
I JUST DESCRIBED THAT WE FILL
OUT FOR MEDI CAL COULD IN SOME
WAY BE USED AS THE SAME
MECHANISM FOR REPORTING ABOUT
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
REVENUES BECAUSE. HAVING TO
REPORTS BE OUR HOPE THAT WE
COULD SEE
THOSE THINGS COMBINED.
ADDITIONALLY.
AND THE ORGAN IS A BY
ORGANIZATION CB HDA IS.
SPONSORING A BILL THIS YEAR S.
B. SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MORLOCK TO REQUIRE AT THE VERY
LEAST THAT THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT REPORT PLATFORMS.
BE BASED ON GAP GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES
I'M SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TRANSMIT THEM ELECTRONICALLY.
THAT THERE'S MORE CONSISTENCY
FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT ABOUT.
WHAT THE INSTRUCTIONS LOOK LIKE
AND HOW AND WHAT THE STAFF AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL ARE GOING TO
NEED TO COLLECT AND HOW BEST TO
REPORT THAT TO BE ACCURATE?
SO SO BE MY COMMENTS ON THE
REPORTING I HAVE SOME OTHER
THOUGHTS ABOUT THE UNSPENT FUNDS
ISSUE BUT CAN HOLD THOSE IN CASE
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT COMES UP
LATER DURING THE SCRIPT
ACTION. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ELIANA ON ISSUE TO.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TO FROM
HEALTH CARE'S.
I'M WELL I WILL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FINANCE EXPLAINED
THE APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
AUDIT.
.
IN SIMPLEST TERMS WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH WAS
AND DISBANDED.
TO IT WAS ESSENTIALLY CLEAVED
INTO TWO PARTS OF THE DAY.
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
WHICH IS RUNNING OUR STATE
MENTAL HOSPITALS AND THEN WE AS
A DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
ABSORBED ALL OF THE COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH.
COMPONENTS.
SO A LOT OF THE STAFF IN THE
PROGRAMMATIC.
RESPONSIBILITY PORTS WHICH
ACTUALLY TURNED OUT
TO BE A PRIOR YEAR APPROPRIATION
THAT REMAINED ON THE SCO'S
RECORDS.
AND SO THAT APPROPRIATION IT
DIDN'T HAVE ANY IMPACT TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WAS
DISPERSED.
COUNTIES OR THE STATE ADMIN.
THAT SOUND SPENT.
SO AND AND AND SINCE THE
FINDING YOU KNOW DATA FINANCE
AND THE DEPARTMENT HAVE WORKED
WITH THE SCO TO REMOVE IT FROM
THE RECORDS BUT. IT SIMPLY
WASN'T NOTHING MORE THAN WHY DID
WE MAKE THAT DECISION.
WHO?
WELL SO THAT CAN.
SO THIS GOES BACK A LONGER THAN
I HAVE BEEN OBVIOUSLY WORKED
KEEP BACK TO AT LEAST NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR NINETY FIVE WHEN THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS WERE
FIRST INITIALLY ESTABLISH SO.
TRADITIONALLY UMPS THIS.
STATE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM ON THE PHYSICAL
MEDICAL HEALTH SIDE THE COUNTIES
HAD SOME FUNDING.
REALIGNMENTS.
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENTS THERE'S
THE BRONZE AND MCCORQUODALE
ACTS.
WHERE THEY WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS AND THEN?
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WE SAW
OUR FIRST NINETEEN FIFTEEN
WAIVER TO ALLOW FOR THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS TO BOTH BE
CREATED AS WELL AS TO SERVE. ANY
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES THROUGH
THOSE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS.
IT IS A DIFFERENT.
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF THE COUNTIES
PUT UP THE NON FEDERAL SHARE OF
THE REVENUE IN ORDER TO DRAW
DOWN THE FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS
WHICH IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN HOW
THE REST OF MEDI CAL STATE RIGHT
NOW TO CALL.
BY AND LARGE YOU THE STATE
GENERAL FUND WITH SOME OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS BUT THE COUNTIES
ARE BOTH.
STATUTORILY AND NOW
CONSTITUTIONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
A SERIES OF SERVICES ESPECIALLY
BASED ON THE LAST REALIGNMENT
THAT WAS DONE TWENTY ELEVEN.
FOR.
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BOTH FROM THE ADULT AND
PEDIATRIC SIDE ON SUBSTANCE USE
DELIVERY.
DRUG COURTS
I'M GONNA GET ALL OF THE OTHER
BIG ITEMS BUT THOSE ARE THE BIG
TICKET ITEMS AND SO THERE IS
ESSENTIALLY A.
BOTH A FINANCIAL REVENUE STREAM
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO THE
COUNTIES AS WELL AS A CHANGE IN
THE CONSTITUTION THE KIND OF
PERMANENTLY. ENSHRINED THAT
COUNTY BASED COUNTY OPERATED
LOCALLY CONTROLLED AND SET OF
DELIVERY OF SERVICES SO.
IT HAS BEEN THAT WAY FOR.
MANY MANY YEARS AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE REALIGNMENT
DECISION THAT WAS.
FURTHER KIND OF FUN MADE MORE
PERMANENT.
I'D LIKE TO A FIGHT CAN SPEND A
BIT OF TIME REALLY DISCUSSING
FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT AND WHAT WE
BELIEVE THAT MEANS AS A STATE.
WHAT IS OUR ROLE IN INSURING
THAT THE COUNTIES HAVE
APPROPRIATED THESE FUNDS IN A
MEANINGFUL? EFFECTIVE WAY.
AND HOW ARE WE TRACKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S BEING DONE.
SURE SO I'LL TAKE A. STAB IN
THAN OTHERS CAN CHIME IN SO I
THINK THE.
AS THE AUDIT NOTED.
COUNTIES SO.
WE DON'T CLAIM NOR DO WE
AUTHORIZE SERVICES FOR MHSAA
RIGHT SO THE COUNTIES RECEIVE
MHSAA FUNDS DIRECTLY AND THEY
ARE THEN ALLOWED TO. CHANGE IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND CRACK.
WAS THAT IS THAT.
A CHANGE THAT HAS BENEFITED US
AS THE STATE TO ENSURE
OVERSIGHT.
OR IS THAT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO COME BACK IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE
FOUND WITH THIS ON IT LOVING I
WOULD SAY.
I THINK WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
WAS STILL.
OPERATIONAL NAM BEFORE IT WAS
DISSOLVED I THINK THAT WAS ONE
OF THE BIG FRUSTRATIONS OF A LOT
OF COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS FELT
WAS IN ORDER TO SPEND A MINT
MHSAA FUNDS. ALL OF THAT HAD TO
BE APPROVED FIRST BY THE
DEPARTMENT AND I THINK WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT.
WAS DISBANDED THAT WAS A
CHANGES REQUIRED VOTE OF TWO
THIRDS OF THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE IT AMENDED THE ACT I'M
LOOKING FOR. NODS TO MAKE SURE
THAT I'VE GOT MY FACTS STRAIGHT.
.
AND SO I THINK IF YOU ASKED.
BE THERE PROVIDERS ARE COUNTIES
THEY WOULD SAY IT ACTUALLY
HELPS.
BOTH SPEED THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES.
IT CERTAINLY I MADE SURE THAT
THE COUNTIES WERE GETTING FUNDS
IN A TIMELY WAY IN ORDER TO HELP
DELIVER SIR SERVICES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THEY STILL HAVE TO
GO THROUGH ALL OF THEIR LOCAL.
PLANNING AND.
KIND OF.
I LOCAL CONVERSATION IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THOSE FUNDS ARE SPENT IN
THE RIGHT WAY. THE BACK END
OVERSIGHT IS THAT WE WILL.
RECEIVE THOSE REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURE REPORTS.
AND YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE EXPENDING THE FUNDS BUT
FROM A YOU'D WE DON'T DO A CLAIM
BY CLAIM KIND OF AUDIT. OF EACH
OF THOSE AND COUNTLESS OVER THE
REVENUE AND.
REPORTS IF WE CAN CHECK IS THAT
THE REPORT THAT'S ON PAGE.
MAKE SURE I GET ENOUGH TENDO.
THIRTEEN OF OUR HAND OUT.
NO THE SERVICE SO THERE'S.
.
SO BET MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT ALLOCATE A SIGNIFICANT MOST
OF THE FUNDING GOES TO THE
COUNTIES FOR THE DELIVERY OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. THERE IS
A STATE ADMIN COMPONENT OF AN
HSA SO WE THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVE.
SOME OF THOSE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE DOLLARS THAT
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION RECEIVES
THE BULK OF THEM BUT THEN
THERE'S OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT
RECEIVE THEM MILITARY CDC ARE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW. I THINK THERE'S FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE MEDICAL
SERVICES ACT DOLLARS EITHER FOR
PROGRAMMATIC.
FUNCTIONS OR FOR THEIR ROLE IN.
EITHER OVERSEEN OR OTHERWISE
ADMINISTERING FUNDS UP WHEN I'M
LOOKING AT THIS THOUGH I'M
SEEING JANUARY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IS THERE AND JANUARY
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. REPORT
THAT'S DUE THERE IS A REPORT
THAT WE ARE HOPING TO FINALIZE
AND GET OUT CONSISTENT.
IF I'M NOT SURE FOR TRYING TO
GET OUT BEFORE OR IN LINE WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION.
THE REPORT WAS CERTAINLY
DELAYED THIS YEAR WHEN WE.
WERE TRYING TO GET IT RELEASE
WITH THE GENERAL BUDGET THERE
WAS.
.
SOME DELAYS IN CERTAIN PIECES OF
THE REPORT SO I'M WE GET
DIFFERENT PIECES OF DATA FROM
DIFFERENT ENTITIES AND SO THAT
JUST DELAYED THE OVERALL
COMPILATION OF THE REPORT BUT
WE'RE HOPING TO HAVE THAT
FINALLY SHORTLY IMMINENT PASS IT
OFF YOU KNOW. I'M SURE YOU CAN
SENSE THE FRUSTRATION FROM OUR
INABILITY TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
OVERSIGHT OF STATE
ADMINISTRATION FUNDS.
IF WE DON'T HAVE CURRENT DATA
THAT IS BEFORE US
AND IT'S DIFFICULT FOR US TO
INVOLVE THE PUBLIC. AND TO HEAR
THE TESTIMONY THAT'S NECESSARY
FOR THESE TYPES OF CHANGES IN
SUCH A SHORT WINDOW AND SO I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHY WE HAD
ESTABLISHED THE DATES FOR
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST. AND THIS
REPORTS TO BE IN JANUARY SO THAT
WE IS A LEGISLATURE COULD.
PROVIDE THAT MEANINGFUL
OVERSIGHT BUT WHAT WOULD MAKE
THINGS SIMPLER IT YES OF WE MAY
I THINK.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND.
OUR TIMING INTO YOURS.
BUT MY QUESTION IS THAT I
REMEMBER FROM LAST YEAR THEY
WERE DELAYED OUT AS WELL.
SO IS THIS A REGULAR OCCURRENCE
THAT THE REPORTS ARE NOT GOING
TO BE AVAILABLE ON TIME.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE REPORT WAS
THAT DELAYED LAST YEAR I WAS
DELAYED LAST YEAR I THINK THAT
WAS MY FIRST JOB EXPERIENCE WITH
THE OVERSIGHT.
YET SO HOME I THINK IT'S JUST
HARD BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION FROM SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS IN THAT HAVE A LOT
OF BACK AND FORTH VICTIMS ON THE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
IT ACCURATE IN THAT WE COMPILE
IT. SO THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
GOOD PRODUCT OF SOME FORWARD ON
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO MY INTO
IT AND I AM TRUMP I'M A WE HAD
AN OVERSIGHT O. OVER ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AND THE. THE COME.
THE COMPLAINT WAS THE SAME
ABOUT THE REPORTING AND WHO
CREATES THE REPORTING.
WHO FOR CREATES THE THE METHOD
OF RAPPER OF REPORT A WEEK
CREATED AND WE HAVE BEEN
REFINING A TEMPLATE THAT WE SEND
OUT TO ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES AND THEN MURDERED SO
THAT'S HOW MY PROBLEM WITH THIS
IS THAT WE CREATE? THE REPORTING
AND YET WE COMPLAIN THAT BECAUSE
THE PROCESS IS SO COMPLICATED
AND WE CREATE PROCESS.
YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING SO
YOU'RE ASKING THESE ENTITIES TO
REPORT.
IN X. WAY RIGHT.
BUT I JUST HAVE TO TELL US WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH THE FUNDS AND
SO I AM OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS GET A TEMPLATE THAT'S WHAT
WE JUST DEVELOPED. TO TRY TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR COUNT UP FOR
THE SLOT THE DIFFERENT STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO BE ABLE TO POP IN
THE THE INFORMATION OF ANY O
THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING TO DO A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH THERE'S
MORE OF A STANDARD TEMPLATE SO
THAT WE CAN JUST. GET THE
INFORMATION FROM THEM THAT WE
NEED AND THEN IT MORE EASILY
FITS INTO THAT TO THE FORMAT BUT
THIS IS THE CONVERSATION WE HAD
LAST YEAR IT'S EXACTLY THE SAME
CONVERSATION WE HAD LAST YEAR
ABOUT THE REPORTS THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO. TO STREAMLINE THE
REPORT PARTING PROCESS.
ECCENTRIC THAT ARE ACCEPT US
ALL THIS IS THE SECOND
CONVERSATION AND IN TWO YEARS
THAT WE'VE HAD OUR LAST YEAR IN
THE SAME YEAR ABOUT IT SOLD DO
YOU EXPECT.
OR CAN I ASK WHEN DO YOU EXPECT
THAT TO BE FINISHED AND WHEN.
IS AGAIN BE FINISHED SO THAT
NEXT YEAR WE WON'T HAVE THIS.
SEE MISSION.
WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
SOME FINAL EDITS THAT WE YEAR
HOPING TO GET APPROVED AND
FINALLY AS I WOULD SAY IT'S
PROBABLY FOR THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISIONS ARE PROBABLY IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
.
AND SO YES I MEAN WE HAVE.
ALSO CHANGE THE DEADLINES BY
WHICH OTHER DEPARTMENTS HAVE TO
GET US INFORMATION SO THAT WE
CAN COMPILERS SOONER AN EFFORT
TO MAKE IT. TIMELY WITH
CONSISTENT WITH THE RELEASE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S THEN THEN THE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION THEN IS HOW
ARE WE REPORTING THIS
INFORMATION IF IT STATE IF IT
TAKES TOO LONG. I YOU KNOW THE
ONLY REFERENCE I HAVE IS TO
WRITE MY TEACHING AND WE HAVE
ONLINE OUR REPORT CARD SO WHEN I
HAVE TO SUBMIT REPORT CARDS. AYE
EACH TEACHER GETS ON THE SAME.
SYSTEM WE ALL DO OUR REPORT
CARDS WE HAVE A DEADLINE AND BY
THAT DATE.
EVERYTHING'S COMPILED SO THAT
ONE PERSON IN THIS CASE THE
PRINCIPLE HAS ALL OF THE THE
REPORTS HOW ARE THESE ALL MANUAL
ARE THESE ALL. OF. THEIR
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENTS
REPORTING ON WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WITH THE FARMS AND SO SOME OF
THEM WILL SAY OH WELL YOU KNOW.
WE WERE WAITING FOR THIS
ADDITIONAL PIECE OF INFORMATION
TO COME IN SO THAT WE CAN GET
THIS TO YOU AND THEN YOU'LL HAVE
THE MORE IN MOST UPDATED
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
YOU FOR THIS YEAR'S UPDATE. AND
SO WON'T WILL SET ME OFF MY BACK
AND FORTH NEGOTIATION TRYING TO
GET THAT INFORMATION FROM THEM I
FUTURE SAW IN HIM AND HE DIDN'T
KNOW THAT YEAH AND DROPPED IT
YEAH IN TEACHING THERE IS NO
NEGOTIATION ON REPORT CARDS. UP
THE REPORT ARE TO ARGUE ON THAT
DAY. AND I HAVE TO HAVE ALL MY
DATA CORRECT I HAVE TO HAVE ALL
MY ASSESSMENTS DONE SO THAT I
WHEN I GET ONLINE AND REPORT
THERE IS NO NEGOTIATION ABOUT
WHAT EVERYONE CAN.
THE TWINS FROM READ IT FROM ME
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE TIME FRAMES
ARE THAT THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S
ARE GONNA HAVE TO SUBMIT
INFORMATION TO US BY WHEN WILL
HAPPILY SHARE THE TEMPLATE.
AND THEN WILL BE TRACKING TO
THAT.
FOR DEVELOPMENT AND RELEASE
CONCERT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET EDUCATE AND SO WHEN CAN I
EXPECT THAT.
.
REMEMBER NEGOTIATION ON THE DATE
IF YOU GIVE ME A DATE THAT'S
WHEN I EXPECT THE DATE THE
INFORMATION TO BE TURNED.
I MEAN WE CAN SIMPLY YEAH IF CAN
GIVE IT TO IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS.
OKAY SO BY THE END OF APRIL.
OFF BETTER YET I'LL FIND YOU A
DATE LIKE I GUESS.
.
I JUST WONDER IS THERE.
HOW TO PUT TEETH IN?
THIS COULD GET ME NO PUN
INTENDED OBVIOUSLY BUT.
OF HOW HE PUT HAD HOW DO YOU PUT
TEETH INTO GET.
YOUR OWN STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS TO ACTUALLY DO THIS
I MEAN WHY WHY IS IT WHY IS IT
SO DIFFICULT AGUIAR CURRY
DEBATE.
I DON'T AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT WHERE YOU KNOW I THINK.
MINUTES A COUPLE THINGS
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE I THINK.
.
WE DON'T NEED.
NECESSARILY ANY KIND OF
STATUTORY AUTHORITY WE'D YOU
KNOW IT'S MORE ABOUT CONSISTENT.
BOTH FEEDBACK AND JUST GOOD
PERSONAL COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS RIGHT THEN WE HAVE
STAFF AND OUR DEPARTMENT THAT
HAVE. LONG STANDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND THEY KNOW WHO TO
CALL AND SOMETIMES IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF DISPUTE OF PICKING UP
THE PHONE OR. YOU KNOW SETTING
UP A MEETING TO SAY WHAT ARE YOU
STRUGGLING WITH TO GET.
CAN WE UNDERSTAND WHY.
AND SO I DON'T THINK IT'S YOU
KNOW I THINK A LOT OF TIMES I AM
WE ALL ARE WORKING
INTO GETTING THIS INFORMATION
AND SO IT WORKS THE OTHER WAY AS
WELL. YOU SAY YOU DON'T NEED IT
BUT IF WE DON'T GET THE
INFORMATION IN THE QUICK ENOUGH
TIMELY FASHION THEN WORK WERE
FORCED TO PUT IT IN STATUTES
SOME SOME WAY SOMEHOW. SO THAT
WE GET THE INFORMATION AND THEN
THERE'S THIS BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT WHY YOU SHOULD AND WHY YOU
SHOULD AND AND ALL OF THAT AND
SOUL. SO I'M AGAIN THE
FRUSTRATION IS THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE RESPONSES THAT WE WE
ARE ASKING AND AGAIN.
FOR US AND AS A DOCTOR ARAMBULA
STATED IS HOW DO WE PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT WHEN WE'RE NOT GETTING
THE DATA AND SO IT'S STARTING TO
FEEL AND YOU KNOW AND I'M NOT
I'M PUTTING IT OUT THERE. IS
STARTING TO FEEL LIKE THESE ARE
STALLED TYPE TACTICS JUST SO
THAT THERE IS NO OVERSIGHT AND I
WHEN WHEN THAT FEELING.
.
A INCREASES THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE
GONNA STATUTORY.
REQUIREMENTS OR AT LEAST IN OUR
PART ATTEMPTING TO GET THE
INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S NOT
BEING PROVIDED THE THE YOU KNOW
COLLABORATIVE WAY RIGHT AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR FRUSTRATION AND.
CERTAINLY APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
AND WE WILL.
GET THAT INFORMATION TO YOU ON
THE TWENTY THIRD AND THEN.
IF WE CAN RELEASE THE REPORT AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WOULD BE.
GOOD AS WELL.
SO MAYBE I'LL JUST TAKE A STEP
BACK BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS AND
COMPARING A LITTLE BIT OF APPLES
AND ORANGES HERE AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE I.
GET FROM THE DEPARTMENT. WHAT IS
OUR APPROPRIATE FISCAL OVERSIGHT
AS A STATE WHAT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
EFFECT?
GREAT SO.
AND I WILL CERTAINLY.
ALSO ASK FOR BOTH THE
COMMISSION AND.
COUNTIES TO CHIME IN.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE RECENTLY BEEN
SHARING.
AND IT WAS INCLUDED IN YOUR
REPORT.
THE FILING OF THE ARE YOU ARE
SO THEY REVENUE AND EXPENDITURE
REPORTS BY COUNTY WHEN THEY WERE
SUBMITTED WHEN THEY WERE
FINALIZED. ON IN SOME CASES THAT
WAS.
IT YEAH OUR WEIGHT BOTH PROVIDE
SOME GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
WHICH COUNTIES HAD BEEN EITHER
PROVIDING ARE NOT PROVIDING THE
REPORTS WE CERTAINLY.
CAN ALSO APPRECIATE.
AS.
.
AS BOTH TOBY AND AKERSON SAID.
THE COUNTIES HAVE THREE YEARS TO
EXPAND THESE.
REVENUES AND SO SOMETIMES I
THINK THERE'S.
A HESITANCY TO.
LEAP TOOK CERTAIN CONCLUSIONS
LIKE AL YOU'VE GOT ALL THESE
RESERVES AND YOU HAVEN'T USED
THEM WHEN THEY HAVE ACTUALLY
THREE YEARS TO USE THOSE FUNDS
AND SO I THINK.
WE ALSO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN WE PROVIDE DATA.
EITHER TO YOU OR POST THE
REPORTS ONLINE THAT PEOPLE CAN
APPRECIATE THAT THE COUNTIES
DON'T HAVE TO USE THEM IN THE
YEAR IN WHICH THEY RECEIVE THOSE
FUNDS OR THEY CAN BE USING THEM
FOR LONGER TERM INITIATIVES.
BUT I THINK.
SO PART OF IT HAS BEEN A LITTLE
BIT GREATER TRANSPARENCY ON HOW
THE.
ARE YOURS HAVE BEEN FILED BUT
ALSO WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WORK WITH.
.
THERE'S AYE OUTSIDE VENDOR THAT
WORKS WITH THE COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO
THAT AREAS WHERE THEY'RE
STRUGGLING TO USE THE FUNDS ARE
LARGELY CONTAINED TO THE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND. PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION FUNDS AS WELL
AS INNOVATION FUNDS SUCH A
SMALLER SUBSET OF THE LARGER ON
EMERGENCY ALLOCATION.
I THINK A LOT OF US HAVE
THOUGHTS AS TO WHY THOSE FUNDS
ARE EITHER HARDER TO SPEND OR
WHY AND THEY HAVE BEEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE COUNTIES TO
SPEND AND SO I THINK. YOU'LL
HEAR FROM US A LOT OF INTEREST
IN WORKING CLOSELY WITH AND
COUNTIES TO HELP.
EITHER THINK OF IDEAS AROUND
HOW THAT.
MONEY CAN BE SPENT BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT IT IS AS.
TOBY SAID DELIVERING ON
THE PROMISE IN THE INTENT OF THE
INITIATIVE WHICH WAS IT WAS A
LOCALLY BASED LOCALLY DESIGNED
USE OF THOSE FUNDS TO BEST
TARGET. NEEDS AND LOCAL AREAS
AND SO YOU KNOW I'LL DEFER IF
THERE'S OTHER THOUGHTS ON THAT.
MY UNDERSTANDING TO OBVIOUSLY
YOUR PREVIOUS TESTIMONY WHERE
THERE WERE FIVE CORE METRICS
THAT WERE NEEDING TO BE.
FOLLOWED AND I'M WONDERING IF WE
HAVE ANY DATA OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO SHOW US HOW WE
ARE AS A STATE OR DO.
M. CAN I COMMENT ON THE FISCAL
OVERSIGHT RIGHT THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW THE THE COMMISSION
EXISTS AS A COMPONENT OF THE MEN
HOW SERVICES ACT
AND I THINK THERE'S SAID.
.
AND WHEN THE PUBLIC AUTHORIZES A
TAX INCREASE
TO THE EXTENT THAT PROP FIFTY
THREE WAS DONE TO AN INITIATIVE.
THERE'S AN EXPECTATION
THAT THE MONEY WOULD BE WELL
SPENT AND AND SO YOU KNOW PART
OF THE REASON WHY IT IF YOU SORT
OF YOU KNOW TALK TO CONSULTANT
TO THIS WORK. PART OF THE REASON
WHY WHEN YOU PUT IT A BALLOT
MEASURE OUT THERE FOR TAX
INCREASE THAT THEY INCLUDE AN
ENTITY LIKE THIS.
IS BECAUSE THERE'S.
PEOPLE ARE ARE TRUSTING THAT THE
MONEY THAT IS RAISED RIGHT.
WILL WILL GO TOWARDS THE REASONS
THAT PEOPLE ARE AGREEING TO TAX
THEMSELVES RIGHT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT PEOPLE ARE DOING.
THAT IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING WHEN
PEOPLE ARE SAYING ADDITIONAL
MONEY COMING IN BUT IT BUT NEEDS
NOT BEING MET PARTICULARLY IN
TERMS OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION
RIDE AND AND THERE'S THIS
DISCONNECT.
BETWEEN PEOPLE'S UNDERSTANDING
OF THE FISCAL REALITY OF GROWTH
IN SPENDING.
AND INCREASES AN UNMET NEEDS AND
SO I THINK THAT.
THE STATE HAS LONG HAD A AN
OVERSIGHT ROLE EVEN UNDER
REALIGNMENT NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT CAME WITH A
COMMITMENT FOR THE STATE TO
DEVELOP PERFORMANCE METRICS.
RIGHT AND SO THERE WAS THIS
ARRANGEMENT WHERE THE COUNTIES
WOULD WOULD HAVE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS THE DESIGN
OF THEIR SYSTEM.
IN EXCHANGE FOR A HIGHER LEVEL
OF OUTCOME REPORTING
AND I THINK WE'VE STRUGGLED
HISTORICALLY IT'S NOT EASY TO
DO.
FOR IN THE FIRST PLACE RIGHT
THERE HAS THERE HAVE BEEN LOTS
OF ATTEMPTS AND IT IN INCLUDING
LEGISLATION THAT YOU HAVE
AUTHORED MISTER CHAIR.
AND I THINK THAT THAT THE STATE
HAS LONG HELD THIS ROLE WHEN
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN IMAGES SAY
DOLLARS ACCRUED IN THE STATE
FUND. AND THE STATE ALLOCATED
THEM BASED ON COUNTY PLANS AND
AN OVERSIGHT WAS.
YEAH SORT OF IMPLEMENTED THROUGH
THAT PLAN REVIEW STAGE RIGHT.
BUT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO IS
SHIFT THAT TO DO OVERSIGHT IN
TERMS OF.
AND MORE TRANSPARENCY MORE
UNDERSTANDING BUT ALSO THE
OUTCOMES AND AND I WAS
REFERENCING ANOTHER UNDER THAT
PREVENTION INTERVENTION
COMPONENT THERE ARE SEVEN
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO BE REDUCED AND SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING.
TO A WE HAVE A VIDEO SCREEN WITH
THE EIGHT CS WE HAVE A DATA YOU
SCREW THE PARTNER JUSTICE WERE
WORKING TO LINK THOSE DATA SETS
SO WE CAN. TRACK AND
INCARCERATION RATES ONE OF THE
GOALS OF OF PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTIONS TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FOLKS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS WHO WERE JAILED.
.
THAT WORK HAS BEEN DONE FOR IN
OTHER PLACES FOR OVER A DECADE
ITS NOT EASY TO DO THE DATA AT
THE DOJ ISN'T ALWAYS YOU KNOW
IT'S IT CAN BE HARD TO MATCH
USING AND ABUSING PROBABILISTIC
MATCHING.
WE'RE WORKING TO DO THAT WITH CD
ON EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE GOALS
OF THE ACT IS TO IS TO USE MEN
HOW STRATEGIES TO REDUCE SCHOOL
FAILURE.
THAT'S AN AREA THAT'S VERY
CHALLENGING A WEEK WE'VE SEEN A
LONG HISTORY OF OF COMPETITION
BETWEEN COUNTIES AND SCHOOLS
OVER SCARCE RESOURCES WHO PAYS
SO TO SPEAK.
AND SO PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH COMMISSION IS TRYING
TO DO IS TO MEET THAT PUBLIC
OBLIGATION. OF OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BY MAKING IT
EASIER FOR EVERYBODY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE MONEY'S
COMING FROM WHERE IT'S GOING HOW
IT'S BEING USED.
AND WHAT THE PUBLIC IS GETTING
FOR ITS YOU KNOW HOW MUCH BANG
FOR THE BUCK ARE YOU GETTING.
THAT THE MORE DIFFICULT PIECE
BUT THIS IS OFTEN MORE IMPORTANT
PIECE IS TO THAN HELP YOU AS
POLICY MAKERS AND HELP THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO ON THE POLICY
SIDE IN THE COUNTIES AS THE
FOLKS WHO ARE RUNNING SYSTEMS.
TO UNDERSTAND THE TRADE OFFS.
THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS CAN CREATE IN TERMS
OF HOW WE APPROACH DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES AND SO YOU KNOW YOU
GOT IN YOUR PACKET SOME
QUESTIONS PRESS ABOUT INNOVATION
INCUBATOR OUTLET TO GET TO. BUT
PART OF THAT WORK IS TO REALLY
PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO STRENGTHEN THAT OVERALL
STRATEGY AROUND USING DATA TO
MAKE BETTER DECISIONS ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE NOW WHERE
WE NEED TO BE HEADED WHAT'S
WORKING AND FOR WHOM AND THAT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT POINT.
BECAUSE YOU CAN HAVE EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS THAT WORK IN
CERTAIN ENVIRONMENTS FOR CERTAIN
PEOPLE THAT JUST DON'T WORK FOR
OTHER PEOPLE IN OTHER
ENVIRONMENTS AND QUITE OFTEN
THAT NO ONE GETS LOST IN THE
SORT OF BROADER. HIGH LEVEL KIND
OF ANNOUNCES BUT I THINK THE THE
POINT IS WELL TAKEN MISTER CHAIR
THAT THE STATE HAS AN ONGOING
OBLIGATION.
TO FOR A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND THE AROUND
THE FUNDS
I THINK WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS IN
THAT AREA CLEARLY THE REPORTING
IS IS AN ESSENTIAL ELEMENT YOU
CAN'T DO YOUR JOB WE CAN'T DO
OUR JOB. IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE.
AND.
AND QUITE WELL SAID A MEAN ONE
SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL FOR A STATE
THE SIZE OF CALIFORNIA NOR DO I
THINK WORK TRYING TO. DICTATE TO
REACH IN AND EACH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY WHAT.
NEEDS THEY HAVE WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITY BUT.
I THINK WE AS A STATE SHOULD SET
UP SOME FRAMEWORK TO AT LEAST
DESCRIBED.
HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT
IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH IS BEING
KEPT IN RESERVES?
AND SO MY NEXT SET OF QUESTIONS
IF I CAN IS.
WHAT IS A PRUDENT RESERVE IS
THERE A CAP ON THE SIZE OF A
RESERVE THAT A? COUNTY SHOULD BE
HOLDING ON TO AND HOW DO YOU
MAKE THOSE TYPES OF
DETERMINATIONS.
I KNOW THAT.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGED IN THE AUDIT AND.
IN THE FISCAL REGULATIONS THAT
WERE.
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER DEVELOP
WITH OUR DEPARTMENT ANYWHERE
ADDRESSING A COUPLE DIFFERENT
THINGS I'M PRUDENT RESERVE AS
WELL AS THE USE OF INTEREST SO
IF YOU DO HAVE FUNDS AGAIN IF.
IF YOU'RE ALLOWED THREE YEARS
TO EXPAND THOSE FUNDS OBVIOUSLY
INTEREST ACCRUES ON. ON THAT.
I THINK WE'VE SAID THAT.
WE KIND OF ARE SETTING IN THE
REGULATIONS WHAT WE CONSIDER TO
BE A PRUDENT RESERVE AND
UNDERSTANDING.
COUNTY SOMETIMES HAVE THESE
RESERVES BECAUSE AS WE ARE
SETTLING NOW AND THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I'LL I'LL GET BACK TO
THIS BRAIDED FUNDING. IS WHEN
WE'RE IN.
AND A COUNTY AND WE'RE DOING AT
COSTS RECONCILIATION ON THEIR
EXPENDITURES FOR MEDI CAL AND WE
WILL LOOK AT A CLAIM AND SAY.
THAT WAS AN ALLOWABLE
EXPENDITURE FOR MEDI CAL FUNDING
THE COUNTY CAN.
CANCEL THAT CLAIM WITH US AND
HAY THAT WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING AND SO
SOMETIMES THAT'S WHAT THE
RESERVE IS USE FOR TO KNOW THAT
THE COUNTIES OF CERTAINLY.
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDS THAT WHEN WE GO
BACK AND DO THOSE COSTS
RECONCILIATIONS THAT THEY HAVE
THAT IN PLACE AND SO. THE
REGULATIONS AND I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE NUMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD BUT THERE'S A. THERE WILL
BE VERY CLEAR KIND OF
PERCENTAGES OF WHAT WE EXPECT
COUNTIES TO HAVE TO HOLD ITS
PRUDENT RESERVES AND ANYTHING
AFTER THAT WOULD BE DEEMED TO
PROBABLY ACCESS.
WE'RE GONNA RUBIO YES JUST.
HOW MUCH OF A COOK SO WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT PERCENTAGES HOW
MUCH MONEY IS?
GIVEN TO COUNTIES HOW MUCH MORE
MONEY DO WE HAVE IN RESERVE AND.
YEAH LET'S START WITH THOSE.
SO LAST YEAR CHRIS COOK A
FINANCE A LAST YEAR THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION THAT WAS ALLOCATED THE
COUNTIES.
FOR THE.
SURE OKAY FOR ITS OIL WOULD THAT
BE CAN I ASSUME THAT THAT WAS
EVERY YEAR. THAT THE PHENOMENA
REVENUE HAS BEEN INCREASING.
ANYWHERE HELPS UP YEAH I DON'T
HAVE THE HIGHEST OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS YEAH OK YEAHIT'S
IT'S PEGGED TO CAPITAL GAINS. SO
DEPENDING ON HOW WELL OUR
ECONOMY IS DOING THAT TAX
REVENUE FLUCTUATES GREATLY. I'M
SO THEN THERE'S A METHODOLOGY
THAT.
FINANCE WORKS THROUGH AND EACH
COUNTY GETS A CERTAIN ALLOCATION
AND THEN IT'S BUCKET INTO THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS THAT P. AND I
WHICH IS THE. PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION INNOVATION FUNDS
AND THEN THEY'RE GIVEN THREE
YEARS TO EXPAND THOSE FUNDS AND
SO EACH COUNTY HAS ITS OWN.
EITHER RESERVE OR THERE ARE
FUNDS THAT ARE WITHIN THOSE
COUNTY ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO PERVERSION WHICH IS
THE OTHER HIGH POINT OF THE
AUDIT WHICH WAS HOW LONG THEY
HAD BEEN SITTING ON THOSE FUNDS
OR HOW MUCH MONEY DO WE HAVE AN
RETURNS.
I THINK WE HAVE.
AB ONE FOURTEEN AND THE
CALCULATIONS THAT WE HAD HAD
APPROXIMATE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE MILLION THAT WAS
SUBJECT TO REVERSION.
I'M NOT TO RIVERS AND.
I'M TALKING ABOUT RESERVES
LITTLE SO.
STRUCTURE CAN SAYS IT'S
YOU KNOW UP UNTIL LAST YEAR LAST
YEAR THERE WAS A RIVER OR A
CHANGE IN THE LAW FOR SMALL
COUNTIES BUT GENERALLY IT'S
THREE YEARS TO USE THE MONEY I
LISTEN.
FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND I
WAS NOT PART OF THE FOLKS
ATTRACTED THIS BUT CLEARLY WAS
HELP MAKE THE CASE FOR THAT AND
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
REVENUES.
THE IDEA WAS THAT IT COUNTIES
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO SPEND ALL THE
MONEY IN THE FIRST YEAR REMEMBER
SOME OF THE MONEY COMES IN IN
THE ELEVENTH MONTH. OR THE
TWELFTH MONTH OF THE FISCAL YEAR
AND SO THERE'S A AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU MAY NOT
BILL TO SPEND YOUR ENTIRE APRIL
PAYCHECK BY THE END OF APRIL.
SO SOME OF THAT YOU SPEND IN MAY
OR JUNE.
BUT THE THE IDEA WAS NOT THAT
YOU COULD SIT ON THE MONEY FOR
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND THEN
ONLY BEGIN TO USE IT IN THE
THIRD YEAR.
WHEN WE'VE LOOKED AT A SAMPLE
OF COUNTIES WE SEE SOME COUNTIES
WELL TO MAKE IT BACK TO THE TO
PRESERVE PEACE. SO THE COUNTIES
ARE ALLOWED TO PUT FUNDS INTO A
PRUDENT RESERVE TO RAINY DAY
FUND A LOCK BOX THE MONEY GOES
THERE. AND THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
SHIFT UP TO TWENTY PERCENT OF
THEIR OF US WHAT'S CALLED A CSS
COMPONENT INTO THAT PRETTY
RESERVE IF THEY DO THAT IT'S NOT
SUBJECT TO REVERSION.
IT REALLY IS A RAINY DAY FUND
AND IT'S IN A LOCK BOX WERE IN
AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ESTABLISHES
PARAMETERS UNDER WHICH THIS FUND
CAN BE ACCESSED OKAY NOW ARMED
MAN IF I CAN FIND ME. SO TWENTY
PERCENT BUT THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
KEEP THE MONEY FOR.
FOR THREE YEARS SO I'M ASSUMING
TWENTY PERCENT WERE YOUR ONE
TWENTY PRESENT YOUR TWO OR TOTAL
TWENTY PERCENT FOR THE THREE
YEAR EACH YEAR EACH SONG. OKAY
BUT WHILE THAT'S RIGHT IN OTHER
WORDS THERE'S THERE'S THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR COUNTIES THAT
THAT CAN SHIFT THERE'S ACTUALLY
A LIMIT ON HOW MUCH THEY CAN
SHIFT OUR RIGHT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO SHIFT ANY BUT IF THEY WANT TO
PUT INTO A RAINY DAY FUND. FOR
DOWNTURNS IN THE ECONOMY THAT'S
FOR THE PRINT RESERVES FOR THE
RIVERS AND RULES DON'T APPLY TO
RIGHT NOW SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT JUST SO THAT THAT SO THAT
I'M CLEAR ON ON THE TWENTY
PERCENT I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE. RIVERS AND.
MONEY I'M ASKING ABOUT THE
RAINY DAY SOUL.
IN THREE YEARS LET'S ASSUME AND
I'M JUST IN GENERAL LET'S USE
THE BILLION DOLLARS.
AS AS A AS A BANE RESERVE OR
THERE'S HIGH HIGH
LEVEL OF VARIATION IT'S THE
OTHER THE OTHER RESERVE THAT YOU
SHOULD THINK ABOUT OF THE FUNDS
THAT AREN'T IN THE PRUDENT
RESERVE THAT JUST AREN'T BEING
SPENT.
THEY'RE BEING HELD FOR CASH FLOW
PURPOSES OVER THAT THREE YEAR
PERIOD AND AND SO WE WE SEE
VARIATION OF SOME COUNTIES THAT
ARE KEEPING MAYBE SIX MONTHS OF
CASH ON HAND. IT REALLY IS
CHECKS ARE COMING IN AND CHECKS
ARE GOING OUT IN THE SKY KEEPING
AT A RUNNING BALANCE HERE WE SEE
OTHER COUNTIES. THAT ARE SITTING
ON TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
REVENUES IN THEIR ONLY BEGINNING
TO SPEND IT IN THE SECOND HALF
OF THE THIRD YEAR. THAT'S NOT
THE PRUDENT RESERVE RIGHT THAT'S
IN THE MEANTIME IT IT ISN'T
THERE A NEED. RIGHT I WAS OUT IN
THE EARLY AND IN THE MEANTIME
UNTIL THAT'S THE PART YEAH
PARTICULARLY IN PARTICULAR
SUDDEN COMMUNITIES WHO ARE VERY
CONSERVATIVE AS THEY LOOK AT
PROJECTIONS AND I KNOW. THE
ISSUE OF RAINY DAY FUND IS
CONTROVERSIAL EVEN IN THIS
BUILDING ABOUT WHETHER WE SPEND
WHEN WE HAVE THE REVENUES OR
WHETHER WE TAKE A LONG RANGE.
PLANNING APPROACH IN PHILIP THE
PIGGY BANK I THINK THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION DOES HAPPEN IN EACH
COUNTY ABOUT HOW CONSERVATIVES
ARE GOING TO WANT TO BE. HOWEVER
I THINK THAT IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND WE DO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS REGULATIONS UNDER
WAY THIS VERY SPECIFIC IDEAS
ABOUT WHAT WHAT DOES NOT TO
INCLUDE BUT. RATHER THAN LOOK AT
THE IDEA OF A RESERVE FOR A
RAINY DAY NEEDING TO REACH.
AT LEAST A CERTAIN LEVEL WE
ACTUALLY THINK IT SHOULD BE
FLIPPED AND IN FACT THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A MAXIMUM FIVE AMOUNT
OF A PRUDENT RESERVE SO THAT IN
FACT BECAUSE YOU HAVE NEEDS IN
THE COMMUNITY. YEAR YOU'RE
PROHIBITED REALLY FROM
ACCUMULATING MORE REVENUES THAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN
YOUR OPERATION SAY FOR SIX
MONTHS.
AND THAT THAT WE WOULD BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SOMETHING THAT
WOULD PLACE SEVEN POUND CEILING
RATHER THAN A FLOOR. AT YOUR
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN PROGRAMMING
AND HAVE YOU KNOW THAT CRITICAL
SERVICES CONTINUE IF THERE IS OF
A DIP IN THE REVENUE IN THERE
ARE IN FACT VERY VOLATILE YEARS
I THINK FINANCE COULD ATTEST TO
THIS THERE HAVE BEEN YEARS IN
WHICH. THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE HAS
STEPPED TO HIS MUCH AS THIRTY
NINE PERCENT BELOW WHAT IT WAS
THE PRIOR YEAR SO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SCARE.
GOVERNMENT AND AND WE DO WANT
TO BE PREPARED FOR THOSE THINGS
BUT WE DO FULLY AGREE THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE THE ABILITY
TO ANSWER TO LOCAL.
SITUATIONS WHERE PERHAPS
REVENUES IN OTHER AREAS DROPS OR
YOUR COMMUNITY EXTREMELY
IMPACTED BY HOMELESS BUT EVEN
USING YOUR EXAMPLE OF A THIRTY
NINE PERCENT DECREASE WHICH WAS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT WE'VE SEEN
IN ANY ONE YEAR. THAT DOESN'T
EXPLAIN HOLDING TWO AND A HALF
YEARS WORTH OF FUNDS.
IN RESERVE WHEN THERE IS AS MUCH
NEED AS WE HAVE AND WE WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT AND SO WE WE
AGREE THERE IS A NEED FOR A
STATEWIDE STANDARD. THAT
CLARIFIES WHAT THE PURPOSE OF A
RESERVIST BECAUSE THE ACT
ACTUALLY HAS THREE DIFFERENT
DESCRIPTIONS OF WHAT THE
RESERVISTS FLOOR AND WHEN YOU
CAN USE IT WE NEED TO CLEAN
THOSE THINGS THAT. WE ALSO NEED
TO CLARIFY REALLY WHAT'S
REASONABLE WHAT CAN PASS THE
SMELL TEST BETWEEN WE WANT TO
HAVE LONG RANGE PLANNING WE
DON'T WANT TO PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER CRITICAL SERVICES.
HOWEVER AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO A MASS DOLLARS
THAT COULD BE USED FOR VERY
CRITICAL NEED MY PROBLEM WITH
THIS IS WHERE THE MENTAL HEALTH.
A. ISSUES IS IN THAT UP A CRISIS
MODE IT'S NOT LIKE OH YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A FEW PEOPLE HERE IT'S.
SO WE HAVE A CRISIS IN OUR HANDS
AT SOME POINT WHERE DOES LIKE A
REGULAR PERSON SATAN YOU KNOW
WHAT.
YES I A LONG TERM PLANNING BUT
LOOK AT THE CRISIS WE HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE ORANGE COUNTY WHERE I AM
IN MY COUNTY WHERE WE'RE HAVING
A CRISIS OF MENTAL HEALTH. A.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO CALL
IT OF OF FOLKS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AT WHAT POINT DOES
A REGULAR PERSON GOAL. I GET ALL
OF THAT BUT LOOK AT THE CRISIS
AND LET'S.
TRY TO.
I'M FRUSTRATED I'M FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT CARS THAT WERE
BUILDING IT'S PEOPLE'S LIVES
THAT WERE PLAYING WITH AND AND
IF WE'RE NOT PUTTING THAT MONEY
IN THOSE SERVICES WERE AFFECTING
NOT JUST THAT PERSON'S LIFE BUT
THEIR FAMILIES. BUT COUNTIES THE
CITIES AND WE SIT BACK AND GOAL
PULL MY GOT BACK CRISIS OF THAT
HAPPENING IN ORANGE COUNTY POOR
PEOPLE BY YEAR WERE SITTING ON.
A OF MONEY THAT COULD BE USED
FOR THAT FOR THAT AND I THINK
IT'S IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REALLY THINK THROUGH THE
DIFFERENCES AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S EASY. WE'VE SEEN A COUPLE
OF NEWS STORIES TALK ABOUT
COUNTIES ARE SITTING ON MONEY I
THINK WERE WE TO LOOK AT OUR OWN
STATE BUDGET YOU COULD WRITE THE
SAME HEADLINE IF WE WANTED TO
YOU KNOW PICK APART THE VALIDITY
OF HAVING A RAINY DAY FUND. THAT
WERE SITTING ON MONEY AND YET WE
HAVE NEEDS IN OUR STATE I THINK
WE DO NEED TO DEFINITELY CLEAR
UP WHAT A REASONABLE PRINT
RESERVE WOULD BE. WHETHER WE
SHOULD HAVE ONE ABOUT AYE NOT
JUST OUR LITTLE BUT IT'S NOT
JUST THE RESERVE YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S TO DO RIGHT SHUT THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
COUNTIES WITH THIS UNSPENT MONEY
I THINK I. TOBY MENTIONED.
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WERE KIND OF PILED UP
BECAUSE THE STATE DEPARTMENT A
MENTAL HEALTH FOLLOWED BY D. H.
CS DID NOT. ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
STATUTE WHICH WAS THAT TO THE
EXTENT COUNTIES COULDN'T SPEND
TIMELY THOSE DOLLARS WOULD GET
REVERTED THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. SO
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE ON IN
COLLABORATION WITH COUNTIES AND
OTHERS WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH
A ONE TIME MECHANISM TO LOOK
HERE INVEST THOSE GOD IS IN THAT
WERE WET. WE GET UP WITH IT HE
LEARN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING THAT PEACE AND
HOPEFULLY GOING FORWARD WE DON'T
WIND UP HAVING THE SAME
CONVERSATION AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE
OASES CHO TO FINISH ITS WORK
THAT IT STARTED A YEAR SO AGO.
I'M TO LOOK AT THE INNOVATION
GUIDELINES THOSE JUST GOT
PUBLISHED IN REGULATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN SO WE'VE HAD JUST NOW A
NEW SET OF REQUIREMENTS TO BEGIN
TO IMPLEMENT AND PUT PROGRAMS
FOURTH TO THE OAC TO HAVE THOSE
INNOVATION DOLLARS CAN EXPAND IT
SO. I THINK WERE WERE HOPING
THAT ON THE AUDIT IN THE FIRE
THAT'S BEEN PLACED UNDERNEATH.
DOT ONLY THE STATE AGENCIES BUT
CERTAINLY THE COUNTIES AROUND
THESE ISSUES THAT WE ARE PUTTING
SOMETHING SOMEPLACE AND SEE PHD
HAVE SOME SPECIFIC IDEAS THAT
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU
ALL.
AND WE'VE BEEN AT THIS FOR
ALMOST AN HOUR SOIL I'LL STOP ON
THE ISSUE SHORTLY BUT JUST A FEW
MORE OVERVIEWS IF I CAN.
DONE.
QUESTION SIX I FOUND THEM
POWERFUL ONES WONDERING DIRECTOR
IF YOU COULD ANSWER IT SO.
THE THAT.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
HAS THE ABILITY TO.
DEEM CRITICAL PERFORMANCE
ISSUES.
HAS D. H. CS RECEIVED ANY OF
THESE NOTIFICATIONS AND WHAT
HAVE WE DONE ABOUT HIM.
SO.
THAT AND WE HAVE HAD ONE.
AND IT WAS INVOLVING AND COUNTY
THAT HAD USED MHSAA FUNDS FOR A
NON MHSAA PURPOSE.
SO WHEN WE RECEIVE.
.
ISSUES LIKE THAT WE GO TO THE
COUNTY WE'D DO I WOULD.
I'D.
DON'T TAKE INVESTIGATION AS A
KIND OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT TYPE
OF INVESTIGATION BUT.
WE WOULD GO OUT TO THE COUNTY
AND WE WOULD KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THAT WAS ACTUALLY UNSUPPORTED
BY.
WHAT THEY HAD EXPENDED THE FUNDS
ON AND THEN WE WORK WITH THEM TO
LET THEM KNOW THAT THEY CAN DO
THAT? THEY HAVE TO THEN BACK OUT
THE EITHER EXPENDITURE THEY HAVE
TO PAY WITH DIFFERENT FUNDS ARE
REPLACE THE FUNDS THAT THEY
OTHERWISE USE BUT THERE'S ONLY
BEEN ONE.
COME LET ME THEN TRANSITION TO
THE NEXT QUESTION.
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS OF.
INTEREST.
WHO WHAT'S THE PLAN WITH THAT
WHAT'S OUR ROLE AS A STATE AND?
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO TO TRACK
THAT SO WE CONSISTENT WITH THAT
INFORMATION NOTICE THAT WESENT
OUT TO THE COUNTIES WE HAVE TOLD
THEM THAT THE INTEREST?
IN WHICHEVER ACCOUNT THAT IT'S
ACCRUING ON HOUSE TO BE SPENT
CONSISTENT WITH THE WAY THAT
THOSE FUNDS WOULD OTHERWISE BE
YOU SO IF YOU'RE EARNING
INTEREST ON YOUR. PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION ALLOCATION
THE INTEREST THAT ACCRUES TO THE
HOUSE WE USE IN PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION EFFORTS
INTEREST THAT IS.
GARNERED ON THE INNOVATION
FUNDS AND YOU HAVE TO USE IT FOR
YOUR INNOVATION SO THAT WE
ISSUED GUIDANCE TO THE COUNTIES
AND LETTING THEM KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE THAT INTERESTS.
I'M I'M GONNA ASK A QUESTION
THAT'S QUITE DETAILED AND I'M
SORRY IF I LOSE ANYONE BUT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IT AND I
DON'T FULLY GET IT.
SO IF.
FISCAL YEAR ONE TWO THREE.
COME FISCAL YEAR TWO YOU WANT TO
CHANGE YOUR THREE YEAR PLAN TO
MAKE IT TWO THREE FOUR.
DO THE PERCENTAGES THAT YOU'VE
SPENT IN EACH INDIVIDUAL AREA
HAVE TO BE. ACCURATE.
SO IF YOU HAD SPEND EIGHTY
PERCENT ON COMMUNITY SERVICE AS
AN TWENTY PERCENT ON INNOVATION
ARE THOSE TRANSFERABLE. TO THE
NEXT CONTRACTOR HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SPENDING
TWENTY PERCENT ON EARLY
INTERVENTION. BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE.
WE KICKED THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
ON ACTUALLY PREVENTING DISEASE.
THAT THE POINT OF THIS IS THE
EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION AND THAT WE NEVER
EFFECTIVELY SPEND THOSE DOLLARS.
SO HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SPENDING AT A MINIMUM TWENTY
PERCENT AS DESIGNED IN STATUTE.
AND SO I THINK THAT EASIEST WAY
I ACCORDING TO. BRENDA IS ITS
FIRST AND.
FIRST OUT
SO IF YOU GET ALLEN ALLOCATION
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN SAY AND.
TO MAKE MATH EASY LET'S SAY IT'S
A MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
ACCOUNT.
HALF A MILLION AND PNI AND HALF
A MILLION INNOVATION THOSE
NUMBERS ARE RIGHT BUT DISTRICT
MAP.
.
MENU EXPEND ALL OF YOUR
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
YOU SPENT MILLION DOLLARS HE
SPENT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY.
A THOUSAND OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND PNI AND YOU SPENT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN INNOVATION.
AND YOU COME BACK AND SAY I
WANT TO USE THOSE REMAINING TO
AMOUNTS OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND AND COMMUNITY SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES. YOU CAN'T WRITE
YOU CAN ROLL IT INTO THOSE
ACCOUNTS FOR THE NEXT YEAR AND
SOME COUNTIES MAY DO THAT RIGHT
SO IF YOU GET ONLY.
SOME CAN EASILY GET LIKE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN INNOVATION FUNDS IN A
SINGLE YEAR THE VERY SMALL IN
YOU CAN DO A LOT WITHOUT AND SO
THEY MAY SET ON INNOVATION FUNDS
FOR. A COUPLE OF YEARS TO KIND
OF BUILD UP AN AMOUNT AND THEN
COME AND SAY TO THE COMMISSION
WE'D LIKE TO USE. THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR INNOVATION
AND THIS IS HOW WE WOULD USE
THAT.
BUT YOU DON'T GET TO COME BACK
AND RE ALLOCATE YOURSELF INTO IT
A DIFFERENT ACCOUNT JUST BECAUSE
YOU DIDN'T USE FUNDS.
SO THEY STAYED PRETTY MUCH IN
THAT ACCOUNT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED.
SO IS THERE.
CAN WE GET AN ANALYSIS OF.
WHERE THEY ARE IN THOSE SPECIFIC
POOLS OF MONEY THEN SO THAT WE
CAN THEN ANALYZE?
HOW TO HELP TO INCENTIVIZE
APPROPRIATE DECISION MAKING BY
THE COUNTY SO THAT? THEY'RE
SPENDING THE FUNDS HAS.
INDICATED.
DO YOU.
YES SO I'M LOOKING AT EITHER
FINANCE THEIR EACH COUNTY THAT
HAS BALANCES.
OUTSTANDING BALANCES AND.
PNI AND INNOVATION BROKEN DOWN
BY COUNTY IS THAT PART OF THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S NO CONCERN
WHAT'S GOING OUT TO COUNTY
THOUGH AND THEN WHAT WHEN THE
CLOCK STARTS FOR. EACH OF THOSE
FARMS AND THEN THEY HAVE TO
SPEND THOSE MONIES WHICH AND
WITHIN THE HOUR YEAH TIME FRAMES
FOR THEM AND THEY HAVE AND THEY
HAVE TO STAY WITHIN THE
COMPONENTS SO. YOU CAN'T SHIFT
FROM ONE COMPONENT TO ANOTHER SO
IT CAME INTO ONE COMPONENT
THAT'S EVEN WITH AB ONE FOR TO.
GET THREE ALLOCATED CERTAIN SO
SO THAT'S REALLY KIND OF A VALUE
I THINK THAT'S BEEN HELD ACROSS
ON MHSAA IS TERRIFIC. IF
SOMETHING GOES OUT ORIGINALLY IN
A PARTICULAR COMPONENT IT STAYS
IN THAT PROPONENTS.
TOOK MISTER CHAIR. YOU KNOW YEAH
IT JUST KIND OF.
GOING UP WEBER ANNA ANNA SAID.
SCREENSHOT I THINK THE PROBLEM
WITH THE
FACT THAT.
WHERE'S OUR OVERSIGHT.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IF THE ONLY
THING WE SEE IS MONEY GOING OUT
OF OUR ACCOUNT AND NOT WE SEE
THE FUNDS THAT ARE EXPENDED
AFTER THE COUNTY HAS EXPANDED
AND BECAUSE THEY FILE THOSE
REPORTS WITH US SO I NOTHING ON
RETIRED MAYBE EVERY YASHA AND
THAT. SUMMER DELAY I'M AROUND.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY IS SO YOU
KNOW YOUR REFERENCE TO THE
REFERRALS FROM THE COMMISSION TO
THE DEPARTMENT.
.
THE THAT'S THAT'S RECOGNIZING
THAT THE COMMISSION DOES NOT
HAVE AUDIT CAPACITY OR AUTHORITY
RIGHT BUT THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT
HOWEVER SANTA.
SO IT'S TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COMMISSION IDENTIFIES A
CHALLENGE COUNTY THAT WAS
SOMEWHAT
HUMOROUS AND DISAPPOINTING. M.
THAT THEM
HAVE SOME CHALLENGES THERE
THERE ARE LOTS OF FISCAL
PRACTICES THAT NEED TO BE
TIGHTENED UP IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT A HUNDRED PERCENT
OF THE MONEY DISPENSED GOT
INNOVATION. IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
THE COMMISSION'S APPROVAL
PROCESS I MEAN DEDICATED
INNOVATION.
THE PREVENTION OR INTERVENTION
IS MUCH MORE DIFFICULT IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO TRACK THAT.
BOTH IN TERMS OF EXPENDITURES
BUT ALSO A PROGRAMMATIC LEVEL
YOUR QUESTION IS HOW DO WE KNOW
THAT THE MONEY IS BEING SPENT
WHAT'S BEST TO BE SPENT ON.
AT AND THEN PART OF THAT IS IS
IT ACTUALLY IMPACTFUL.
THAT'S YOU KNOW OUR OUR OUR
STRATEGY IN THE LIMITED
AUTHORITY RESOURCES WE HAVE
REALLY IS TO PUT THE REPORTS OF
THE KINDS OF REPAIRING ONLINE
LET PEOPLE SEE THEM.
AND RELEASED TRIED TO SUPPORT
THAT BROAD LEVEL OF PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THEN TO DO
THE DATA LINKING AND AND THE
IDEA THERE. IS TO REALLY HELP
THE PUBLIC UNDERSTAND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE GOALS THAT
ARTICULATED IN THE ACT. BUT BUT
WE DO DEPEND ON THE ABILITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT TO DO THE AUDITS
IN THE REVIEWS BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT. THAT
WE FALL UNDER AND YOU'VE SEEN
SORT OF THE CHALLENGE AROUND.
THE COST REPORTS YOU KNOW IF
THE AUDITOR IS TRIED TO.
BECAUSE IT IS A COMPLICATED
SYSTEM WHERE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
THIS THE IT IS COMPOSED OF FIT
TOGETHER AS WELL IN THE VERY
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT WHY AREN'T
WE DOING A BETTER JOB
INTEGRATING PHYSICAL HEALTH IN
THE HOUSE. WITH ONE QUESTION
THOUGH YOU SAID THAT THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING THESE REPORTS ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION ON LINES OF THE
PUBLIC CAN SEE IS THERE ANYWHERE
WHERE THE PUBLIC CAN SEE IT WHAT
WHAT MONEY. IS IN RESERVES AND
WHAT MANY.
IS IS THE OUT GOING BACK TO
REVERSION YASSER CURRENTLY ON
OUR WEBSITE YOU CAN CLICK ON
YOUR COUNTY AND YOU CAN SEE THE
REVENUE LET'S SAY.
.
IT'S W. BULGARIA MHS SO AC DOT
CA DOT GOV IT'S A I WILL I WILL.
TELL YOU WITH A BIT OF
EMBARRASSMENT IT IS A STANDARD
STATE WEBSITE THAT IS NOT VERY
USER FRIENDLY.
BUT I'M HAPPY TO SHOW YOU SEND
YOU INTO THAT'S THE PROBLEM
THOUGH AND I HEAR PEOPLE SOLELY
ON IS THE PROBLEM IS THAT YOU'RE
SAYING ALL OF THESE GREAT THINGS
HAPPEN THROUGH THE WEBSITE BUT
THEN YOU'RE SAYING THAT IT'S NOT
A GOOD WEBSITE SO THEN. THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY NOT JUST FROM US
BUT FROM THE PUBLIC IS NOT
HAPPENING FOR USING THAT WERE
DEPENDING ON THE PUBLIC TO TO DO
THIS. IS
ANYWAY I I THINK ARE AND WHAT HE
SAID TO THOUGH IS THAT.
THE REAL ACCOUNTABILITY IT LIES
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE THAT ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
THAT THERE REALLY A GRAND JURY I
LIKE THAT ANALOGY SORRY I THINK
WE CUT YOU OFF PLEASE MISS
PARLEY. DISCREDITED TO POINT OUT
IT'S IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING FOR
COUNTIES TO HEAR THAT THE STATE
FINDS IT CHALLENGING TO BE ABLE
TO.
TELL THE STORY ABOUT THE
VOLUMES OF DATA AND NARRATIVE
THAT ARE BEING REQUIRED TO BE
PRODUCED BY COUNTY IS THEN SENT
TO THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AS
WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT. I AND I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THAT IT IS
CHALLENGING BUT I THINK THAT
THAT NEEDS TO STOP BEING A GOOD
ENOUGH ANSWER THE FACT THAT IT'S
COMPLEX AND CHALLENGING. AND
THAT THAT EACH COUNTY IS
SUBMITTING PILES OF INFORMATION
THAT'S REALLY BASED ON WHAT
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY HAS TOLD
THEM ARE THE NEEDS WITH DATA. IN
THE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THEY'RE PUTTING IN PLACE WITH
PREVENTION WITH COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS WITH
INNOVATION THE INFORMATION IS AT
OUR FINGERTIPS IT'S THE LACK OF
IT IS A. AGENCY AND TO TAKE ALL
OF THAT AND THEN TURN THAT INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S VALUABLE I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO KNOW.
HOW MUCH MONEY ARE COUNTY
SPENDING AND ON WHAT TYPE OF
THING BUT I THINK MORE VALUABLE
WOULD BE TO KNOW OTHER PEOPLE'S
LIVES ARE CHANGED IN OUR PEOPLE
GETTING HEALTHIER?
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE ACT WAS
INTENDED TO TRY TO GET VOTERS
YOU KNOW WE WERE TELLING VOTERS
THAT WE KNEW WHAT WORKED WE WERE
BUILDING ON PILOT PROGRAMS THAT
WE NEW WORKS AND WHY SHOULDN'T
EVERY COMMUNITY HAVE THE OPTION
TO DO THOSE THINGS.
SO THE ABILITY TO HAVE A STATE
AGENCY WHETHER IT'S THE
OVERSIGHT COMMISSIONER THE
DEPARTMENT.
CONTRACT OUT WITH A THIRD
ENTITY TO TAKE THESE CHALLENGING
AND COMPLEX PROBLEMS AND TAKE OF
THE VOLUMES OF INFORMATION
THAT'S BEING COLLECTED AND TURN
THAT INTO A STORY ABOUT THE
OUTCOMES THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING. SOMETHING CVH DAY
WOULD VERY MUCH UNLIKE THE
LEGISLATURE'S PARTNERSHIP IN
LEADERSHIP AND THEN IT'S A TOPIC
THAT WILL BE HEARD IN THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THREE LATER
THIS WEEK.
CAN.
.
WHAT WHAT METRICS WOULD THE
COUNTY HIGHLIGHTED AS EFFECTIVE?
EXAMPLES OF MONEY BEING WELL
SPENT.
I THINK AND I THINK ONE NEED
ONLY READ THE ACT.
THAT THAT WHILE THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AND
SPECIAL TARGET POPULATIONS
BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BEING IMPLEMENTED.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS IN
WHICH EVERY COUNTY HAS BEEN
EXPECTED TO.
RES.
YOU KNOW TO REALLY BE LOOKING AT
CAN YOU TELL US THAT THE PROGRAM
THAT YOU'VE DEVELOPED IS
REDUCING INCARCERATIONS IS
IMPROVING AND SCHOOL INVOLVEMENT
FOR KIDS IS KEEPING OUT OF
PEOPLE OUT OF HOSPITALS WHEN
THERE'S THE SEVEN OR EIGHT
OUTCOMES THAT ARE LISTED. THAT'S
WHAT THE VOTER PAMPHLET SAID WE
ALL SHOWED UP.
TO THE ELECTION IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR AND I THINK WE NEED TO
START THEIR.
HAVE WE AS A STATE COLLECTED
THAT DATA AT ANY POINT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND HOW ARE
WE TREND.
WELL I THINK THIS IS.
PART OF THE CONVERSATION FOR
LATER IN THE AGENDA IN TERMS OF
THE DEPARTMENTS.
DEVELOPMENT AND MATURITY AROUND
A PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES SYSTEM IT
IS NOT AND SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON MHSAA. SO IT GETS BACK TO
KIND OF MY INITIAL COMMENTS
AROUND.
MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA USING A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS AND SO
WE HAVE.
METRICS THAT WE ARE BUILDING
AND DEVELOPING AS AND WE TRY TO
MEASURE OUTCOMES AS A STATE AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND FOR WHAT WE
OVERSEE AND.
BUT THAT'S A THAT'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THAN WHAT
YOU WERE ASKING AS IT PERTAINS
TO AN AGE OF SAY. WE DIDN'T OF
THE DC ARE I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT
IT STANDS FOR.
WHICH BRENDA.
CAN SPEAK VERY ADEPTLY AT I'M
SURE.
FOR AS A DATA PERSON WHICH WAS
COLLECTING INFORMATION ABOUT A
PARTICULAR COMPONENT THE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS WHICH IS A
A VERY BIG PART OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT COUNTIES ARE
MAKING.
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE
SEEN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS OUTSIDE
OF GOVERNMENT BE ABLE TO TAKE
THESE KINDS OF COMPLEX THINGS
AND LOOK AT ISSUES LIKE
PREVENTION. AND BE ABLE TO TELL
US IN FACT ARE THOSE INVESTMENTS
COST YOU KNOW THEIR COST
BENEFIT.
AND NOT JUST CAN BE TRACED WHICH
DOLLAR WENT TO WHICH PROGRAM BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY AGAIN DID THE
DOLLAR INVESTED GET TO THE
OUTCOMES THAT VOTERS EXPECTED.
AND I GUESS THAT'S THE. POINT I
KEEP TRYING TO DRIVE FOR AND I'M
LOOKING FOR AN OUTCOME WE CAN
HANG OUR HAT ON.
FOR THE INCREASE IN COVERAGE AS
WELL AS THE INCREASE IN
SPENDING.
WHAT CAN WE SHOW DEFINITIVELY
AFTER YEARS OF INVESTMENTS?
THAT HAVE MADE MEANINGFUL IMPACT
FOLD DIFFERENCE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AND I'M HAPPY TO HEAR BUT
I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM ANYONE
HERE.
THAT THERE'S A DEMONSTRATE A
BOWL.
IMPROVEMENT
POST MONEY BEING SPENT ON SO I
ASK AGAIN DO WE HAVE THE
APPROACH APPROPRIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
OVER THE SPENDING THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY AYE I DO KNOW
THAT BECAUSE IT'S REQUIRED OF
EVERY COUNTY TO ADDRESS
EVALUATION OUTCOMES THAT EVERY
COUNTY. IS LOOKING AT THE
OUTCOMES THEY'RE PRODUCING THAT
GETS REPORTED IN PART OF HOW
THEY THE.
.
SO TO RATIONALIZE THEIR THEIR
THREE YEAR PLANS YOU KNOW WE'VE
DONE THIS IT WORKS WE'VE
THEREFORE ARE EXPANDING INTO
CONTINUING IT SO WE KNOW THAT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. THERE IS ROBUST
INFORMATION JUST I THINK I'M A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO ONE OF OUR
COUNTIES WAS HERE BRIEFING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DELEGATION ON
A RECENT RAND REPORT THAT LOOKED
SPECIFICALLY AT ITS MHSAA
EVALUATIONS NOW COMES. RAND HAS
ALSO EVALUATED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS AND PREVENTION DOLLARS
THAT THE COUNTY'S JOINTLY
ADMINISTERED TO REDUCE SUICIDE
IN REDUCED EGGMAN DISCRIMINATION
IS ARE THINGS THAT WERE ABLE TO
SHOW WORK.
BUT AS TO TO THE MANY OTHER
DOLLARS.
BEING EXPENDED STATEWIDE I
THINK WE REALLY IT IS MORE THAN
TIME.
FOR ONE UNIFIED APPROACH TO
BEING ABLE TO EVALUATE THE
OUTCOMES AND THE OTHER GOOD NEWS
SAYS THE ACT ACTUALLY
CONTEMPLATED THIS.
IN THE STATE ADMINISTRATION
ARENA IN THE ACT.
ONE OF THE VERY SPECIFIED
PURPOSES OF OF THAT UP TO FIVE
PERCENT BE SET ASIDE FOR IS TO
ENSURE AN ADEQUATE EVALUATION
THE OUTCOMES OCCUR. SO IT'S NOT
EVEN FOR LACK OF A FUNDING
SOURCE SO I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
SEGUE IN THIS WILL BE THE LAST
ROUND OF QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE
ON THIS ISSUE BEFORE WE
PROGRESS.
IS REGARDING.
STATE ADMINISTRATION SO MY
UNDERSTAND IS THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS
MONEY IN STATE ADMINISTRATION
FUNDS AS WELL CAN WE GET IT.
A BASIS FOR HOW MUCH EXTRA
STATE ADMINISTRATION FUNDS WE
HAVE.
RIGHT SO AS NOTED ON PAGE
FIFTEEN AND NAY AGENDA THERE'S A
CHART.
THAT REFLECTS THE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE A.
ADMIN CAP FILE A CHART THAT WE
REFER TO AS ADMIN CAP.
SO IN THAT.
YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE THAT AT THE
VERY BOTTOM THAT THAT THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY TWO POINT
THREE MILLION THAT'S AVAILABLE.
IN ACCESS FUNDS THAT CAN BE
USED TO.
.
FROM THE MHS F.. ALTHOUGH ALL
KNOW THAT.
THE PRIMARY.
IT THAT.
WHEN LOOKING AT THIS BALLOTS
THIS ISN'T CONSIDERED A WAH
ONGOING AMOUNT THAT CAN BE SPENT
A RATHER WE VIEWED THE
ADMINISTRATION VIEWS AS A ONE
TIME. AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF OUR EXPENDITURES.
THAT IS CURRENTLY BEING IN OUR
ONGOING EXPENSES BEING OBLIGATED
ARE EXCEEDING.
.
THE AMOUNT THAT'S GOING TO BE
RECEIVED
AND SO THE REASON THAT THERE IS
THERE ARE RESERVISTS BECAUSE OF
PAST YEAR. SAVINGS THAT HAVE
ACCRUED SO THAT.
AMOUNT KIND OF ROLES DO IT'S
APPALLING BASE
SPEAK.
.
IT COULD BE SAID THAT THOSE
FUNDS COULD BE USED FOR.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT CORRECT.
SURE IS THERE A REASON WE'RE NOT
USING THESE FUNDS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
I MEAN I WOULD I WOULD SAY THAT
THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE.
ANY CHANGER ADDITIONAL USE OF
THOSE FUNDS WOULD JUST BE A AND
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT.
AND HOW YOU WOULD WANT TO USE
THAT I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
USED IN THE PAST FOR OTHER
ONETIME INITIATIVES WHICH ARE
COMING UP ON YOUR. AGENDA LATER
AROUND SUICIDE PREVENTION AND SO
I THINK IT'S ALWAYS THE
NEGOTIATION BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ON WHETHER OR
NOT THAT'S FUNDS SHOULD BE USED
HOW MUCH AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES. HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES DO YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
THAT HELP YOU WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
MY CHEST I?
IT'S LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE.
THAT'S ALSO ONE OF THE ITEMS
THAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY AND THAT
WE RECEIVED FUNDING BUT NOT
POSITION AUTHORITY WHICH WE WILL
COME BACK AND TALK ABOUT BUT
IT'S PROBABLY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE POSITIONS TOTAL. IS THERE
A.
IS THERE A LACK AND I GUESS
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DR ED
RIGHT I'M I'M. IN NO MEANS AM I
EVER TRYING TO PLACE BLAME ON
TRYING TO SOLVE PROBLEMS. AND IT
SEEMS AS IF WE HAVE APPROPRIATE
FUNDS.
WHAT ARE WE MISSING?
IS IT NOT HAVING THE APPROPRIATE
POSITIONS ARE THE OVERSIGHT IS
THAT THE FACT THAT MONEY GOES
OUT THE DOOR. WITHOUT HAVING
CHECKED THE PLANS BEFOREHAND IS
IT THE OVERSEEING DEPARTMENT
ISN'T THE APPROPRIATE PLACE TO
HOUSE THIS.
I THINK THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
WE AS A LEGISLATURE ARE GOING TO
BE GRAPPLING WITH THIS YEAR. BUT
IT'S.
A BIT DISTURBING TO RECEIVE THIS
AUDIT REPORT AND I MUST ADMIT.
TO LOOK AT THE AUDIT REPORT THAT
CAME BEFORE THIS AS WELL.
THAT SHOWED MUCH OF THE SAME%
PROBLEMS SO I DON'T BELIEVE THIS
IS A.
A NEW PROBLEM THAT WERE
ADDRESSING.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO A
CONTINUING THIS SO WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE TO OPEN.
AND THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CANDOR AND BILLETED TO TALK
ABOUT THESE PROBLEMS.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE.
THERE YOU GO.
ARE YOU GOING.
CAN THAT OUT OF HERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF.
ACCORDINGLY.
COMING.
HOLD.
IN.
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO ORDER.
SURE. SO AND.
WHEN THE.
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH WAS.
DISMANTLED AND WE OBSERVE THE
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH.
SO FIVE PIECES OF THAT
DEPARTMENT.
THE.
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE THAT
HAVE BEEN HOUSED IN THE FORMER
DEPARTMENTS.
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
THOSE INDIVIDUALS CAME OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT.
SO WE ABSORB THE EXPERTISE AND
THE WORK ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
BUT WE NEVER I'M CONSTITUTED OR
RECONSTITUTED OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
THE AGENDA HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS A WEBSITE THAT
WAS US STILL OPERATIONAL THAT
HAD ALSO BEEN CARRIED OVER
WHICH.
ON IS NOT IN ESSENCE ACTUAL
THERE'S NOT ACTUALLY AN OFFICE
ON THE INDIVIDUALS I THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR BOTH WORKING
WITH.
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION AND
STAKEHOLDERS WORKING WITH.
THE GRANTS THAT WE HAVE AROUND
THE SUICIDE HOTLINES WE HAVE
THREE STAFF THAT CONTINUE TO
WORK ON ISSUES RELATING TO THE
PREVENTION OF.
SUICIDE AND WORKING WITH
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS BUT WE
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE AN OFFICE.
.
AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS REPORT UP
THROUGH OUR MHSAA UNITS WE HAVE
A SET OF SMALL DIVISION THAT WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT TERMS OF THE
STE SOME OF THE STAFF THAT DO
THEIR AND. AND THEY WORK UNDER
THAT UNDER THAT DIVISION.
TOBY EWING WE HAVE YOU NEXT.
WELL IN IN TERMS OF.
.
SORRY I WAS I WAS.
LISTENING.
PROPIAS YEAH.
SO THE M. LAST YEAR THIS EIGHT
YOU'VE GOT TO QUESTIONS IN THE
PACKET ONE WITH IS REGARD TO THE
WORK THAT WE'VE INITIATED IN
TERMS OF US A STRATEGIC PLAN
PROCESS HAD PREVENTION. AND THE
OTHER IS AN UPDATE ON THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE PROJECT THAT THE
NETS IN TERMS OF THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE PROJECT WE RECEIVE AN
ANNUAL RIDLEY WAS GIVEN ANNUAL
REPORT FROM THE BRIDGE DISTRICT.
AND AND WE SORT OF MONITOR THEIR
PROGRESS ASSESSMENT LARGELY
CONSTRUCTION NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE ACT IS IN OUR NO SKILL SET.
COME THOUGH THAT LATEST REPORT
FROM THEM I BELIEVE IT WAS
NOVEMBER DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
A AFTER SOME DELAYS BECAUSE THAT
THEY RECEIVED TWO BIDS TO THE
WORK THE BIDS WERE WELL ABOVE
THE PROJECTED.
BUDGET FOR THAT WHERE THEY HAD
TO GO OUT AND FIND ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES DAMAGE TO SAY PROVIDES
ABOUT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A PROJECT THAT IS OVER I THINK
IT'S OF OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
BY NOW.
THEY'VE STARTED THE
CONSTRUCTION PROCESS IN THAT
THEY'RE IN THE FABRICATION
STAGES OF BUILDING OUT THE
GNATS.
AND THE CANTILEVER STRUCTURAL
SUPPORT THE HOLD THE NETS AND SO
THEY'VE THEY'RE BEGINNING TO DO.
BUILD OUT THE SAFETY STRUCTURES
AROUND THE CONSTRUCTION SITES
AND SO.
THAT OUR CONVERSATION WITH THE
BRIDGE DISTRICT
SUGGESTED THAT WORK IS MOVING
FORWARD IT'LL TAKE YOU TO FILL
TAKE SOME TIME AND I THINK THE
RUNNER ON A TOTAL OF FIVE YEAR
TIME FRAME FROM SECURING THE
FUNDING THROUGH COMPLETION OF
THE PROJECT. BUT IT IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THEM IN TERMS OF
THE DISTRIBUTE PLAN FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION. OF THE COMMISSION
FORMS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE OPERATES UNDER ALL
THE BAGLEY KEENE RULES SO IT'S
OPEN MEETING.
WE HELD OUR FIRST MEETING IN IN
REDDING EARLIER THAT ACTUALLY
ABOUT A MONTH AGO AND THAT
COUNTY HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
RATES OF SUICIDE IN THE STATE A
LOT OF ISOLATED.
OLDER WHITE MALES A AND SO
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COUNTY WE HELD A PUBLIC MEETING.
AND HEARD FROM FAMILY MEMBERS
AND PROVIDERS AROUND THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING EMPHATICALLY
AROUND THEIR PREVENTION
STRATEGIES IN IN TERMS OF
ENGAGING. MAN WHO OFTEN ARE
RELUCTANT TO COMMENT GAGE TO
TRADITIONAL STRATEGIES IN THE
HOUSE SERVICES AND SO. AND IT
WILL WE THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
HEARING SCHEDULED FOR MAY IN
SACRAMENTO WE'RE BRINGING IN.
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
EXPERTS TO COME AND TALK WITH US
ABOUT DATA ABOUT RISK FACTORS
ABOUT A MODEL PROGRAMS AND AND
WELL ORGANIZED ANOTHER SIMILAR
PUBLIC HEARING. LATER IN THE
YEAR THAT'LL START TO TALK ABOUT
SOLUTIONS
IF AUTHOR REACHED OUT TO MOST OF
THE SOCIAL NETWORK PLATFORMS
BECAUSE THEY'RE FINDING THAT
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN SUICIDE CAR ON SOCIAL
NETWORKS SYSTEMS. THEIR GOOGLING
SEARCH TERMS HOW DO I RIDE IN
AND INSERT WHATEVER.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR
WHICH IS INFORMATION ON.
DIFFER MODALITIES ARE
PREVENTION STRATEGIES AND SO
THEY WANT TO BE A PARTNER.
AND TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN CONNECT THE SUCH A
NETWORKING COMPANIES TO THE
PUBLIC SECTOR SIDE SO WE CAN DO
A BETTER JOB PREVENTING AN
INTERVENING WHERE APPROPRIATE SO
THAT WORK IS UNDER WAY WE'RE
EXCITED WE WILL NOT HAVE THAT
WORK DONE BY THE JULY DEADLINE.
THAT YOU HAD ASKED WE WILL SEND
YOU A LETTER TO EXPLAIN THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE AND WHEN WE
THINK THAT THE WORK WILL BE
DONE.
WE ARE ALSO WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WERE AN INDEPENDENT ENTITY
WERE NOT PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE DON'T WANT
TO DRAFT A PLAN. THAT MISSION TO
CONSIDER.
WE WANT TO DRAFT A PLAN THAT
THEY WILL ADOPT AND SO WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE AGENCY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE WORK WE DO IS
IT IN THE PARAMETERS OF WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD FIND
ACCEPTABLE MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU HAVE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS MIGHT HAVE ON THIS
PARLOR.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME I WAS
ASKED TO DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION
OF SUICIDE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
IN OUR STATE I DID BRING SOME
MATERIALS BUT THE SERGEANTS NEED
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE APPROVED
BEFORE WE COULD DISTRIBUTE
THOSE.
SO I THINK THE COUNTY IS.
IN ADDITION TO THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLAN THAT YOU'RE
HEARING ABOUT HAVE SINCE THE
ENACTMENT OF THE MEDICAL
SERVICES ACT UNLIKELY BEFORE
SEEN THEMSELVES VERY MUCH ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE ABILITY TO DO
SUICIDE PREVENTION WORK.
I THINK IT'S RARE IN OUR NATION
THAT THE COUNTY BUT A WHOLE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY EMPLOYMENT
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES AT ALL.
AND NO OTHER COUNTY OR STATE IN
THE NATION HAS BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
A MENTAL HEALTH TO THE VOTERS
SUCCESSFULLY IN THE WAY THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND UP TO
TWENTY PERCENT OF OUR REVENUES.
TO TRY TO PREVENT FOLKS
FROM BECOMING ILL OR MORE ILL
AND HAS BEEN REALLY.
NATIONALLY EXCITING THING TO BE
ABLE TO BE PROUD OF.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL COUNTIES ARE
CERTAINLY USING MANY OF THEIR
MHSAA COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS OR PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION TO PUT SUICIDE
PREVENTION. AND ACTIVITIES INTO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES INCLUDING I'M
SUPPORTING SUICIDE PREVENTION
CRISIS LINES AND THEY'RE DOING
TRAININGS COMMUNITY OUTREACH
WORKING WITH SCHOOLS AND OTHERS.
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE
THERE DIFFERENT HIGH RISK
POPULATIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
TARGET IN THOSE ACTIVITIES COVER
ONE OF THE EXCITING THINGS THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO DO IS. A JOINTLY
ADMINISTERED SET OF INVESTMENTS
TO REALLY FOCUS IN ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THAT IS A STATE WIDE CRISIS AND
THAT DOING IT FIFTY EIGHT TIMES
WITH UNIQUE STRATEGIES WOULD NOT
BE PERHAPS IT'S COST EFFECTIVE
IS REALLY GETTING SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS FROM.
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO TELL US
HOW WE MIGHT GET ARE THE BIGGEST
BANG FOR OUR BUCK IN IN TRYING
TO TAKE A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH
TO SUICIDE PREVENTION. SO OVER
THE SPAN OF THREE OR FOUR YEARS
I'M COUNTIES JOINTLY
ADMINISTERED I'M A REALLY LARGE
CAMPAIGN CALLED KNOW THE SIGNS
AND THAT'S AMONG SOME OF THE
MATERIAL. WE'RE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
REACH ONE OUT OF EVERY TWO
CALIFORNIANS IN THE STATE.
USING ADS IN MAGAZINES ON
TELEVISIONS ON THE TH AND
BILLBOARDS BROCHURES VIDEOS AND
OTHER WAYS.
TO REALLY HELP PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND REALLY JUST LIKE YOU
OR I IF YOU HAVE A PERSON IN
YOUR LIFE YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
MIGHT HARM THEMSELVES WHAT DO
YOU DO DO YOU HAVE THE
CONVERSATION A NEPHEW DO.
TO TRY TO BUST SOME OF THE
MYTHS THAT ARE COMMON ABOUT THE
THE CONCERNS THAT WELL IF I TALK
TO THEM ABOUT SUICIDE I MIGHT
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE THAT. I WHICH
IS A MYTH BUT IN FACT TO GIVE
YOU THE REAL WORDS TO USE AND TO
TALK TO SOMEONE I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SUICIDE IS PREVENTABLE DOT
ORG WEBSITE.
AND WE WOULD WE WERE ABLE TO
EVALUATE THAT AND RAND FOUND
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE EXPOSED
TO THAT CAMPAIGN DEFINITELY FELT
THEY WERE MORE CONFIDENT TO BE
ABLE TO INTERVENE IF THERE IS A
PERSON IN THEIR LIFE THAT THEY
ITSELF AND THE CONTENT OF WHAT
WAS BEING SAID WAS. CULTURALLY
RELEVANT AND THE THE MATERIALS
ARE NOW AVAILABLE IN ADDITION TO
ENGLISH AND SPANISH IN CAMBODIAN
CHINESE MONK MAYOR KOREAN ALLOW
ME AND PUNJABI RUSSIAN SPANISH
TAGALOG AND VIETNAMESE. OTHER
ALSO SPECIAL OUTREACH MATERIALS
DESIGNED FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
YOUTH AND THE LGBTQ YOUTH
COMMUNITY AND BECAUSE SPANISH.
SPEAKING INDIVIDUALS ARE AT
HIGHER RISK IN MANY COMMUNITIES
OF SUICIDE THERE ARE SPECIAL
SPANISH LANGUAGE SUICIDE
PREVENTION TRAINING. AND THAT
WAS PROVIDED TO COMMUNITY
HEALTH%
WORKERS TO AND PRETORIUS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ALSO AND MENTIONED SOME
REALLY AMAZING WORK THAT HAS
BEEN FUNDED WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND THROUGH A
TRAINING CALLED AND PUNK NATO
WE'RE ABLE TO OFFER TRAINING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STAFF
INSTRUCTORS AS WELL AS SOME
STUDENTS ABOUT HOW TO.
SPOT THE SIGNS THAT A YOUNG
PERSON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM MIGHT BE AT RISK AND WHAT
TO DO TO REACH OUT AND GET THEM.
AND HELP OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STAFF AND
STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OVER A HUNDRED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
AROUND CALIFORNIA WERE TOUCHED
BY THAT.
AND I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
SOMETHING FUN AND IN A VERY MUCH
MORE YOUTH CENTERED APPROACH.
SOME OF YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD OF
THE DIRECTING CHANGE CAMPAIGN
ACTUALLY OF DONE SCREENINGS AND
AN AWARD CEREMONY DOWNTOWN HERE.
AT THE CREST THEATER.
DURING THE SPRING SO HUNDREDS
OF.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE YOU SEE
HAVE BEGUN TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. CREATE THEIR
OWN.
SHORT PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT COMMERCIAL OFTEN
YEAH YOU KNOW. PORTRAYING
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FRIENDS
FROM SCHOOL AND THE POINT OF
WHICH IS TO REALLY TRY TO. GET
EMPOWER AND EMPOWER YOUTH TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND AS IMPORTANTLY
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE INTERVENING
IF THEY DO HAVE A FRIEND THAT
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT. SO
DIRECTING CHANGE DOT ORG.
IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE KINDS
OF WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO REALLY WITH SCHOOLS AND I'M
AN EVALUATION OF THAT FOUND THAT
EIGHTY PER EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT.
OF THE STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THAT HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF MENTAL ILLNESS
AND SUICIDE SINCE JUST A
SNAPSHOT OF SOME OF THE EXCITING
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DEAL. AND WHEN COUNTIES ARE ABLE
TO PUT THEIR INVESTMENTS
TOGETHER AND GET CREATIVE.
WE DO THINK THAT IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR AND THE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION ONE OF
THEIR PURPOSES BEING TO SUPPORT
THE DISSEMINATION OF INFORMATION
TO FIND CREATIVE WAYS AND WORK
WITH THE COUNTIES AND ARE CBO
PARTNERS TO GET THE KIND OF WORK
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE OVER
THESE. PAST AND FOURTEEN YEARS
OR SO OF THE ACT AND TO THE GET
US ALL IN A ROOM AND AND BE ABLE
TO EXCHANGE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING NOT ONLY
IN THE PREVENTION SPACE MORE I'M
PROBABLY BUT CERTAINLY ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS ON ISSUE THREE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE AT
THIS TIME.
BUT WE. ARE.
HI I AM DOCTOR KEY THE CURRY AND
I'M THE CEO OF DIDI HIRSCH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND SUICIDE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
CHANGE THAT WE WILL STOP ONE
LIFE AT A TIME.
SO WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT
ABOUT NUMBERS AND.
WHAT'S BEING DONE WITH THEM AND
HOW THEY'RE BEING TRACKED I
WANNA TALK ABOUT SOMETHING.
I CAN SAFELY LIVES ONE PERSON AT
A TIME.
AND THAT'S THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE.
ONE COUNSELOR TALKS TO ONE
PERSON AND GIVES THEM A GLIMMER
OF HOPE.
THE THE MATH IT'S THAT THIS NEW
LIFELINE USES HAVE BEEN VERIFIED
BY RESEARCH AS BEING EFFECTIVE
AND SAVING LIVES.
HE MIGHT NOT KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IT OR YOU MIGHT THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT SINCE IT'S
NATIONAL SANSA PAYS FOR THAT'S
NOT TRUE THEY LAUNCHED IT. BUT
THEY DO NOT PAY FOR IT WITHIN
THE STATE'S.
MOST LINES GET ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR.
IT'S DEVELOPED IN A WAY THAT
IT'S BASED ON RESEARCH.
BEST PRACTICES.
HAS Q. A ALL THE WINES ARE
ACCREDITED.
IT'S LINKED WITH FACEBOOK SO
THAT OF SOMEONE ON FACEBOOK USE
OF CERTAIN KEY WORDS.
THAT.
INDICATE THEY MAY BE SUICIDAL.
THE LINE POPS UP THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE PREVENTION LIFELINE
NUMBER IT HAS SPANISH TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY.
CALIFORNIA HAS TEN OF THOSE
LINES.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS NOT YET FOUND
A WAY TO GO FROM ALLOCATING
MONEY.
TWO USING IT TO SAVE LIVES.
AND I I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT.
IT'S BEEN UNDER A LOT OF
PRESSURE AND A LOT OF CHANGE.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
WERE VERY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE VOTED.
TO ALLOCATE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE STE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE NETWORK.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN THE NEXT YEAR YOU VOTED
AGAIN.
TO ALLOCATE FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION.
AND WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THE
MONEY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT PART OF IT'S
UNDERSTOOD A CONFUSION ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY IS ACCEPTABLE COSTS
FOR EXAMPLE. CAN WE PAY FOR
UPGRADES AND BONE SOFTWARE CAN
WE PAY FOR DATA SYSTEMS CAN WE
PAY FOR A GENERATOR SO THAT
THERE'S AN EARTHQUAKE WE CAN
KEEP THE LINES UP.
WHEN PEOPLE MOST NEED US CAN
WOOD PAPER CUBICLES.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO HIRE
CONSIDER IN.
AND IF NONE OF THOSE CAN BE PAID
FOR.
AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO MAKE YET ANOTHER
BUDGET.
AS LONG AS WE CAN GET THE MONEY.
TO SAVE LIVES
SO I REALLY ASK THAT WE THINK
ABOUT.
WHEN WE KNOW SOMETHING WORKS
WHEN IT'S VALIDATED WHEN WE HAVE
RESEARCH THAT AFTER PHONE CALLS
PEOPLE ARE LESS LIKELY. TO TAKE
pTHEIR LIVES
LET'S DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
ANNOUNCEMENTS CAN SPEAK.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI AM LYNN MORRISON THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT.
OF CLINICAL OPERATIONS FOR DE
HIRSCHMENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHERE WE HAVE THE OLDEST AND
LONGEST STANDING SUICIDE
PREVENTION CENTER IN THE NATION.
I'M AND WE ARE MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE.
IT'S KETA MENTIONED WE DEFTLY
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS BEEN GOING THROUGH.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM ON
TRYING TO EXECUTE THIS CONTRACT
SO THAT WE CAN GET THIS FUNDING
THAT WAS DESIGNATED FOR
STATEWIDE SUICIDE PREVENTION.
SERVICES.
BUT IT'S IT'S BEEN FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
AT HOME AND IT'S BEEN ALMOST TWO
YEARS. AND WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITHIN THAT TWO YEARS IS THAT
THE SUICIDE RATES CONTINUE TO
RISE.
OUR CALL VOLUME AND THE
INTENSITY OF THE CALLS THAT WERE
GETTING ARE ALSO INCREASING.
DE HIRSCH  AND ALSO THERE
HAVE BEEN IS MANY OF YOU KNOW
MULTIPLE DISASTERS IN THE LAST
YEAR ALONE WITH HURRICANES FIRES
FLOODS SHOOTINGS. WE GET A LOT
OF THOSE CALLS ON OUR DISASTER
DISTRESS HELPLINE AS WELL AS ON
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE. PEOPLE ARE MORE
DISTRESSED THAN EVER LAST YEAR
DO YOU HERSCHEL LOAN TOOK OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALLS ON OUR
CRISIS LINE AND THAT KEEPS GOING
UP.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THESE TWO
YEARS WITH WITHOUT THE FUNDING
IS THAT.
DIDI HIRSCH IS LUCKY THAT WE
HAVE SUPPORT FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
BUT OTHER COUNTIES AREN'T AS
LUCKY SO THEY HAVE HAD TO CUT
SERVICES OR REDUCE THEIR
SERVICES.
WE THEY HAVE.
SHRUNK THEIR GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OF
WHERE THEY WILL TAKE CALLS FROM
AND SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
DO YOU HIRSCH'S THE EMERGENCY.
BACKUP FOR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT MEANS MORE
CALLS ARE COMING TO US
NOW BECAUSE OF THAT.
.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WERE NEEDED
MORE VOLUNTEERS THE CALLS ARE
TAKING LONGER THEIR MORE
INTENSE.
THERE'S MORE TURNOVER AND
VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE OF JUST THE
DAILY GRIND OF TAKING THOSE
CALLS. THAT WERE NEEDED MORE
VOLUNTEERS IN MORE TRAINING. AND
SOME PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT
YOU HAVE A VOLUNTEER ON A
SUICIDE CRISIS WHY WE DON'T TAKE
THAT LIGHTLY THEY GO THROUGH A
HUNDRED PLUS HOURS OF TRAINING.
BEFORE WE WILL EVEN PUT THEM ON
A CALL ONCE THEY'RE ON A CALL
THEY NEED THE OVERSIGHT. OF A
SHIFT SUPERVISOR A MANAGER ON
THAT CHEF TO BE ABLE TO MONITOR
THOSE CALLS FOR A COUPLE MONTHS
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GIVING CALIFORNIANS THE BEST
POSSIBLE. CARE IN THE WORST
SITUATION THAT THERE AND AT THAT
TIME.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME COUNTIES
HAVE HAD TO TAKE ON ADDITIONAL
CONTRACTS FROM OTHER AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE ON CALL AFTER OUR
SERVICE FOR EXAMPLE.
TO JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET BUT
THAT'S ALSO INCREASING THEIR
CALL VOLUME SO IT'S IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT.
SO WERE ASKING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THIS COMMITTEE.
TO HELP US TO SECURE THESE FUNDS
FOR FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR THE FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS SO THERE'S NO
GAP IN SERVICES. AND WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS LIFESAVING
SERVICES THAT ARE SO NEEDED IN
CRITICAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
UP BEFORE I GET THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESPONSE TO THAT COMMENTARY I
DID WANT TO ON.
MENTION THAT I BELIEVE
HISTORICALLY THE COUNTIES PAID A
PORTION OF THIS
OF THE FUNDS TO HELP WITH THE
SUICIDE HOTLINE. AND WAS
WONDERING MISS BARLOW IF I
COULD.
IF. YOU COULD HELP TO RESPOND
WHY THE COUNTIES NO LONGER ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO A PORTION OF THE
SUICIDE HOTLINE.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE
FOUND WITH THE RECENT AUDIT.
IT SEEMS THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
FUNDS TO HELP US REACH OUR GOAL
OF ENSURING THE SUICIDE HOTLINE
IS OPEN.
SURE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO GO BACK
AND FIND OUT MORE ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC RISK.
SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
MIGHT HAVE BEEN PROVIDING FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINES I AM
AWARE THAT THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION CAMPAIGN INCLUDING
THE KNOW THE SCIENCE INFORMATION
THAT YOU HAVE. FOUND WITH YOU
THERE WAS A THOSE WERE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS OVER MULTI YEAR
PERIOD EACH COUNTY WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE OR NOT
AND TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES ARE IN FACT CONTINUING.
TO SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SOME OF THESE KIND OF SIGNATURE
PREVENTION CAMPAIGNS.
OTHERS NOT BECAUSE OF EITHER
OTHER LOCAL PRIORITIES THEY
MIGHT HAVE TO DO PREVENTION AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT NOT TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THE COUNTY
SUPPORT OF THE HOTLINE SINCE
SUBSTANCE GREAT AND IF I MADE
DIRECTOR CAN'T GET A RESPONSE ON
WHY.
TWO YEARS OF FISCAL
APPROPRIATIONS HAVE NOT.
RENDERED ANNALS AND HOP SURE SO
AND TO BE CLEAR WHEN YOUR WEB
FUNDING WAS RECEIVED
SO WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
LAST YEAR.
AND I WOULD SHARE THE
FRUSTRATION IN TERMS OF THE
CONTRACT NEGOTIATION HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN.
REQUIREMENTS IN STATE
CONTRACTING LA THAT WE DON'T.
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY CONTROL
BUT WE CERTAINLY FOLLOW THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES.
THERE'S ALLOWABLE COSTS THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO BE USED IN EXPENDED
AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
REFERENCE BY THE. TESTIMONY ARE
NOT ALLOWABLE AND SO THAT HAS
BEEN PART OF THE NEGOTIATION
BETWEEN US AND THE CONTRACTOR
IS.
THIS THERE ARE STATE CONTRACTING
RULES THAT SAY WE CAN'T PAY FOR
THOSE THINGS AND SO WE'RE
HOPEFUL I'M WE WERE TRYING TO
CLOSE NEGOTIATIONS LAST WEEK.
AND WE HAD TENDERED DONE IT
WOULD CUT CONTRACTOR YOU TALKING
LIKE CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT I'M
THE PERSON THAT JUST TESTIFIED
FROM DIDI HIRSCH IS THE
CONTRACTOR OKAY.
SO THERE'S DIFFERENT CONTRACTORS
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS WHAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S ONE
OKAY DE HIRSCH BUT. NONE OF JUST
AS WE TALKED ABOUT BREEDING A
FUNDS EARLIER THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US IF COUNTIES
WERE WILLING.
TO BRAID FUNDS TO HELP ENSURE
THAT THIS WAS COMING OUT BECAUSE
THOSE FUNDS DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME.
REGULATIONS AS MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT CORRECT.
IF COUNTY YET IF YOU'RE USING TO
DATE UNDER THEIR STATE
CONTRACTING RULES SO IF YOU'RE
NOT USING STATE FUNDS THEN. IF
THE COUNTIES HAVE DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS BUT.
RIGHT THE NEGOTIATIONS WERE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
CERTAIN.
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE AROUND WHAT
WE CAN AND CAN'T.
YOU STATE FUNDING FOR
SO ALLOW ME TO PUT A PEN EN AND
SAD LIKE TO COME BACK TO A
DISCUSSION WITH EUNICE BARLOW
LATER ON TO SEE IF THERE'S. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO ENSURE
THAT THIS NEEDED EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAM IS IMPLEMENTABLE.
FOR OUR STATE.
IT'S JUST A COMMENT THOUGH I SO
CALLED BACK TO THE BUREAUCRACY
PART.
SO IF THERE'S A A CLEAR SET OF
OF OUR ALLOW BULLS THEN THERE
SHOULD BE NO NEGOTIATION RIGHT.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
COMMENTS ABOUT BUT DIFFICULTY
OVER NEGOTIATIONS IF THERE'S A A
SET STANDARD. BACK TO MY REPORT
CARD.
AND OLOGY IS.
I KNOW IF YOU GET EIGHTY
PERCENT THAT'S BE IF YOU GET
NINETY PERCENT AND ABOVE THAT'S
AND EIGHTY AND IT'S VERY CLEAR.
WILL THERE WOULD THERE SHOULD BE
NO NEGOTIATION BACK AND FORTH IN
MY OPINION. OUT UNLESS THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT I'M MISSING
THAT'S THE BOOK I BARELY MISSING
SOMETHING WELL THERE'S A REASON
WHY WE HAVEN'T SIGNED A CONTRACT
IS THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
WE CANNOT PAY FOR AND THAT
CONTRACTOR HAS WANTED THEM PAID
FOR SO THEY HAVEN'T SIGNED THE
CONTRACT AND SO THAT'S. WHY WE
DON'T HAVE ONE YET WE WOULD LIKE
THERE TO BE A CONTRACT SO I HE I
SEE IN THE BACK? NODS OF NO
THAT'S NOT CORRECT.
SO HOW IS IT THAT I CAN GET THE
EXACT INFORMATION AND MAYBE
YOU'LL AND AND THE CONTRACTOR IN
THE SAME ROOM SO THAT WE CAN
TALK THIS OUT WE COULD DO IT
HERE. FROM.
OR WE CAN DO IT.
YOU KNOW PERHAPS OFF SITE AND
AND SOMEBODY'S OFFICE SO THAT
I'M ABLE TO HEAR BECAUSE IT'S
NOT MAKING SENSE. AND SO.
JUST.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AND I.
I'M FRUSTRATED AGAIN WITH THE
ANSWERS ABOUT YOU KNOW PUTTING
THE BLAME ON SOMEBODY ELSE AND
THAT'S HOW IT FEELS THAT YOU'RE
BLAMING THEM. OUT FOR THIS AND
SO AM I BLAMING THEM TO BE FAIR
WALT BUT THAT'S THE POINT I'M
WHEN I SEE THEM.
SAYING NO AND YOU SAYING YES
THERE'S DEFINITELY.
.
BACK TO MY REPORT CARDS IF
THERE'S A STANDARD THAT YOU.
.
PUT OUT AS.
AND IT'S OUT THERE FOR OF.
I KNOW LONG PERIOD OF TIME IN
THE DOESN'T CHANGE IN BETWEEN
I'M ASSUMING THAT THIS HAD ABOUT
CRITERIA HAS BEEN ON ON. ON THE
BOOKS AND THEY KNOW. OF THE
RULES FOR A LONG TIME.
BECAUSE THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME
DOING A CONTRACT USING THESE
FUNDS BUT ITS STATE FUNDING AS
OPPOSED WE KNOW YOU HAVE TOLD ME
THAT YOU USE THE FUNDS LAST YEAR
YOU DO THEIR SET TWO YEARS OF
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED.
ON THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR THAT
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED THOSE
FUNDS.
OKAY.
I.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE THIS OFF
LINE YEAH.
IF I MAY. EN SENATOR RUBIO THAT
THAT COMMITTEE ALSO HAS THE
OPTION OF EXEMPTING THAT
CONTRACT FROM THOSE RULES.
AND THAT THAT'S THE NEXT
QUESTION THOUGH IF IT'S CRITICAL
TO SERVICES
AN AND I CAN GET INTO THAT BUT
IF IT'S CRITICAL TO SERVICES
WERE NOT BUILDING CARS THIS IS
PREVENTING. LIFESAVING IF NOT
EVEN YOU KNOW OR WITH MIGHT HELP
THEM THIS IS LIFESAVING.
.
SERVICES THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
AND WERE HUG THAT WERE HUNG UP
ON THE TECHNICALITY YET PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING AND AGAIN TO MY
EARLIER QUESTION AT WHAT POINT
DOES THE ACTUAL LIKE A PERSON
SAY HEY. THESE PEOPLE NEED HELP
AS OPPOSED TO. YOU KNOW.
WHATEVER IS GOING ON BECAUSE
CLEARLY THERE'S SOMETHING GOING
ON.
BETWEEN THE CONTRACTORS AND YOU
GUYS.
BUT IF THERE'S EXEMPTIONS THEN.
SOME POINT AT SOME POINT
SOMEBODY HAS TO SAY. THIS IS
PEOPLE THAT ARE LOSING THEIR
LIVES.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT PROVIDING THE
SERVICES WHO IS THAT PERSON.
AND THAT'S
IF YOU CAN ANSWER THAT FOR ME
RIGHT NOW IS WHO IS THAT PERSON
THAT. CAN SIT DOWN AND SAY.
LOGICALLY.
PEOPLE NEED HELP.
AM I THINK WHERE YOU'RE GOING
AND MAYBE THIS WILL BE HELPFUL
IS IF DD HIRSCH COULD COME AND
TESTIFY TO. WEAR SOME OF THE
STRUGGLES CAR BECAUSE THERE'S.
A HURDLE THAT'S DIRECTLY BEFORE
US WE WANT TO REALLY GET PAST A
HOPEFUL YOU'RE HEARING FROM THE
DYESS HERE IS.
OUR INTEREST IN FUNDING THIS
PROGRAM LAST YEAR THAN THE SET
CITY OF THIS PROGRAM AND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT'S GOING ON ITSELF IF YOU
WHAT MAN.
I'M FIRST I WANNA CLARIFY.
THAT I CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERY
COUNTY BUT THE TEN.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LIFELINE IN CALIFORNIA DO GET
SOME DEGREE OF FUNDING FROM
THEIR COUNTIES IT'S JUST THAT.
AS THE NEED HAS GROWN.
THE FUNDING HAS NOT NECESSARILY
KEPT UP BUT I I WANNA.
YOU KNOW ONCE AGAIN CLARIFY THAT
LA HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL.
AN I SOMEONE SAID SOMETHING.
EARLIER I THINK IT WAS SO RIGHT
ON WE CAN'T HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES DECIDING HOW WE'RE
GONNA TAKE CARE OF A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE
BE FUNDING THIS.
.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT I DO I
FEEL MAY BE BUT I MISUNDERSTOOD
THAT YOU SAID WE HAVE RECEIVED.
FUNDS
THE FIRST YEAR'S WORTH OF BONDS.
NOT NOT I THINK WITH YOU I'M NOT
SURE IF.
I THINK THAT THAT THE FUNDING
WITH ALEC
IF YOU WHICH IF MHSAA FUNDING
FOR IT NEEDS TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE.
WHAT MADE IT VERY?
SPRING OF LAST YEAR I HAVE SO I
CAN SPEAK A BIT. LENA HUMPHRIES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
GIVEN THE VOLATILITY OF THAT
MHSAA REVENUES THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATION AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATION. FOR SUICIDE
HOTLINES INCLUDED PROFESSIONAL
LANGUAGE THEN MADE IT CONTINGENT
ON THE BILL BELOW THE OF THOSE
FUNDS WITHIN THE STATE DIRECTED
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES.
SO FINANCE ISSUES A NOTIFICATION
AT THE CLOSE OF THE TALKS HERE
SINCE THESE ARE TAX REVENUES.
THAT ON MARCH THIRTIETH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STATING THAT THERE
WERE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES FOR
THIS APPROPRIATION.
IN APRIL OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THE FUNDS FOR RELEASED RELEASED
THE DEPARTMENT.
FOR THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET
ACT APPROPRIATION AS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
OF FINANCES RECEIVE THE
NOTIFICATION.
BUT A AND WILL BE ISSUING A
NOTIFICATION SORT SHORTLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE THROAT BIBER.
NOT A PLEASE A SOMEWHERE RUBIO I
CAN JUST IS OKAY SO THE QUESTION
WAS UNANSWERED UP.
THE YOUTH SOMEBODY SAID THAT
THAT MONEY WAS GIVEN TO THEM.
HOW THAT MONEY BEEN GIVEN NO WE
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY MONEY
YET WILL PROVIDE ANY HOTTER
ASSOCIATIONS ARE STILL GOING ON
BUT HAD A STATED THAT YOU PLATE
OF THAT I'M HERE DATED SO I
MISSTATED SO IF IT WAS SEAT WITH
THE THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT I'M
HAVING HAD? IT WAS APPROPRIATE
THREE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WHICH
IS MY MISSTATEMENT AND THEN NOW
AND FINANCES CLARIFIED AND I
APPRECIATE THAT PEOPLE BUT IF I
WOULD IN A PROBE THAT
CLARIFICATION WHAT IN THE MAKE
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM THAT I HAVE.
GETTING A MISINFORMATION AND IF
NOBODY PROBES AND CLARIFY THAT
WE DON'T GET THE CORRECT
INFORMATION IN I WOULD ASK THAT
PLEASE NEXT TIME WHEN YOU MAKE
STATEMENTS LIKE THAT THAT
THEY'RE CORRECT. OTHERWISE WE
HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE DYING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
APPROPRIATION AND YOU JUST
STATED THAT YOU DID GIVE THEM
THE MONEY. AND AND WE DID I
THINK YOU RECEIVED THAT I I KNOW
WE SEND IT TO YOU.
.
WE DID SEND A SUMMARY A FIVE
PAGE SUMMARY OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN DIDI
HIRSCH.
AND THE.
.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY MONTHS.
THEN IF IT HIT THEIR EXTRAS HERE
IF ANYONE NEEDS THEM WILL AND
I'M GONNA.
.
TO FOR NOW TO MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS ARE SO.
BUT LET'S LOOK LET'S WALK
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE
HE EVEN AT.
THE TABLES HERE FROM THE DIET IT
SEEMS CONFUSED. THAT THE NOTES I
HAVE HERE.
AND IN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WINNER RELY ON YOU SO.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED.
AND THE FINAL BUDGETS INCLUDED
FOUR MILLION.
AND FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
RESPECTIVELY FOR SUICIDE
HOTLINES.
TRUE OR FALSE
THAT IS CORRECT
WITH OKAY MOTION LANGUAGE SO'S
WORTH OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
SO.
BOTTOM LINE.
IS
THAT'S EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS CORRECT.
WITH A SLIGHT CLARIFICATION
THAT INCLUDE A PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO STIPULATE THAT THERE
WERE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CAP.
SO PROVIDED THAT THERE WERE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES BUT THOSE
FINDINGS WOULD THOSE FUNDS OR
ALL SEEN THAT THE STATE BUDGET
HAS GONE FROM YOU KNOW THE
EIGHTH LARGEST ECONOMY TO THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS I THINK
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FUNDS.
ARM.
TO.
HE HEARS WHAT QUITE FRANKLY IS
REALLY IRRITATING FOR ME. IS I I
KNOW MYSELF I KNOW THE CHAIRMAN.
ALL QUITE A FEW MEMBERS IN THIS
BUILDING WORK VERY VERY HARD
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS.
THE PUSH FOR VETERANS WHO SITE
AWARENESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A MANDATE IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
COUNTING THAT'S.
IFYOU JUST TAKE THAT SIMPLE
NUMBERS TWENTY TWO VETERAN
SUICIDE THE DAY.
ANY A MULTIPLIER THAT OUT FOR
TWO YEARS.
THE NUMBER IS SIXTEEN THOUSAND.
SIXTY VETERAN SUICIDE.
SO WHILE YOU ALL CAN'T FIGURE
OUT WHAT CONTRACT IS WHAT IT.
THAT'S VETERANS DYING ON THE
STREETS NOT TO INCLUDE EVERYBODY
ELSE WHO NEEDS HELP.
WELL LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED DISCUSSION TO GETTING
THIS RIGHT.
WEATHER WE NEED TO CHECK WAY
THAT THE CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION
OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
BUT I'M NOT OKAY WITH PEOPLE
DIED FROM SUICIDE ON OUR STREETS
BECAUSE YOU ALL CAN'T FIGURE OUT
CONTRACTS.
I THINK.
.
IF I.
MAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THE TWENTY TO VETERANS IS A.
NATIONWIDE BUT YOUR.
SENTIMENT IS APPROPRIATE.
IF I MAY ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO
WORK WITH US AND FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN GET PAST THIS ISSUE. SO
WE CAN HELP TO APPROPRIATE THOSE
FUNDS. AND WE KNOW AS WAS STATED
EARLIER WE HAVE THE FUNDS WITHIN
OUR STATE ADMINISTRATION WE NEED
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH.
HOW WE ENSURE THAT THIS HOTLINE
IS AFFECT
SO WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOR?
I DON'T KNOW A NUMBER
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY MISTER EWING.
UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
APPRECIATE THE DEDICATION THE
LONG DAYS GO INTO THIS.
.
YOU KNOW I YEAR YOU KNOW THAT
YOU BY THIS GENERAL QUESTION AS
A PACKET EXPLAINS WORK MORE A
COMMISSION OF THE STATE WERE
INDEPENDENT. THEIR SIXTEEN
COMMISSIONERS ARE TWELVE A WHO
ARE APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THEN A SITTING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SITTING SENATOR THE
SUPERINTENDENT.
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SERVING
THE COMMISSION. I'M WE HAVE THIS
AS WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BROAD
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ROLE. I SHARE WITH YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF THE FUNCTIONS THAT WE
THAT WE TRY TO PUT IN PLACE.
AS I JUST CURIOUS KNOWS WHO'S
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CARILLO SCIENTIST
YEAH EN SENATOR PELL GRANTS AND
SIGHED.
.
YEAH.
HE WE HAVE WE AS I DESCRIBED
THINK THE BEST ANALOGY AS WE ARE
LIKE A MENTAL HEALTH GRAND JURY
BUT OVER THE YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN THE
COMMISSION SOME VERY SPECIFIC
AUTHORITIES. THAT ARE UNLIKE A
GRAND JURY AYE WE REVIEW AND
APPROVE COUNTY INNOVATION PLANS.
AND YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATION. OF THE MONEY THAT
IS SUBJECT AB ONE FOURTEEN IT IS
NORTH OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF
THAT IS INNOVATION MONEY ABOUT
FORTY PERCENT OF THAT IS P. E.
I. OR CSS.
THE COMMISSION DOES REVIEW AND
APPROVE INNOVATION DOLLARS OUR
RESEARCH IN AND WE SHARED THIS
WITH THE AUDITOR AND SHOWS THAT
OUR OUR REVIEW PROCESS IS ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE DAYS.
AND SO THE AUDITOR CONCLUDED
THAT DELAYS ON OUR SIDE ARE NOT
THE REASON WHY COUNTIES ARE
SPENDING THESE FUNDS IN FACT
THERE ARE. THINGS SEVEN COUNTIES
BASED ON THE LATEST RESEARCH
THAT HAVE NEVER BROUGHT AN
INNOVATION PLAN BEFORE THE
COMMISSION.
AS YOU'VE SEEN IN THE IN THE
PACKET SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
FURTHER ITEMS WE ARE WORKING TO
STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS WHAT WE
REALLY WANT IS INNOVATION TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
THAT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
THE LANGUAGE OF THE OF THE
POLICY IS QUITE ELEGANT.
AND THAT IS PUSHING OUR SYSTEM
TO BE PREVENTION ORIENTED TO TO
REALLY FOCUS ON EARLY
INTERVENTION AND IT SEES THIS
THIS SIR. SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OVERALL
IT'S ABOUT ONE TO ONE AND A HALF
PERCENT OF MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS
BUT IT'S TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
TO CHANGE THE WAY. WE DELIVER
SERVICES TO REALLY DRIVE TOWARD
BETTER OUTCOMES BETTER
EFFICIENCIES N TERMS OF THAT
CARE AND AND WE'RE STRUGGLING TO
DO THAT BUT WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT IN THE LATER AND AN ITEM.
WE DO A FEW OTHER THINGS.
WE HAVE WE HAVE TRIAGE FUNDS
THAT ARE ALSO ON YOUR AGENDA
ITEM WE SEE THOSE AS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT TOOL WHICH TO THOSE
HAS INCENTIVE FUNDS.
WAYS THAT WE CAN REALLY
ENCOURAGE PUSH OR INCENTIVIZE
COUNTIES TO TRY THINGS THAT THEY
MAY NOT BE DOING ON THEIR OWN.
AND SO RECENTLY THE COMMISSION
THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE DECISION
DEDICATED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF THOSE FUNDS TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS.
BECAUSE IN WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE AROUND KIDS IN CRISIS WE'RE
FINDING THAT CHILDREN OFTEN
PRESENT IN CRISIS IN A SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT RIGHT THERE ARE
THOSE CRISES AT THREE IN THE
MORNING WHERE THE CALLING NINE
ONE ONE. THE QUITE OFTEN IT IS
IN A SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT WE'VE
HEARD HORROR STORIES
OF SCHOOLS CALLING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PUT A CHILD IN
HANDCUFFS BUT IN THE BACK OF A
POLICE CAR. AND DRIVE THEM DOWN
TO LIKELY ARE AND THAT'S VERY
TRAUMATIZING ON TOP OF THE
ORIGINAL CRISIS.
SO THE COULD THE COMMISSION A
ADMINISTERS PART OF THE STATE'S
SPD TWO AND A HALF WHILE THE
SACK WITH TALK TO THE BIT ABOUT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE WE HAVE A
RESEARCH EVALUATION WORK SO THAT
THE WORK THAT THAT REALLY LED TO
THE AUDIT IN TERMS OF
MONITORING.
EVER VERSION FUNDS I WAS PART OF
THAT WE RECENT YOU TO REPORT ON
THE INTERSECTION OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND MENTAL HEALTH. AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOUND THAT TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THEIR FIRST MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONTACT THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE. AND WE'RE WORKING
TO TRY TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS THERE
THAT'S ALSO ONE YOUR DENTAL
LATER IN THE DAY.
WE'VE WE'VE GOT A PROJECT ON
THE HEALTH IN THE SCHOOLS FOR
DENNIS'S HAD PREVENTION WE
TALKED ABOUT.
WE DO ISSUE REGULATIONS AND A
SUMMER RUBIO I'VE ASKED THE
STARTED TO GIVE YOU THE ACTUAL.
YOUR ELF THE WEBSITE YEAH I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND
DEMONSTRATE THAT. AND AND AND
THAT WE'RE DOING A NUMBER OF
THINGS AS WE TALKED ABOUT TO
REALLY MAKE IT EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE MONEY'S
COMING FROM WHERE IT'S GOING
WHAT WE'RE GETTING FOR THE
MONEY.
VERY CHALLENGING AND AND TO THE
CHAIRS CORE QUESTION OF AND WE
DO NOT YET HAVE THOSE METRICS
EVEN THOUGH THE STATE HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
ONE.
TO COME UP WITH AGREED UPON SET
OF INDICATORS THAT ALLOW THE
GENERAL PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND.
WELL WE'RE PUTTING MORE MONEY
INTO THE SYSTEM WE HAVE MORE
NEEDS ARE WE GETTING BETTER AT
SERVING THOSE NEEDS AND THAT
CONTINUES TO BE CHALLENGING BUT
I BUT I THINK.
WERE MAKING PROBABLY MORE
PROGRESS IN CALIFORNIA THAN IN
ANY OTHER STATE IN PART BECAUSE
OF THE NATURE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND THE FACT
THAT THAT YOU HAVE THIS.
UNIQUE STATE LEVEL MENTAL HEALTH
GRAND JURY THAT IS WORKING ON
THIS AND AND NOT TRYING TO RUN A
SYSTEM WHILE ALSO OVERSEAS.
IT'S KINDA MIGHTN'T BROAD
OVERVIEW OF IT HAPPEN RESPOND
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALLOW ANY COMMENTS ON
ISSUE FOR.
WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE FOR THIS TIME.
SAYING NONO BRING IT UP TO THE
DIETS AND ASKED QUESTION THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US.
THERE.
IT SEEMS TO BE A DECREASE IN
YOUR BUDGET AND WANTED YOU TO
SEE IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN WHAT
WAS THE RATIONALE BEHIND THAT.
YEAH PRIMARILY THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY WERE IN THERE ONE TIME
INCREASES IN PRIOR YEARS.
THERE WAS FUNDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MADE AVAILABLE
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO ON A ONE
TIME BASIS SUBJECT TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE FUNDS.
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT
SO THE DECLINE IS NOT A DECLINE
IN THE COR IN OUR CORE OPERATING
BUDGET IT'S A REFLECTION OF
THESE ONE TIME EXPENDITURES THAT
ARE NO LONGER REFLECTED IN THE
BUDGET.
I'M FROM THE OUTSIDE THE OF
APPEARANCES THAT WERE DECREASING
OVERSIGHT IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE
FOUND IN OUR LAST AUDIT AND.
WE'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY IF YOU
LIKE TO REMEDY THAT. MISTER
CHAIR.
WAS NOT MY SUGGESTION BUT I
APPRECIATE THE INPUT.
THE HOME CINCO MORE FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON ISSUE FOR WE WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE FIVE.
GREAT.
.
SO THAT SO.
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION REVIEWS
AND APPROVING OF EIGHT PER
PROVES COUNTY INNOVATION
PROPOSALS RIGHT WE'VE BEEN.
WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WE KNOW WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE BARRIERS TO
USING THESE DOLLARS EFFECTIVELY.
AND THAT THE COMMISSION.
HAS IDENTIFIED FOUR KEY
CHALLENGES.
FIRST WE'RE NOT SEEING WELL IT
START THIS IS STARTING TO HAPPEN
BUT.
TRADITIONALLY WE WERE NOT SEEING
COUNTIES THAT WERE COMING
TOGETHER AROUND INNOVATION.
EACH COUNTY PREPARED INDIVIDUAL
INNOVATION PLANS AND THEY WERE
QUITE OFTEN FOR A FEW HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR A FEW
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEY WERE
SMALL.
.
A TECHNICAL SORT OF YOU KNOW.
ADJUSTMENTS TO AN EXISTING
PROGRAM TO MEET A GAP IN THEIR
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
INNOVATION COMPONENT DEMENTIA
SAY WAS REALLY INTENDED TO DRIVE
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE
BIG SHIFTS THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTFUL AT THE POPULATION
LEVEL.
AND SO THE COMMISSION IDENTIFIED
THE NEED TO REALLY BRING THE
COUNTIES TOGETHER AROUND SHARED
CHALLENGES
HOW CAN WE PULL THESE DOLLARS SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE IMPACTFUL
OPPORTUNITIES.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE WE TEND
TO SEE COUNTIES THAT ARE DOING
MINOR ADAPTATIONS
PART OF THE REASON FOR THAT WE
BELIEVE IS BECAUSE INNOVATION IS
HARD.
AND COUNTIES ARE PROPOSING
THINGS THAT THEY'RE MORE LIKE TO
BE SUCCESSFUL WITH
AND SOFIA WANT THEM TO BE EDGIER
IN THERE INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
WE NEED TO GIVE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
THAT THE ARTIST THE SECOND
CHALLENGE THE COMMISSION
IDENTIFIED IS OF THE DIFFICULTY
OF EVALUATING THE IMPACT OF AN
INNOVATION OVER A TRADITIONAL
SERVICE.
IN PART BECAUSE VERY FEW
ACCOUNTABLE HEALTH PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY HAVE IN HOUSE
EVALUATORS AND EVALUATION OF
INNOVATIONS ACTUALLY VERY
DIFFICULT.
IN THE FOURTH PIECES BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT DOING THOSE HIGH LEVEL
EVALUATIONS WE REALLY WANTED TO
DO THE DISSEMINATION SO THAT THE
INNOVATIONS PURSUED BY ONE
COUNTY WERE ACTUALLY
INFLUENCING.
ALL OF THE COUNTIES
AND THROUGH THAT WE WERE GETTING
BIGGER BANG FOR THE BUCK IN
TERMS OF THIS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR MANDATORY SET ASIDE FOR
INNOVATION.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
IS A PROPOSAL FOR THAT FOR THE
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP AN
INNOVATION INCUBATOR.
IN FEBRUARY WE ACTUALLY CONVENE
AN INNOVATION SUMMIT AND. WITH
GOOGLE AND CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION THAT I THINK YOU
MISTER EWING YOU MAY BE ONE
ISSUE AHEAD OF US SEMI MONOGRAM
ON ITEM FIVE.
ISSUE FIVE.
INNOVATION PLANNING BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE INNOVATION INCUBATOR
IS THAT WE WERE REFERENCE NO
RIGHT THERE'S THEIR NAME
INNOVATION THERE'S A VERY
SIMILAR I KNOW THERE'S A NAME TO
BE.
RIGHT UP.
I'M WITH YOU OKAY SO WE AT.
.
WE BROUGHT TOGETHER ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE ARE FROM WHAT
WE'LL CALL THE INNOVATION
SECTOR.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE TECH
SECTOR DATA ACADEMIA ALONG WITH
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS COUNTY
OFFICIALS CONSUMERS FAMILY
MEMBERS TO REALLY TALK ABOUT HOW
TO SUPPORT HOW TO DO INNOVATION
AROUND WHAT WE CALL THE HUMAN
CENTERED DESIGN APPROACH. THAT
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY ALSO HOW TO
SUPPORT COUNTIES IN THIS
ENDEAVOR AND SO. THAT WAS A ONE
DAY WORKSHOP WE RECOGNIZED THAT
IF WE WANT TO COUNTIES TO
SUCCEED WITH THIS VERY
CHALLENGING TASK OF INNOVATING
THROUGH THE PUBLIC SECTOR WE
NEED DIVIDE THEM SUPPORT. SO
WHAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU IS
A PROPOSAL TO LAUNCH AN
INNOVATION INCUBATOR. FIVE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AS A
FOUNDATIONAL MONEY TO SET IT UP.
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THEY'VE ASKED US
TO FOCUS THAT ON REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF CONSUMERS WHO ARE
INVOLVED WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE
MHSAA.
WE'RE THRILLED WITH THE SUPPORT
AND THE PROPOSAL PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT WITH
THAT WE RELEASED LAST NOVEMBER
THAT HIGHLIGHTED MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES KEEPING FOLKS WITH
AND HOW NEEDS OUT OF JAIL.
BUT.
I DON'T WANT TO LOSE THE
QUESTION AND I AM.
THAT ISN'T BY THE TIME THEY'RE
INTERFACING WITH OUR JAIL SYSTEM
AREN'T WE. ALREADY LATE
ABSOLUTELY WOULDN'T THERE BE A
MORE APPROPRIATE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
UPSTREAM THAN ACTUALLY RECEIVING
THEM IN A.
CRIMINAL SYSTEM ABSOLUTELY ANY
INTENTION IS NOT TO INNOVATE
AROUND HOW TO RESTORE COMPETENCY
THE INNOVATION IS HOW TO INVEST
IN WHAT WE CALL THE ZERO
INTERCEPT SO USING WHAT'S CALLED
THE SEQUENTIAL INTERSTATE MODEL
THE ZERO INTERCEPT MODEL. IS TO
PROVIDE COMMUNITY SERVICES IN
LIEU OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT RIGHT THAT THAT THE
REALITIES SO YOU MAY HEAR LATER
ON IN THE DAY ARE AT YOUR NEXT
MEETING THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
HOSPITALS WILL TALK WITH YOU
ABOUT FORTY SEVEN PERCENT OF THE
FOLKS WHO WERE DEEMED COMPETENT
STAND TRIAL. WE'RE NOT GETTING
MEDICAL SERVICES IN THE SIX
MONTH WINDOW PRIOR TO A FELONY
ARREST.
THESE ARE THE FOLKS WHO ARE MOST
SEVERELY ILL WHY AREN'T WE
SERVING THEM.
SO THE THE GOAL HERE IS TO
CREATE A FORUM WHERE WE CAN
BRING THE COUNTIES TOGETHER. TO
CONNECT THEM TO EACH OTHER TO
CONNECT THEM WITH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS AND REALLY LEVERAGE THE
INNOVATION INVESTMENT IN WAYS
THAT ACTUALLY REDUCE THAT
CRIMINAL REDUCES THAT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT WORTH TRYING
BY GOOD YEAH. JUST NO INNOVATION
NEEDED JUST PUT CALPERS IN THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. UP MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS IN THEM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS NOT
ACADEMIC COUNTERS.
AND I AND I AM BEING SARCASTIC
OBVIOUSLY BUT THAT THERE IS NO I
ONLY PARTIALLY PUT IT EXACTLY
PUT THEM IN THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND YOU
WILL MAKE SURE. I CAN GUARANTEE
YOU THAT THAT WOULD REDUCE
SIGNIFICANTLY I I WOULDN'T KNOW
THE NUMBERS YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
THE INNOVATIVE THE INNOVATORS
GIVE ME THOSE NUMBERS BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IF YOU PUT. MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS. BATON
THAT WOULD CHANGE THE I'M SORRY
I JUST HAVE TO INTERJECT THERE
THAT'S OUR PROPOSAL NUMBER SIX.
WELL ISSUE NUMBER SIX SUCH.
.
A I THINK THE COMMISSION AGREES
WITH YOU RIGHT IS THAT THAT
THESE FUNDS NEED TO BE USED
AGAIN THEIR EYES YOU KNOW
SOMEWHERE IN THE ORDER OF TWO
AND A HALF TO THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
RIGHT THAT IS NOT CONSISTENT
BEING USED IN WAYS THAT ARE
REDUCING CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT OR REDUCING SCHOOL
FAILURE RIDE IN AND SO THAT'S
THIS THIS TO WERE NOT THIS
ACTUALLY ON TWO SEPARATE
PROPOSALS THERE'S A NAY PARDON
TO BE PART THE A IS BECAUSE IT
IS INCLUDED IN THE. GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO BE IS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE
THIS BUDGET
SO WHAT WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
DO IS GET A PATH TO SUCCESS FOR
INNOVATION IN CALIFORNIA BY
CREATING A VENUE AND WE'VE
DESIGNED THIS THAT THE STATE
LEVEL ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS AND
TO SAY STATE FUNDS. WOULD
BASICALLY SEED AND LAUNCH THIS
THIS ENTITY WE WERE CONTRACTED
OUT TO A NONPROFIT BECAUSE
THEY'RE SMARTER PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD AND WE ARE NOT OF HOW TO
DO IT.
AND THE IDEA IS THAT WE WILL
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO BE OF
THE USE THEIR EXISTING FUNDS TO
PAY FOR THAT SEWER SERVICE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS IT'S A MARKET TEST
IN THE IDEAS OF WEAKENED SUPPORT
THEIR ABILITY. TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY GIVEN THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE HIGHLIGHT
THE EVALUATION AND DO THAT THE
LEARNING THAT COMES OUT OF THAT
STATEWIDE THEN THEY CAN YOU KNOW
USE OUR INNOVATION DOLLARS
ACTUALLY. NO PAY FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE DESIGNING
BUT THE INCUBATOR DOES IS HELP
THEM DESIGN THEM IN A
COLLABORATIVE STRATEGY AND OVER
TIME THEY WOULD USE THEIR
FUNDING TO PAY FOR THAT SERVICE
ONCE THE INITIAL STATES INITIAL
INVESTMENT IS GONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO ANY
COMMENTS ON ISSUE FIVE.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
OASES PROPOSAL FOR INCOMPETENT
ARE FOR. THE MENTAL HEALTH
INNOVATION PLANNING ASSISTANCE
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S TAILORED TO
THOSE WHO ARE MENTALLY ILL.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OF INCREASED
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
FIVE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU KIRSTEN BARLOW ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
DON'T HAVE A CONCRETE POSITION
ON THIS VERY SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
NOR THE CHILDREN'S INCUBATOR
THAT'S ABOUT TO FOLLOW. HOWEVER
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THESE ARE
STATE ADMIN FUNDS WHICH WE
DISCUSSED QUITE A BIT EARLIER
AND FROM WHAT I CAN UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A TEN MILLION DOLLAR ASK
WHEN YOU COMBINE THE TWO.
I WOULD ONLY IT'S SORT OF POSE
THE QUESTION ABOUT PRIORITY
SETTING.
WHEN AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE THE
STATE EVALUATION OF THE OUTCOMES
OF OUR CURRENT INVESTMENTS LET
ALONE APPROPRIATING ANOTHER TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO LOOK AT SOME
TIME AND ASPECT OF THE ACT THAT
MAKES UP LESS THAN FIVE PERCENT
OF THE SERVICES THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED LOCALLY. SUMMER JUST
A QUESTION FOR CONSIDERATION
ABOUT OUR PRIORITIES WITH STATE
ADMIN DOLLARS.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
KIMBERLY CHEN WITH A CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMISSION'S
FOCUS ON ENGAGING COUNTIES AND
WITH REGARD TO THE. INNOVATION
FUNDS AND.
SPECIFIC TO THE TV CONTRACT WE
ARE ENCOURAGED THAT WE SEE TO
INCLUDE T. TO STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE PROJECT.
AT INNOVATION AND AND IT IS A
NECESSARY PART.
THAT AND IT'S BEING GENERATED A
WITH COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS BUT
THE.
APPROVAL PROCESS AND OTHER
FACTORS.
DO PERCENT CHALLENGES IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH
COMMUNITY A STAKEHOLDERS AND
COUNTIES I'M SOME OF GOTTEN.
APPROVAL FOR PROJECTS THAT
SPECIFICALLY US SERVE TO REDUCE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
THERE A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE'VE.
WOULD HAVE GATHERED FROM THAT.
ONE OF WHICH IS TO CLARIFY THE
CRITERIA FOR INNOVATION.
TO PROVIDE T. TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AS WELL AS CREATING A SET OF
STANDARD EVALUATION MEASURES FOR
THE PROJECTS TO PROVIDE T. A FOR
THAT UP.
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
FUNNY COMMENTS WE MAY HAVE.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD ISSUE FIVE
OPEN BUT WANT TO ON.
AB SAY INNOVATION IS ONE OF
THOSE AREAS WHERE IT IS BETTER
FOR US TO COLLABORATE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF MERITS TO THIS
PROPOSAL THAT YOU BRING HERE
TODAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE SIX.
BUT IF YOU SIX IS BASICALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT THE NEEDS ARE
MUCH GREATER THAN SIMPLY THE
POPULATION THAT IS INVOLVED WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
PARTICULAR ON CHILDREN AND SO
YOU KNOW RECOGNIZING THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COMMENTARY ON
CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS.
THE THERE'S AN EQUAL.
.
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT HAS TO GET
DONE IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING THE
ABILITY OF COUNTIES TO USE THESE
FUNDS EFFECTIVELY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN IN A
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES SO WHAT. WE'RE NOT
ENVISIONING TO SEPARATE
INCUBATORS HERE OR REP WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE ENVISIONING AS
A POT OF FUNDS.
THAT CAN BE USED TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS RECOGNIZING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THE IS
INCLUDED THE ORIGINAL FIVE
MILLION AND THEY'RE FOR ADULTS.
THAT WE THINK THAT.
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WOULD ALLOW
THAT INCUBATED ALSO FOCUS ON THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELIA.
THE ADMINISTRATION.
DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS PROPOSAL WE WERE UNAWARE
AND HAVE NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW OR ANALYZE IT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE SIX
OF THE STUFF.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIN SHELTON
WITH STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
I'M IT'S QUIT SCHOOL THERE ARE
REALLY KEY ACCESS POINT FOR THE
EARLY INTERVENTION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND WE
BELIEVE THIS PROJECT CAN DO. A
LOT MORE TO STRENGTHEN THOSE
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELEN RA THOUSAND TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS WHERE IT REALLY
SUPPORT THESE NEW AND OF WAIT
THEY HAVE WAYS OF LOOKING
PARTICULARLY FOR SCHOOLS. WHERE
THE KIDS ARE WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM WHERE THE FUNDING
FOR THESE PROPOSALS ARE THANK
YOU?
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS.
.
I MEAN ED MIGHT TWO CENTS BUT.
WE HELD A HEARING A WEEK AGO ON
ACES AND.
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LOOK AT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING. AND
THAT INTERFACE BETWEEN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
SCHOOLS AND HOPE THIS.
INNOVATION INCUBATOR MAY BE A
SOURCE TO A HELP.
PROMOTE THAT DISCUSSION WITH
THAT WILL HOLD ISSUE SIX OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVEN.
OKAY.
AND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ITEM ITEM
SEVEN AND I WANT TO INTRODUCE
OUR VICE CHAIR. MISTER COULD
TERRIFY ME TAMPLIN.
THAT SHIELD TALKS ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL BUT
JUST FOR FOR BACKGROUND.
THE DEPARTMENT MENTAL HEALTH
BEFORE IT WAS DISSOLVED HAD A
SERIES OF CONTRACTS FOR
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY. WHEN IT
WAS ELIMINATED WHEN THE
DEPARTMENTS ELIMINATED THOSE
FUNDS CAME TO THE COMMISSION AT
THAT TIME THERE WAS ABOUT ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
OUR BUDGET FOR FOUR SEPARATE
CONTRACTS TARGETING CONSUMERS.
FAMILY MEMBERS CHILDREN AND
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH. AND OVER
THE COURSE OF A COUPLE OF YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE INCREASED
FUNDING TO THE COMMISSION FROM
ONE POINT NINE MILLION TO FOUR
POINT SEVEN. ADDING FUNDS FOR
VETERANS REDUCING DISPARITIES
THE LGBTQ POPULATION BUT ALSO.
ANA ELEVATING THE FUNDING LEVEL
TO AN EQUAL SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND PER YEAR PER
DEMOGRAPHIC TARGET.
WE ISSUE THOSE DOLLARS IN A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS THAT
WAS A CHANGE THAT WE DISCUSSED
WITH YOU WHEN THOSE ALLOCATIONS
FOR INCREASED AND IS NOW.
STANDARD PRACTICE SOMETHING
THAT YOU ASKED US TO DO. AND SO
I'M WHAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU IS A PROPOSAL FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER DOLLARS
THE THESE DOLLARS ARE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE. THESE ALLOW US TO FIND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY REALLY
TRYING TO DRIVE THAT
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE INTO THE
DECISIONS OF THE COUNTIES ARE
MAKING BUT I'M I'M GOING TO
DEFER TO MY. VICE CHAIR TED TALK
THE SPECIFICS OF THE PROPOSALS
AND HE TOLD ME AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS TARA
SLIMY TAMPLIN AND. I'M THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE MEDICAL SERVICES
OVERSIGHT INCOME ABILITY
COMMISSION I WAS APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR AS A. ON THE
COMMISSION AS A MENTAL HEALTH
CONSUMER SIDE RECEIVE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND OUR
COUNTY SYSTEM AND ALSO CURRENTLY
AND MY MOM'S INTERPRETER AND
SUPPORTER FOR HER MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE COUNTY.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT SPECIFIES THAT THE IMAGE
IT'S A FUNDS BE USED TO SUPPORT
CONSUMERS AND FAMILY MEMBERS AND
TO PARTICIPATE IN POLICY AND
PROGRAM.
DECISIONS IN THESE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS REALLY WILL SUPPORT
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY FOR THOSE
PURPOSES.
IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR AND
SPITS SPECIFICALLY FOR.
INDIVIDUALS HAVE WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS AND OUR.
AND OUR STATE IN NOVEMBER OF
LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION
REPORTED THAT TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE ACCESSING. ON
MENTAL HEALTH CARE THROUGH LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ON THESE FUNDS
WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT WE
DEVELOP COMMUNITY BASED
STRATEGIES.
AND TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE RATHER THAN INCARCERATE
PEOPLE. AND BECAUSE OF UNMET
UNMET HEALTH NEEDS
AND SIMILARLY THE COMMISSION IS
HER TESTIMONY THAT MANY
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES.
FACE CHALLENGES ACCESSING CARE.
FOR REFUGEES SOMEWHERE TO ME
AND MY FAMILY WHO CAME HARRIS
REFUGEES FLEEING THE AFGHAN
SOVIET WAR WE'VE HEARD MANY TALK
ABOUT.
HOW THEY HAVE ARRIVED IN OUR
STATE AND OFTEN EXPERIENCING
EXTREME TRAUMA ABUSE OTHER
HARDSHIPS ON?
AND ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES CAN MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEIR
SUCCESSFUL TRIP SETTLEMENT AND
OUR COMMUNITIES OR PROLONG STE
STRUGGLES.
FOR IMMIGRANTS
A CLIMATE IN THE US THESE DAYS
IS NOT ALWAYS WELCOMING.
.
THAT WE'VE HEARD STORIES ABOUT
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN WHO ARE
AFRAID TO GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCARED THAT THEIR
PARENTS.
THE MOM AND DADS ARE NOT GOOD
ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN AWAY NOT
HOME AFTER THEY'VE LEFT
SCHOOL WE'VE HEARD MANY STORIES
ABOUT YOUNG FOLKS THAT ARE DACA
RECIPIENTS AFRAID TO LEAVE THE
HOUSE FOR ANY KIND OF.
SUPPORT AND SO A AGAIN ACCESS
TO PROGRAM IN THE HEALTH CARE
CAN BE ESSENTIAL TO THEIR WELL
BEING.
.
SUPPORT THE SCHOOLS REDUCING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT AND
SUPPORTING IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES
THE COMMISSION IS ASKING FOR ONE
POINT THREE FOUR MILLION TO
SUPPORT TO ADDITIONAL
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY CONTRACTS.
AS AND. OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
HAS SHARED.
THESE FUNDS WILL SUPPORT
OUTREACH EDUCATION AND TRAINING
AND ADVOCACY AND.
THERE I THINK REALLY CRITICAL
TO HELPING ALSO. ALLOWING THAT
COMMUNITY TO FIND A VOICE FEEL
EMPOWERED GET CONNECTED TO
OTHERS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING BUT
ALSO FIGURE OUT HOW TO NAVIGATE
OUR SYSTEM WHICH IS COMPLICATED
AND IT DEPENDS ON WHICH COUNTY
URINE. SO WE REALLY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THOSE COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER TO SPEAK AND UNDERSTAND
THEIR NEEDS AND GET BETTER SERVE
THE NEEDS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. CRISCO AND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I.
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
WE'RE GONNA ICAP SEEING THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC I HELD
NETWORK SENATE FROM SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSED INVESTMENT I
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES HAVE FACE
LONGSTANDING BARRIERS
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACCESS TO
SOCIAL SERVICES AND HEALTH CARE.
ARE GIVEN THAT YOU'RE MATTER CAN
OFTEN VIOLATE MIGRATORY
EXPERIENCE IS COUPLED WITH
MISCONCEPTIONS OF RECEIVING A
HEALTH SERVICES THE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL WELL BEING OF IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES ARE PARTICULARLY AT
RISK.
OFFER MANY IT'S LIKELY THAT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES EXPERIENCE
BEFORE AND AFTER.
THEY ARRIVE MIGHT GO
UNDIAGNOSED AND UNTREATED FOR
YEARS
I LAST YEAR ICE DEPORTED THIRTY
SEVEN PERCENT MORE PEOPLE LIVING
WITHIN THE U. S. SENATE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN. ARE A
RECENT SURVEY AYE CFTC HELPED
CONDUCT OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
I HEALTH CARE EXPERTS PROVIDERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA UNDERSCORED
THE REALITY THAT IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ARE INCREASINGLY
FEARFUL. OF ENROLLING IN PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS DUE TO
AGGRESSIVE DEPORTATION ACTIONS
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I LAST YEAR'S UPC HEARD FROM
NUMEROUS REFUGEES STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT CHALLENGES AN URGENT NEED
TO REFUGEE CALIFORNIANS. ARE
CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC BARRIERS
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
LACK OF MEDICALLY TRAINED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST.
WELL THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
IN WHICH IS ANTI IMMIGRANT
POLICIES AND SYSTEMICALLY
UNDERMINES AYE US REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT AS WE KNOW IT. AYE
WE MUST STILL FIGHT TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF OUR STATE AYE WE
ARE THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THIS
INVESTMENT SO THAT MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
OF CALL CALIFORNIA HOME. ARE
INTENTIONALLY REPRESENTED IN
THESE CRITICAL DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING CALIFORNIA'S MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ELLIOT.
FOUND THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
PROPOSAL.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVEN.
CAN'T REALLY TELL THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK WE
WANNA
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE MENTAL
HEALTH PROPOSAL HERE AS MY
COLLEAGUE. AND AND.
MADAM VICE SHOWS.
SPOKEN TO.
IMMIGRANTS ARE CRITICAL IN
GONNA REFUGEES ARE CRITICAL TO.
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR OUR
SOCIETIES AND WE VALUE THEM
DEEPLY AND THAT'S THE STATE HAS
DONE.
TAKING MULTIPLE ACTIONS ON
OTHER POLICY AREAS TO PROTECT
IMMIGRANT COMMITTEES WE THINK
MENTAL HEALTH IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS PART OF THAT.
FROM OF THE WORK ON FROM THE
FEDERAL THREATS IN DHAKA TO.
THE MUSLIM THAN IN AND.
IT IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
SOMEONE WHO IS DIRECTLY IMPACTED
IT CREATES A SENSE THAT YOUR
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE PERHAPS YOU'RE
NOT WELCOME HERE PERHAPS ARE NOT
AS VALUED AND. BUT WE REJECT
THAT NOTION AND A STRONG SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER JUST WANTED
TO LEND OUR BOYS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU BECAME.
ADRIN TALK ABOUT THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL THIS IS AN
UNDERSERVED POPULATION WITH
UNIQUE NEEDS AND OFTEN STRUGGLE
TAXES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO SUPPORT THE
ADVOCACY. TO ENSURE THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE THEIR NEEDS
MET.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SEVEN OPEN BUT I WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO SAY THAT THE FEAR IS REAL
BEING BORN AND DELAY NOW IN THE
RECENT. TRAGEDY THAT WE HAD
HAPPENED IN THE LANE L. WHERE.
.
PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITY WERE
ATTEMPTING TO ESCAPE ITS.
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
INVESTMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT'S OCCURRING
TODAY. WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE A
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I WANT THANK THE CHAIR AND ALSO
MEMBERS FOR.
INVITING US MY NAME IS RONALD
WASHINGTON I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
OF THE AYE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
IN THE CHARGES OFFICE.
AND IT WOULD BE ALSO IS OUR
CAROLINE ABUJA ARE SHE OVERSEES
OUR.
OUR GRANT PROGRAMS.
OF WHICH WE WILL.
.
TALK TODAY I JUST GIVE YOU A
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF. THE
INVESTMENT A MENTAL HEALTH
WELLNESS GRANT PROGRAM AND THEN.
SO THE COMPANION TO THAT IS TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH PROGRAM.
SO JUST GIVE YOU A ARM.
ARE A GENERAL OVERVIEW OF SORT
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING WITH
EACH PROGRAM AND KIND OF TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE FINDING
AND.
ARE COMPLIMENTS ON THAT PROGRAM
.
ALSO MET AT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE CAN HAPPEN
PROGRAMMATIC KLAY.
AND THEN.
LASTLY JUST GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF SOME OF THE OVERSIGHT
THAT.
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THROUGH
THE PROGRAM TO HELP US SORT OF
STAY ABREAST OF.
OUR THE PROGRESS OF THE COUNTIES
ARE MAKING WITH THE MONEY.
SO.
.
AS YOU KNOW SENATE BILL.
EIGHTY TWO WAS REALLY FOR.
ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM.
TO EXPAND A MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL CRISIS
STABILIZATION TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND ALSO. PEER
RESPITE PROGRAMS.
THE GOAL IN AND TWENTY FOURTEEN
WAS TO ACTUALLY ADD TWENTY FIVE
ADDITIONAL MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT
TEAMS.
AND ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY TWO
THOUSAND OF A CRISIS
STABILIZATION AND
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL BEARS TO THE
PROGRAM.
SO.
WHAT WE'VE DONE SINCE THAT TIME
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN WITH THAT
WE HAVE ACTUALLY? A APPROVED IN
FIVE SEPARATE FUNDING ROUNDS.
FOUND FIFTY SIX GRANT AWARDS
FOUND THAT BENEFITTED.
FORTY ONE SEPARATE COUNTIES.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THOSE WAS A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN.
FIVE COUNTIES IN THE SUPERIOR
REGION WHERE IT'S A LITTLE
SMALLER SO THEY COLLABORATED ON
A ON.
ON A ON A GRAND AWARD WITH.
BUT MERCED.
DOT COLLABORATION INCLUDED ON
ADDITION TO MERCED MADERA TO
WOLLEMI.
OP CALAVERAS MARIPOSA AND I
BELIEVE STANISLAUS COUNTY.
TO WORK ON ONE FACILITY AND
HAVE A MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT
TEAM THAT WOULD.
PROVIDE.
THE TRANSPORTATION TO THE
FACILITY INMARSAT.
SO THAT ONE HUNDRED AND.
.
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR.
A FUNDING THAT WE HAVE AWARDED
WE HAVE ACTUALLY DISPERSE.
A LITTLE OVER FORTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THOSE FUNDS.
SO ABOUT A THIRD OF THAT.
HAS ALREADY GONE OUT THE DOOR
TO.
.
COUNTIES.
WHAT WE HAVE ADDED OR WHAT WE
HAVE AWARDED SPECIFICALLY ARE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND AN EIGHTY
EIGHT ADDITIONAL VETS?
?
WE HAVE ALSO.
.
OPENED UP DURING THAT PERIOD OF
SEPARATE BEDS.
BUT THEN WE ALSO HAD VEHICLES
AND EQUIPMENT.
.
OF A HUNDRED AND TEN MOBILE
CRISIS SUPPORT TEAM SO.
ABOUT STAFF HAS MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN THAT AREA.
JUST A FEW OF THE THINGS THAT
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES. ALLOWS THE OUT AND.
.
THEY HAVE A HOME ALSO HIRED
FIFTY SEVEN ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR
A MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT TEAM SO.
ALL THE STAFF AND OF THE PROGRAM
THAT WERE AWARDED WERE ALSO
HIRED.
SO THEN.
SECONDLY DON'T TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE CHALLENGES.
SO.
.
THROUGHOUT THE PROGRAM THERE'S
BEEN A A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
THAT STAFF IS EXPERIENCE.
ALL I'LL TOUCH ON JUST A FEW OF
THEM.
.
I WOULD START WITH PROBABLY THE
COUNTIES.
OUR CHILD TO HAVING THE
COORDINATE WITH THEM TO SEVERAL
DIFFERENT APARTMENTS TO GET OUR
APPROVAL OF A PROJECT.
SO YOU MAY HAVE THEIR. THE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND THEY THE
PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT AND THE
REAL ESTATE DEPARTMENT HAVING
TO.
COORDINATE ON THEIR EFFORTS IN
ORDER TO.
.
MAKE THE TIME REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THIS GRANT PROGRAM A MEAT THAT
THE NEEDS OF THE GRANT
REQUIREMENTS IN REGULATION SO.
A WE HAVE EXPERIENCE OVER TIME A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES WITH THEIR
THE INTER DEPARTMENTAL.
LEVELS AT THE COUNTY THAT WE'VE
HAD WORKED. AND HAVE PARTNERED
WITH COUNTIES.
YOU SEE THAT SUCCESSFUL.
ARM.
FOR THOSE COUNTIES THAT WERE NOT
PURCHASING PROPERTY ON COUNTY
OWNED LAND.
OF SOME OF THEM HAVE EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES IN TRYING TO ACTUALLY
FIND PROPER THAT TICKET
PURCHASE.
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE COUNTY
THEMSELVES IN THE REAL ESTATE
DEPARTMENT OR EVEN THREW AWAY
ON.
A OUR SERVICE PROVIDER.
MANY THE COUNTIES USE A SERVICE
PROVIDER TO DELIVER THE SERVICES
AND THAT SERVICE PROVIDER WILL
ALSO.
PURCHASE A PROPERTY TO BE USED
FOR A TWENTY THIRTY APPEAR FOR
THE LIFE OF THE PROJECT.
SO THEY HAVE IN SOME AREAS
EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANT DELAY
AND AND TRYING TO FIND A
PROPERLY CAN PURCHASE IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
ARM.
AND JUST TWO OTHER THINGS I
THINK I WOULD MENTION.
IN IN SOME CASES THERE HAS BEEN
PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH I'M
INTERACTION WITH.
.
CITIES AND COUNTIES OF IS BITS
OF LOCAL OPPOSITION IN THAT IN
SOME INSTANCES.
AND THAT HAS DELAY THE PROCESS
FOR A NUMBER OF COUNTIES.
AND AT LAST ABLE MITCH IN THAT.
.
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE TURN OVER
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED.
I WITH THE COUNTY LEVEL
EXECUTIVES.
.
OFTEN THEY WILL.
HAVE TURNOVER ENABLE.
EITHER PUT THIS PROGRAM OR
PROJECT ON THE BACK BURNER.
OR CHANGE THE PARAMETERS OF A
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN AWARDED
ALREADY SO.
AND THAT HAS CAUSED SOME DELAYS
IN IN AND.
SOME CASES A COMPLETE CHANGE OF
THE PROJECT.
SECULAR.
SO WE'VE HAD WORKED THROUGH
THOSE AND AND MANY OTHER
CHALLENGES.
AS WE'VE PROGRESSED OF THIS
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW.
STAFF IS HAS DONE A A
SIGNIFICANT JOB AND MAINTAIN A
RELATIONSHIP FOR THE COUNTIES ON
AN ONGOING BASIS.
TO TRY TO ALLEVIATE AND OVERCOME
EACH OF THESE CHALLENGES.
W..
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE NIGHT
I THOUGHT SO WELL CHAFF A
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR THAT MUCH
OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
FUNDS AT THE COMMISSION RECEIVES
ARE REALLY DEDICATED TOWARDS
PERSONNEL.
AND WE ISSUE WE PROVIDED A
REPORT TO YOU BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR OUTLINING THE OPPORTUNITIES
BUT ALSO SOME OF THE CHALLENGES.
I THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM AT THE COMMISSION
BECAUSE IT DOES ALLOW US TO
CREATE SOME INCENTIVES
FOR COUNTIES TO DO THINGS THAT
ARE NOT OTHERWISE DOING.
AND I'M MORE AWARE CHALLENGED BY
THAT BECAUSE COUNTIES WILL ALSO
SAY THESE CAN BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT FUNDS THEY HAVE.
AND YET WHEN THE FUNDS RIGHT
NOW.
AND YOU KNOW WE SEE FUNDS IN
THEIR ACCOUNTS AND AND THERE'S
QUESTIONS ARE ON THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE PROGRAM.
AND WE SORT OF QUESTION THAT
RIGHT THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT YOU CAN INVEST IN
MARCH INVESTING YOUR DOLLARS AND
THREE.
BUT EVEN RECOGNIZING THAT THIS
IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT TOOL THAT
THE STATE HAS TO SHAPE HOW
COUNTIES INVEST IN THESE KINDS
OF PROGRAMS.
THE COMMISSION IS A WELL AS THE
COUNTY TO RECEIVE THESE FUNDS
THROUGH OUR FIRST ROUND THE
REALLY WRAPPING UP THAT PROGRAM
AND YOU'LL HEAR THE NEXT ITEM OF
REPORT OUT ON THAT AND THERE ARE
SOME UNSPENT FUNDS.
WE'VE SEEN SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS HAPPEN WITH HIS
DOLLARS WE'VE SEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH GET.
CREATE MUCH STRONGER TEAMS
BECAUSE THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
USED TO PUT PEOPLE IN PATROL
CARS OR IT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHO CAN WORK WITH FAMILIES AFTER
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT LEAVES WHAT
THESE OR OR THERE ARE OUTREACH
STRATEGIES HAPPENING IN HOMELESS
CAMPS BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OR EAT OR.
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSES WHO
ARE YOU KNOW HIRED WITH THESE
DOLLARS SO THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL. WE'VE ALSO SEEN
SOME CHALLENGES MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES ARE CONSISTENT WITH
MY COLLEAGUES ON THAT ON THE
FIFTH ON THE FACILITY SIDE. THAT
IT HAS TAKEN A SOMETIME FOR
COUNTIES TO FIGURE OUT THESE
PARTNERSHIPS.
WE ARE DOING A NUMBER OF THINGS
TO ADDRESS THIS MOVING FORWARD
WHERE START WE'RE ACTUALLY
ENACTED PROCUREMENT NOW FOR
SECOND ROUND OF TRIAGE GRANTS.
THAT RECOGNIZING THAT ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE FUNDS
THAT WERE FIRST ALLOCATED THEIR
ALLOCATED IN A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS FOR THE COUNTIES
IDENTIFIED THEIR GREATEST
PRIORITIES BUT EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THAT WENT TOWARD THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE REALLY
TARGETING ADULTS. ONLY ABOUT
FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN PERCENT
TARGETING CHILDREN.
BECAUSE OF THAT IN THE SECOND
ROUND THE COMMISSION DIRECTED
STAFF TO WRITE THE RFP IN A WAY
THAT AT LEAST HALF THE FUNDS
MUST GO TOWARDS KIDS.
AND WITHIN THAT HALF THAT IS FOR
CHILDREN THEY SET ASIDE A
PORTION TO BUILD STRONGER SCHOOL
COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS AGAIN
BECAUSE I RESEARCH INTO THIS
CRISIS IS FINDING THE KIDS ARE
PRESENTING IN SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS.
SO.
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS
AS WELL TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
DELAYS WE'RE REQUIRING.
LETTERS OF INTENT FOR IT FOR
THAT PARTNERSHIP AS A CONDITION
OF THE APPLICATION SO THAT WHEN
COUNTIES IF THEY'RE RECEIVING
THESE FUNDS ARE NOT FACING THE
SAME KINDS OF DELAYS. IN IN
GETTING AGREEMENTS ACROSS
MULTIPLE ENTITIES.
THE AUDIT POINTED OUT THAT WE
DID NOT DO A STATE LEVEL
EVALUATION DURING THE FIRST
ROUND WE'D WE WE DID REQUIRE THE
COUNTIES DO AN EVALUATION OF
THEIR PROGRAM AND WE DESIGNED
THAT SPECIFICALLY. TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO EVALUATE THEIR PROGRAM
AROUND THEIR NEEDS BECAUSE WE
WANTED IT. TO BE SUSTAINED WITH
THEIR LOCAL DOLLARS
AND SO THE EVALUATIONS REALLY
WERE DESIGNED TO MEET THEIR
INFORMATION NEEDS
THE DOWNSIDE OF THAT. IS THAT
IT'S VERY HARD TO TELL STATEWIDE
STORY YOU GET VERY LOCALLY
RELEVANT INFORMATION THAT VERY
LITTLE THAT TELLS YOU HOW THE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE BEHAVED.
BECAUSE OF THAT CHALLENGE THE
COMMISSION DIRECTED US TO TO
SHIFT COURSE
AND TO A A. FINE A THIRD PARTY
EVALUATION AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL AND SO WERE IN
NEGOTIATIONS NOW TO DO THAT BUT
THE COMMISSION HAS ALREADY
ADMINISTRATIVELY. DIRECTED THAT
THE STAFF TO.
PURSUE THAT STATE LEVEL
EVALUATION WHICH IS HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT.
HABITAT RESPOND ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THAT WORK THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ALEJO ISSUE EIGHT.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE A.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR LINTEL
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
REPRESENTING THAT PROVIDERS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE.
AS SO IT. WAS NOT TOUCH ON WAS
THE CHILDREN.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
AND THAT MONEY IS YOU GOT TO GO
OUT SO LIKE HERE DISCUSSION
EARLIER ABOUT SUICIDE PREVENTION
WE'RE WAITING ON THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT I NEEDED
FOR CHILDREN'S WE HAVE A NINE
YEAR OLD THAT SAT IN AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT IN
TEMPERATE CISCO FOR OVER THIRTY
DAYS JUST BECAUSE THEY HAD
CRISIS NEEDS. THIS IS MONEY THAT
NEEDS TO GO OUT TO SERVICES
THINKING VACUUM.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT CON
ISSUE EIGHT.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT TO THE
DYESS AND SHE.
PREFACED MY QUESTION WELL.
WHAT HAPPENS TO BOTH THE
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SERVICES GRANTS AS WELL AS THE?
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS.
HAVE THESE MONIES BEEN
APPROPRIATED AND.
WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR THE?
SO.
YEAH.
.
UNDER TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
I WAS HOPING TO GET TO IT BUT.
SO.
WE HAVE OF FUNDS THAT WERE
APPROPRIATED IN THE BUDGET.
.
BOTH GENERAL FUND AND AND NOW
IMAGES SAY DOLLARS.
.
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET TOTAL ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
THEY ARE.
DIVIDED UP AMONG A A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT CENTERS AS I MENTIONED
CRISIS STABILIZATION.
THE ENTIRE GAMUT THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE UNDER OUR
REGULAR S. B. EIGHTY TWO MONEY.
SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO NOW
IS A COUPLE THINGS WE WANT TO
GET OUR REGULATIONS OUT THAT WE
CAN BEGIN.
TO DO.
AN APPLICATION PIER AND GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS FOR
AWARDING GRANTS.
BOB. WHAT YOU SAID TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION AND THE COMBINATION OF
BOTH OF THOSE IS OVER EIGHTY
MILLION?
WHAT IF WE LOOK AT COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS WAS A ONE
TIME SIXTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION? GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION AND THE.
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
SERVICES GRANTS WERE SEVENTEEN
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND.
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW IT IS THAT YOUR BALANCES
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION IF.
WE'VE.
IN OUR GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATED
MORE FUNDS THAN THAT.
CERTAINLY ME I'M CLEAR I WAS
REFERRING TO JUST TO CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BECAUSE I HADN'T
GOTTEN TO THE IT INFRASTRUCTURE
PIZZA PARA.
SO.
THE CHILDREN YOU PIECE IS REALLY
COMPOSED OF TWO PARTS OF ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR POT AND ALSO A
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLAR PART.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE GOING TO BE
USED FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
THAT'S THAT'S A PIECE THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON DEVELOPING.
REGULATIONS FOR.
BUT ONE OF THE THE CHALLENGES
WERE HAVING AND WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS TRYING TO.
BOB ALLYING.
.
FUNDING STREAMS AND WHICH.
MONIES HAVE TO BE SPENT.
AND ALSO ENCUMBERED SO BAD. ON
IF WE'RE OVER SUBSCRIBED IN.
ONE AREA AND UNDER SUBSCRIBE TO
ANOTHER AREA SO FOR INSTANCE IF
WE HAVE.
A LACK OF RESPONSE.
IN.
MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT TEAMS.
AND AND MORE THAN ENOUGH
RESPONSE IN FAMILY RESPITE CARE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ABILITY TO
MOVE THOSE FUNDS FROM ONE POT TO
THE NEXT.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWENTY
SIXTEEN FUNDS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
SPENT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SO HOW OF WE APPROPRIATELY
INSURED THAT THE MONEY IS
GETTING OUT THE DOOR TO DEAL
WITH THE. CRISES THAT WE HAVE
GOING ON EACH AND EVERY DAY.
BECAUSE THESE HAVE NOT BEEN.
.
THEY DON'T HAVE REGULATIONS FOR.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVEN MINUTES
ALSO SO.
BECAUSE THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN ARE PRETTY
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF THEIR
POTS.
SO FOR INSTANCE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
WE HAVE AN AMOUNT.
THAT CAN BE YOU SPECIFICALLY FOR
MOBILE CRISIS AND FAMILY RESPITE
CARE BUT.
IT CANNOT BE USED IN ANY OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND WE ALREADY KNOW THAT DEMAND
FOR INSTANCE
IT'S GOING TO BE.
FAR LAST IN THE MOBILE CRISIS
SUPPORT TEAM.
AS AN EXAMPLE SO WE HAVE SEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION ABOUT
AVAILABLE TO US.
TO MAKE GRANTS FOR MOBILE CRISIS
SUPPORT TEAMS.
WHERE?
CONFIDENT THAT THAT WILL BE
SEVERELY UNDER SUBSCRIBED.
AS A COMPARISON.
IN THE A REGULAR SB EIGHTY TWO
INVESTMENT MENTAL WELLNESS
HEALTH PROGRAM WE HAD. A HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAD ABOUT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
POWER THAT WAS USED FOR MOBILE
CRISIS SUPPORT TEAM SO WE KNOW.
THAT AMOUNT IS GOING TO BE UNDER
SUBSCRIBED.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS TO BILL
TO MOVE IT AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE
TO ONE OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS?
SO THAT MONEY ISN'T LOST.
HOW MUCH OF THOSE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN SPENT SO FAR THAT WERE
APPROPRIATED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN?
BUT NONE OF THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
SPENT SO FAR THEY'VE NOT ISN'T
THERE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
IF THEY WERE APPROPRIATED FOR A
CRISIS CENTER. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT WE HAVE NOT ESTABLISHED A
CRISIS CENTER. BY TWENTY EIGHT.
WHEN CAN WE EXPECT REGULATIONS
TO BE BEFORE US SO THAT THE
FUNDS WE APPROPRIATED TWO YEARS
AGO. ARE BEING EFFECTIVE FOR
THEIR DOESN'T PURPOSE.
ARE.
SO.
A PART OF THE CHALLENGE OF WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WAS
WORK.
DEPARTMENT FRANCE YOU THINK IT
THE POTS LINED UP SO THAT WE CAN
THEN BEGIN TO DO REGULATION.
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUMP IN HERE IS THERE SOMETHING.
THAT WE CAN DO WHAT CAN WE DO TO
HELP TO ENSURE THAT THIS MONEY
IS.
AGAIN BEING AFFECT THEM MISTER
CHAIR MARIKA'S ACCOMPANY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I FIRST
WANT TO CLARIFY.
HOW THE COLOR OF THE MONEY HAVE
CHANGED SO IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
REVIEWED APPROPRIATE?
SIXTEEN MILLION FOR IT
CHILDREN'S CRISIS SERVICES
GENERAL FUND AND THEN WE ALSO
PROVIDED ELEVEN MILLION OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACCOUNT.
A YEAR LATER AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AS YOU ALL KNOW WE ARE
REVENUES HAVE. GONE DOWN WE CAN
HAVE THE GENERAL FUND THEM THERE
TO FUND THIS INVESTMENT SO. WE
WE HAD TO LIKE TAKE BACK THE
GENERAL FUND BUT WE REPLACE IT
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACCOUNT FUNDS
SO. IN TWENTY TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING
IS GOOD TO BE APPROPRIATED BILL
TWENTY NINETEEN AND IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FUNDING.
IN ADDITION TO YOU KNOW TO
REPLACE THE GENERAL FUND THAT WE
REMOVE THIS GOOD FOR A
INCUMBENTS UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
AND I THINK THAT GOES INTO THE.
THE CHALLENGE THAT THE OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE AUTHORITIES
AND. IS A ADDRESSING IN ADDITION
TO THE FACT THAT IT'S ALSO A
NEW.
A NEW PROGRAM I MEAN S. B. TO
WAS TARGETED TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADULTS AND CHILDREN.
WHEREAS S. B. AM EIGHT THIRTY
THREE IS MORE TOWARDS PEDIATRIC
CRISIS. AND ALSO WE AS FAR AS
THE.
DELINEATION IN THE CATEGORIES
WERE YOU KNOW SUMMERS ARE ARE.
PEGGED FOR CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT SUMMER FOR QUESTIONS
THAT POSITION SERVICES AND UNIT
SOMEWHERE FOR MORE BUT CRISIS
THEME SUMMER FOR FAMILY RESPECT.
THOSE WERE THE DIVISION OF.
THOSE AMOUNTS WERE SCHEDULE
BASED ON THE GOALS THAT WERE SET
AT THE TIME THAT WE WERE
DEVELOPING THE FUNDING FOR S. B.
THREE THREE SO. EVEN THOUGH.
SO THIS ONE THING THAT WERE
INCOMPLETE IN CONTINUE
DISCUSSION WITH THE AUTHORITY
IT'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS IN THE
LOCAL. IN A LOCAL CLUB. IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY BUT ALSO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE GOALS THAT
WERE SET BY THE BY THE THE
STATUTE MIGHT WAS PASSED IT'S SO
HARD TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS OF KNOW MONEY'S GONE OUT
THEM.
I MEAN I'M NOT TRYING TO
CONTINUE A POINT AND I HOPE.
TO LEAVE IT THERE I JUST AM
HOPEFUL OF WORKING WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THAT. WE
CAN HELP TO GET THAT MONEY OUT
FOR THE CRISES THAT WE HAVE
GOING ON EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AND WITH THAT I HOPE WE CAN TURN
THE DISCUSSION NOW TO THE
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
PORTION OF THIS AND. I'M HERE
THE APART SO THAT THE COMMITTEE
SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM WAS THAT A SIXTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR.
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION.
BOB AND SO. WE ARE IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF REALLY ACTUALLY
DEVELOPING.
.
STAKEHOLDER A GROUP THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH SO WE CAN
GO ABOUT THE PROGRAM IT
OBVIOUSLY.
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ARE NOT OUR AREA OF EXPERTISE SO
WE WANTED TO.
MAKE SURE WE FIRST IDENTIFIED.
GROUPS THAT WE COULD WORK WITH
AND THAT CAN HELP US TO DEVELOP
AND BUILD A PROGRAM.
I IN PART BASED ON USING SOME OF
THE EXPERIENCES WE'VE LEARNED
WHAT THE S. B. EIGHTY TWO
INVESTMENT IN MENTAL HEALTH
WELLNESS GRANT PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HAVE MET WITHOUT THE
COUNCIL ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE AT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
BOARD OF.
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS CON
BEHAVIOR HELP DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
AND A FEW OTHERS THAT I. SORT OF
HELPED US BEGIN TO.
DEVELOP WHAT WOULD MAKE SENSE
FOR A FACILITIES BASED PROGRAM
THAT WEEKEND.
USED THESE FUNDS FOR SOME TO
DEVELOP AND BUILD FACILITIES.
UP FOR THIS POPULATION BUT.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE WE ARE
IN TERMS OF.
DEVELOPING THE PROGRAM JUST
REALLY GETTING STAKEHOLDER INPUT
IS HOW HOW LONG DO YOU THINK IT
WOULD TAKE TO GET INPUT AND
AGAINST TO HAVE FUNDS GO OUT.
WOULD IT BE REASONABLE TO EXPECT
BY MAY REVISION TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR BOTH.
THE COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS AS WELL AS THE.
CHILDREN'S CRISIS SERVICES
GRANTS IS THAT A REASONABLE TIME
FRAME FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT TO
WORK ON A TIMELINE SO THAT WE
MAY HAVE.
INPUT AND.
THAT OVERSIGHT.
SO FOR THE CHILDREN AND YOU BY I
THINK WE WOULD CERTAINLY NITA.
.
WRAP IT UP THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND.
THAT WEEK.
COLLABORATE WITH THEM CONTINUE
TO GET AN AGREEMENT AS TO HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOCATE THE
UNDS.
SO.
IF I CAN HAVE TIME TO.
MAYBE HAVE ARE A CONVERSATION
WITH THEM OFFLINE WE CAN COME UP
WITH THAT DATE SPECIFIC THAT WE
THINK WE CAN GET THAT PIECE
WRAPPED UP. WELL I HOPE BY.
MAY REVISION YOU GUYS CAN COME
BACK TO ME WITH A CONCRETE PLAN
FOR. US ON MAKING SURE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE. BEING SPENT
APPROPRIATELY. WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NINE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
MY NAME IS NORMA PAID NINE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. AND
AS TOBY I'M DOCTOR UNIONS
MENTIONED EARLIER IF WE RECEIVE
A THIRTY TWO MILLION ON GOING ON
THE WHOLE SERVICES ACT FUNDS FOR
AT THE TIME TRIAGE PROGRAMS. AND
WE ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS.
ON WERE ASKING TODAY FOR I.
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE UNSPENT
FUNDS FROM THOSE PROGRAMS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THE
AND COMMISSION ON ALLOCATED.
ATTORNEY SHE ADDED I'M SORRY
THE FIRST ROUND OF TRASH
GRANDSON ALLOCATED APPROXIMATELY
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION.
ACROSS A FOUR YEAR GRANT CYCLE
TO SUPPORT NEW AND EXPANDED
CRISIS ORIENTED PROGRAMS. IN
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES.
THE COMMISSION RECEIVED A TRIAGE
APPLICATIONS FROM APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY COUNTIES AND SETTING THE
CITY MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
AND AWARDED ARRANGING A GRANTS
TO COUNTIES FOR A RANGE OF
PROGRAMS.
SOME OF THE COUNTIES IN THE SIZE
PROGRAMS THAT PLACE PEER
NAVIGATORS IN JAIL OR EMERGENCY
ROOM SETTINGS TO ASSIST OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH CONSUMERS AND
CRISIS TO AVOID HOSPITALIZATION.
OR JAIL INVOLVEMENT BY DIVERTING
THEM INTO COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES.
OTHER COUNTIES DEPLOYED TRASH
FUNDS TO SUPPORT COLLABORATIONS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH OUTREACH
WORKERS TO DELIVER MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS SERVICES.
IN THE FIELD AND TO FACILITATE
AND SUPPORT ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS.
SEVERAL AND COUNTIES EXPERIENCE
DELAYS IN ESTABLISHING
OPERATIONAL AGREEMENTS NECESSARY
FOR THE TRASH PROGRAMS TO
SUCCEED.
COUNTIES REPORT CAN REPORTS THAT
OUR PROVIDED TO THE COMMISSION
INDICATED THAT TRASH FUNDS ALLOW
THE COUNTIES TO HIRE FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TRIAGE
WORKERS. INITIAL GOAL OF THE ACT
WAS TO HIRE AT LEAST SIX
HUNDRED.
MANY COUNTIES PROPOSED TO USE
TRASH FUNDS TO HIRE MENTAL
HEALTH PEERS AS NAVIGATORS
OUTREACH WORKERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
SOME THIRTY PERCENT OF TRASH
PERSONNEL ARE PEER EMPLOYEES.
AND HOWEVER.
COUNTIES EXPERIENCED.
.
DELAYS AND SOME OF THEIR HIRING
OF THE ON STAFF FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND ALSO IT WAS
CHALLENGED TO. COORDINATE WITH
THE COMMUNITY AYE. IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOSPITALS. AND I'M
WITH THE SCHOOLS.
AND IT'S AVERAGE TIME BETWEEN
GRANT AUTHORIZATION AND PROGRAMS
START DATES RANGE FROM ONE WEEK
TO EIGHTY EIGHT WEEKS WITH HALF
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES TAKING
MORE THAN THIRTY WEEKS TO SERVE
THEIR FIRST CLIENT IN CRISIS.
THESE DELAYED THE IMPACT OF THE
ABILITY OF COUNTIES TO UTILIZE
THEIR AUTHORIZED TRIAGE FUNDS.
TO ASSIST COUNTIES THE
COMMISSION EXTENDED THE GRANT
TIME FRAME FROM FOUR YEARS TO
FIVE YEARS. BUT IT'S STILL
ANTICIPATED THAT WALL HIGH OF
THIRTY POINT FOUR MILLION
RETURNED IN UNSPENT FUNDS FROM
THE GRANTS.
WE LIKE TO USE THOSE FUNDS CHIU
I'M IN THE NEXT GRANT CYCLE. IN
THESE WOULD BE NEW GRANTS WITH
NEW COUNTIES AND THE AS TOBY
MENTIONS THE COMMISSION
AUTHORIZED US TO. USE A PORTION
THOSE FUNDS FOR CHILDREN CRISIS
SERVICES AND ALSO SCHOOL THE
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS.
THE THREE MILLION THAT WAS
ALLOCATED FOR OUR CHILDREN'S
PROGRAMS AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
WOULD BE USED AND THOSE GRANTS
FOR THE CHILDREN'S CRISIS
SERVICES AND WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW OF SCORING
THOSE GRANTS.
THE FIRST AND THAT THAT'S THE
THE THREE MILLION AS THE
COMMISSION'S VERSION OF THE S.
B. EIGHT THREE THREE FUND THAT
YOU HAD ASKED ABOUT EARLIER.
AND THE COMMISSION IS MOVING
AHEAD WITH A THE SCORING OF
THOSE PROGRAMS BUT WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF THESE FUNDS COULD BE RE
APPROPRIATED. OUR CONCERN IS
THAT NOT THAT WE WOULDN'T GET
THE FUNDING OUT BUT THE COUNTIES
WOULD HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING THE CONTRACTS SIGNED AND
BACK TO US AND EXECUTED. BEFORE
THE TURN JUNE THIRTIETH
DEADLINE.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ELIA.
CHRIS GOT DEPARTMENT FINANCED SO
AS THE COMMISSION NOTED THEY
RECEIVED THIRTY TWO MILLION FOR
THESE TRIAGE A PERSONAL GRANTS
ANNUALLY AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE. HAVE BEEN SOME
DIFFICULTIES IN THE PAST AND
GETTING THESE FINDINGS OUT AND.
THE FIRST YEAR ALTHOUGH ONCE
THEY'RE ENCUMBERED THEY'RE
AVAILABLE MUCH LONGER AND SO
BEGINNING IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THAT THE GOVERNMENT THE BUDGET.
NOW INCLUDES PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS TWO YOUR
AVAILABILITY AN EXPENDITURE OF
THESE FUNDS SO THE COMMISSION
HAS A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME TO
EXPAND THESE FUNDS.
AND THEN ALSO JUST WANNA.
.
NOTE THAT.
AS OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ADMIN CAP THAT DOESN'T
CONTEMPLATE ANY FURTHER RE
APPROPRIATIONS OF THESE FUNDS
AND THAT ANY.
CONSIDERATION FOR YOUR
PREPARATION WOULD HAVE AN EFFECT
ON THE AVAILABLE ADMIN CAP
DOLLARS MOVING FORWARD EXPLAIN
THAT PART IF YOU CAN. SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE ADMIN CAP.
AT AT THE TIME OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS
IDENTIFIED.
AN AVAILABLE BALANCE OF SIXTY
TWO POINT THREE MILLION. ANY
APPROPRIATIONS OR OTHER
APPROPRIATE ANY RE
APPROPRIATIONS ARE THE
APPROPRIATIONS BETTER INCLUDED.
WILL HAVE AN EFFECT ON THAT
BALANCE INCLUDING THE TRIAGE.
CORRECT.
SO HOW MUCH LESS WOULD BE WITHIN
THE STATE CAP.
IF THOSE TRIAGE FUNDS WERE.
APPROPRIATED.
THE AMOUNT THAT WAS VERY
APPROPRIATE.
MISTER CHAIR AND WERE NOT SURE
OF THAT AMOUNT BECAUSE THE THE
CONTEXT OF THE COUNTIES ARE
UNDER NOW ALLOW THEM EXPENDITURE
RATE. RIGHT HOW MUCH ANOTHER
ATTEMPT MANY CAN THEY SPEND
BEFORE THE CONTRACT AND WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WILL BE.
THERE THIRTY MILLION IS AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT WE EXPECT.
COUNTIES TO BE UNABLE TO SPEND
BECAUSE THAT WE KNOW THEY CAN'T
SPEND FASTER THAN THE RATE
ALLOWED IN THEIR CONTRACT THE
QUESTION IS HOW MUCH SLOWER.
THAN THAT RATE AND SO IT REALLY
IS AN ESTIMATE.
HELLO ANY COMMENTS.
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE NOT.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK UP
TO THE DYESS.
.
I'M GOING TO USE SOME CHAIR
PROVOCATIVE HERE BEING AND HE
OUR DOCTOR I KNOW A THING OR TWO
ABOUT TRIAGE.
AND.
.
REALLY WOULD LIKE US TO.
EVALUATE A PROGRAM THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
PILOTING AT UC DAVIS.
WHERE THEY'VE PLACED A PAIR
PROVIDER INTO THEIR EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP WITH TRIAGE?
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE EARLY
EVIDENCE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
SHOWING HAS BEEN GOOD AND.
ENCOURAGING.
AND WILL WANT TO WORK WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO WORK ON SOME
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO SEE IF
A PORTION OF THESE TRIAGE FUNDS
CAN BE SPENT TOWARDS PLACING A
PURE PROVIDER IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS.
WHICH SEEMS LIKE THE GOAL THAT
WE'VE WORKED ON. NOW THAT WON'T
CHANGE THE LONG TERM ONGOING
FUNDING THAT. COUNTIES HAVE
CURRENTLY.
THIS ONE TIME FUNDING I'D LIKE
TO HAVE US CONSIDER.
IF A PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS CAN
BE SPENT ON THIS WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE NINE OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO.
A COMMITTEE CHAIR
WHEN YOU READ.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M STACY WALKER
WITH THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
PROVIDED FUNDING OVER TEN YEARS
TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS. TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION.
WENT DIRECTLY TO THE COUNTIES TO
SUPPORT COUNTY WET PROGRAMS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
TWO AND THIRTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION.
WAS ADAM ALLOCATED TO THE STATE
FOR A MINISTRY IN STATE WEB
PROGRAMS.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
COMMISSION.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE OVERSIGHT AT THE COUNTY WET
PROGRAMS OFSHE PET HAS NO
AUTHORITY. OVER THOSE PROGRAMS.
THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION OF STATE
ADMINISTERED WHAT PROGRAM
SUPPORTED TWO FIVE YEAR PLANS.
THE FIRST FIVE YEAR PLAN SPANNED
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN.
IT WAS DEVELOPED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
AND THERE WERE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAMS IN THAT PLAN.
WHEN THE.
APARTMENT MENTAL HEALTH
DISSOLVED OFF BUT BECAME
RESPONSIBLE FOR FINISHING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE FIRST FIVE
YEAR PLAN.
WE ALSO DEVELOPED THE SECOND
FIVE YEAR PLAN WHICH INCLUDED A
HUNDRED FOURTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
TO SUPPORT AND STATEWIDE
PROGRAMS
THE SECOND FIVE YEAR PLAN WAS
DEVELOPED WITH COMPREHENSIVE
INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS.
CANDACE BASED ON A PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT.
EXCUSE ME.
THE PLAN INCLUDES PROGRAMS THAT
INCENTIVIZE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION. OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE
WORKERS INTO THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
IT ALSO INCLUDES PROGRAMS THAT
EXPAND THE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION CAPACITY WITHIN THE
PUBLIC MENTALHEALTH SYSTEM. AND
FINALLY WE HAVE A ONE QUIRK
GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT.
.
SUPPORTS COUNTIES THAT BAND
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
STRATEGIC REGIONAL ISSUES.
OUR CONTRACTS RUN THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THEREFORE WHILE OUR OUTCOMES
DATA ARE IMPRESSIVE THEY'RE NOT
COMPLETE.
AND THUS FAR OUR PROGRAMS HAVE
ENCOURAGED INDIVIDUALS TO PURSUE
CAREERS AS MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
EXPOSING MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CAREERS AND PROVIDING
NINETY STUDENTS WITH INTERNSHIPS
IN THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
WE SUPPORT OF MORE THAN EIGHTY
TWO HUNDRED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS OVER THE PAST NINE
YEARS. BY PROVIDING UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN LOAN
REPAYMENT IN EXCHANGE FOR
WORKING IN THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM FOR TWELVE MONTHS.
MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND OF THOSE
AWARDS WERE MADE JUST IN THE
PAST THREE YEARS.
PROVIDED MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY STIPENDS OF UP TO
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. IN
EXCHANGE FOR WORKING IN THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
TWELVE MONTHS.
AND WE'VE INCREASED THE NUMBER
OF RESIDENCY AND TRAINING SLOTS
PROVIDING PROTECTIONS IN THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
.
WE HAVE TRAINED AT LEAST AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE CLINICAL PSYCHIATRISTS.
AND A HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
PSYCHIATRIC NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
WE'VE ALSO SUPPORTED TRAINING
JOB PLACEMENT OF MORE THAN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH IN
THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
SO IN ADDITION TO ADMINISTERING
THE STATEWIDE WEB PROGRAMS
A STATUTE REQUIRES ARE SPREAD TO
DEVELOP A NEW WET PLAN FOR EVERY
FIVE YEARS.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF WORKING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP THE NEXT
WELL FIVE YEAR PLAN WHICH WILL
SPEND TWENTY TWENTY. TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND WE ANTICIPATE
BRINGING THE PLAN BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL. FOR APPROVAL
IN EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN
SO THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER THEM
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MISS PARLOR.
PERSON BOTH THE COUNTY BE EVER
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I
WAS ASKED TO DIS DESCRIBE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
IMPACTS THAT THE MIDDLE HOLE
SERVICES ACT. WORKFORCE IN
EDUCATION TRAINING INVESTMENTS
HAVE MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
BELIEVE.
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE VALUE
OF THOSE THINGS FROM THE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE. AND I WOULD NOTE
THAT JUST GENERALLY SPEAKING AS
WE QUERY AND THE REGIONS THAT
ARE DIRECTORS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY DO AND A RECURRING THEME IS
THAT REALLY WITHOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE THEY
PROBABLY WOULD NOT HAVE DONE AND
HAD RESOURCES TO ATTEND TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY THIS IS
A SOURCE OF FUNDING. UNLIKE ANY
OTHER THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THESE SORTS
OF INVESTMENTS AND SO CONTINUITY
OF THIS I'M IS VERY VALUABLE
GIVEN THE REALLY WORK FOR
SHORTAGE AND HEALTH CARE LET
ALONE IN MENTAL HEALTH CARE THAT
WE. IN CALIFORNIA FACE THAT THAT
IS REFLECTED NATIONWIDE. AND SO
A COUPLE JUST COMMENTS AND.
SO MANY OF THE COUNTIES HAVE
STATED THAT NOT ONLY IS IT
IMPORTANT FOR INCREASING THE
NUMBERS OF FOLKS WHO ARE IN
WORKING IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
FIELD IN THEIR COMMUNITY BUT
REALLY REFLECTING. AN ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO FINANCIALLY SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS AND HAVE A MORE
DIVERSE WORK FORCE WORKING IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
MOST COUNTIES AGAIN DON'T HAVE
RESOURCES OUT OF THE OUTSIDE OF
THIS TO DEVOTE TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
AND WHILE WE DO HAVE SOME IDEAS
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THE FUTURE OF
THESE INVESTMENTS AND.
IMPROVED AND WE DO PLAN TO
PARTICIPATE IN OFSHE PEDS.
NEXT FIVE YEAR PLANNING PROCESS
TO LOOK AT WHAT WE MIGHT DO IN
THE FUTURE.
AND SOME OF THE EXAMPLES I WOULD
SAY.
WORTH SHARING ONE IS JUST FROM
YOURDISTRICT.
CHAIR ARAMBULA.
FRESNO COUNTY HAS RECENTLY
PROVIDED TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
SCHOLARSHIPS TO SUPPORT FIFTEEN
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS ACTUALLY
TO ATTEND ONE YEAR FELLOWSHIPS
AND SO WE'RE BRINGING PRIMARY
CARE. INTO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
REALLY LOOKING IMMIGRATION AND
THAT'S SOMETHING COMING OUT OF
THE THE LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT APPROACH. IN THE
CENTRAL REGION.
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO USE UP FOR
JUST AN EXAMPLE A ROVING
SUPERVISOR PROGRAM WHERE WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE ENOUGH
CLINICIANS TO SUPERVISE THE
STAFF WHO WERE TRYING TO GET.
THEIR HOURS AND IN IN THAT
REGION WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE LICENSURE OF OVER
FIFTY PEOPLE JUST IN THE CENTRAL
REGION ALONE.
I AM IN THE SUPERIOR REGION AND
WE WERE ABLE TO SEE THAT.
REALLY AS A MAJOR INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF SOCIAL WORKERS WHO
ARE WORKING AND THE SUCH
SUPERIOR REGION NORTH IN OUR
STATE. AND AS A RESULT OF THE
PROGRAM OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS GRADUATED WITH THEIR
BSW OR MSW AND UPON GRADUATING
NINETY PERCENT HAVE ACTUALLY
REMAINED IN THE SUPERIOR REGION
WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THAT. GET YOUR EDUCATION
AND THEN GO TO A MORE DESIRABLE
COMMUNITY IS ALWAYS A CONCERN IN
ANY AYE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENT THAT WE MAKE.
I THINK AS YOU HAVE HEARD ME
SPEAK BECAUSE I EARLIER IN THE
AFTERNOON ABOUT THE LACK OF A
STATEWIDE STORY TO TELL.
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO AND DO
YOU PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL
DESCRIPTIONS AS WELL AS DATA ON
THEIR LOCAL WET OR WORKFORCE
EDUCATION TRAINING INITIATIVES
IN THEIR THREE YEAR PLANS WHICH
AGAIN ARE SHARED VERY PUBLICLY.
NOT ONLY ON THE INTERNET OF
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY BUT ALSO
THOSE. THOSE PLANS ARE PROVIDED
TO STATE AGENCIES THOSE PLANS
COULD BE USED AT ANY TIME TO BE
ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A STATEWIDE
SNAPSHOT. AND WE ARE AWARE ASH
BUT HAS RECENTLY CONTRACTED WITH
THE UCSF HEALTH FOR CENTER TO
CONDUCT AN EVALUATION BUT WILL
KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT LATER ON
THIS YEAR.
AND I GUESS I WOULD FINALIZED MY
STATEMENT BY SAYING THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE.
THESE INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN
VERY.
VALUABLE TO THE EXTENT THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FUNDS MIGHT BE AN ACCEPTABLE
METHOD FOR FUNDING SOME OF THESE
LOCAL INITIATIVES.
THAT'S AN OPTION THAT SOME
COUNTIES ARE LOOKING AT BUT MANY
COUNTIES ARE REALLY UNCERTAIN
THAT'S THE FUTURE OF BEING ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD. UP THE
NUMBERS AND DIVERSITY OF THE
WORK FORCE WE NEEDED MENTAL
HEALTH CARE THAT OUR STATE.
IF YOU THINK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA.
NO COMMENT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TEN.
KIMBERLY TEN.
I CAN REALLY CHAT WITH A
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC.
STEVEN IT'S.
SUPPORT OF STATEWIDE STRATEGY.
DIVERSIFYING THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE.
LIKE IT'S PAST WE.
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
OUTCOMES IN THIS.
ABILITY TO OF MAINTAIN THESE.
PROFESSIONS IN IN THE AREAS
PARTICULARLY FOR.
A MORE DIVERSIFIED WORKFORCE WE.
NOTE THAT THE.
AGENDA INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
THOSE QUESTIONS AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO TO
DELVE DEEPER INTO THEM AS THAT
REMAINS AND HAS BEEN A
CONSERVANCY AND FOR ON THE PAST.
THANK YOU.
WE UNDERFUNDED HEALTH ACCOUNTS
OF COMMUNITY PAPER HOPE AGENCIES
ALL BE SPEAKING OF A NEXT ON THE
AGENDA.
SO I'LL SAVE MY COMMENTS BUT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
EGGMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA AND MO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
FOR CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY AND THE GIST OF TIME
A TO SAY THAT WE WOULD HONOR
SUPPORT HER STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE SITE AND BEGIN. THE CAN.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE I'M
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROGRAM AND IT'S
CRITICAL IN. I'M STRIVING TO
RETAIN AND RECRUIT TRAINEES AND
STAFF SWEEPS SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE PROGRAM
THINKING OF.
I AM VIRGINIA RUN THAT ARE NONE
THIS AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIAL WORK EDUCATION PROGRAM.
IT'S KNOWN AS CATHOLIC
A CATHOLIC OPERATES THE
STATEWIDE IMAGE IT'S A STIPEND
PROGRAM FOR MEMBERS W. STUDENTS.
ARE WE OPERATE NINETEEN CAMPUSES
ACROSS THE. STATE.
I THINK ONE OF THE NOTABLE OF
GOALS THAT WE HAVE IS TO PROVIDE
STIPENDS AND RECRUIT.
AND TRAIN CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT STUDENTS
WITH PERSONAL EXPERIENCES OF
CONSUMERS ARE AS FAMILY MEMBERS.
OF CONSUMERS AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
BOB WE HAVE STAYED IN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE WHAT
RENEWAL OF THE WET FUNDING WE
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THAT. AND WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT IF WE
DO NOT RECRUIT A COHORT NEEDS
FOR CLINICAL SOCIAL WORK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR.
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD NOT BE GOOD
ALLAH AT OUR UNIVERSITY STAND
READY TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
I WANTED TO ON I WILL TRY TO BE
BRIEF SO WE CAN FINISH SOMETIME
TONIGHT BUT DID WANTS TO.
ASK ABOUT OUR.
PROGRESSIVELY DIVERSIFYING WORK
FORCE AND WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
TRACK.
AND FOLLOW ON THOSE CHANGES.
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF AS I'VE
HEARD IT DESCRIBED THE AGE
WAIVER SOBRE TSUNAMI THAT'S
COMING.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO HELP
ENSURE THAT WE ARE REPLACING OUR
WORK FORCE WITH ONE THAT LOOKS
MORE LIKE THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE?
THAT IS ONE OF THE GOALS ADAM
THAT'S INVENTED ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
AND I I DO HAVE SOME PRELIMINARY
DATA ITS SELF REPORTED DATA FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO
PARTICIPATE ARE PROGRAMS AND
IT'S ONLY. TO DATE.
.
BASED ON THAT INFORMATION OF
THOSE WHO REPORTED THE
INFORMATION.
SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT WERE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY GROUPS
AND FIFTY THREE PERCENT A SPEAK
A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH
SO.
OUR PROGRAMS ARE SUPPORTING
THOSE EFFORTS.
WITH THE.
.
I'M GOING TO HOLD ISSUE TEN OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWELVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
KANSEN CHU IS PRESENT.
WE WILL COME BACK AFTER.
PRESENTS.
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND TODAY I'M HERE TO.
REQUEST A TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME APPROPRIATION
FOR THE ONE YEAR EXTENSION.
ALL OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AFTER WORKFORCE AND EDUCATION
TRAINING PROGRAM.
THAT WAS
AS FOR WHETHER TO TO BE SHORT.
THE PROGRAM'S CURRENT FIVE YEAR
PLAN HAS ONLY BEEN BUDGET A FULL
FOUR YEARS
THROUGH THE END OF JUNE THE
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AND ONE EAR EXPANSION IS NEITHER
TO CONTINUE FUNDING CRITICAL
PROGRAMS.
ADDRESS IN OR EXISTING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE.
BUT THIS PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
pTHE PASSAGE OF THE A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE ACT.
TO ADDRESS JUST SHORTAGE
THROUGH EFFORTS IN RECRUITING
TRAINING.
RETAINING MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
FUNDING FOR THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM WAS ALLOCATED FOR TEN
YEARS STARTING TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT.
BEN EVERY FIVE YEARS TO
ADMINISTRATIVE DEPARTMENT IS
TASK.
WITH TO WORKING WITH TO
STAKEHOLDER TO DEVELOP A NEW
FIVE YEAR PLAN.
HOWEVER AFTER THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS DUE TO A TRANSITION OF
ADMINISTRATION AFTER DID
DISSOLUTION OF DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
THERE WAS A GAP HERE. IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN.
DOES AFTER WITH
EMPLEADO FIRST FIVE YEAR PLAN.
RESPONSIBILITY WAS SHIFTED TO
THE OFFICE OF STATE WHY HOUSE
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE SECOND FIVE YEAR PLAN
DID NOT BEGIN UNTIL TWENTY
FOURTEEN.
AND DISTRICT CRAFTS IS TO EXTEND
A STATEWIDE PROGRAM FOR ONE YEAR
THOSE A ONE TIME ASK.
TO COMPLETE THE SECOND FIVE YEAR
PLAN SO THEY COULD THEY BE ABLE
TO HOPEFULLY GET READY TO A
BEFORE THAT NAY ANOTHER FIVE
YEAR PLAN AFTERWARDS.
WET HOUSE RESULT IN VERY
SUCCESSFUL INITIATIVES
LIKE THE MENTAL HEALTH LOAN
ASSUMPTION PROGRAM.
WHICH ASSIST MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WITH LOAN
REPAYMENT IN EXCHANGE FOR TWELVE
MONTHS OFF SERVICES
INTO PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
AND UNTIL YOU THAT I HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY DEMAND.
FOR THIS BEHAVIORAL A A
HEALTHCARE WORKER. BREAK BABE
YOU. PRETTY MUCH DUE TO DATE
INCLUSION.
OF DE SERVICES AND AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
AND THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE
ALL.
THE MORE OR LESS MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE ASSESS ARE
ASSESSING DOES THE SERVICES.
DEBATE FOR THEIR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IS RETIRING
FASTER THAT WE CAN HIRE AND
TRAIN. THE TRAIN THEM.
AND THAT'S PRETTY MUCH OF A
REASON THAT I I'VE REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL OF THE WIND YEAR. GAP
FUNDING.
ED TO EXTEND TO LET LET THEM
FINISH THE FIVE YEAR PLAN WOULD
DAHLE A INTERRUPTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO.
FLOUNDER HARVEY.
AFTERNOON RUSH I THINK EVENING
HOME YEAH.
I'M WE UNDER CLICK HARVEY THAT
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEAVER HOPE AGENCIES AYE WE'RE
AN ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
OVER SEVENTY AD BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT. AND SOME OF
THESE AGENCIES I THINK STILL
HAVE REPRESENTATIVE AMOUNT WE
HAVE REPRESENTED ME AUDIENCE
TODAY. SO THANKS FOR HANGING IN
THERE WE'VE SUBMITTED A REQUEST
LETTER AND TO YOU WITH OVER
TWENTY ASSOCIATIONS LISTED IN
SUPPORT AND WE'RE REQUESTING
THAT YOU CONSIDER AS.
MISTER CHIU JUST SHARED OUR
FUNDING REQUEST TO EXTEND THE
WET PROGRAM.
THIS WAS INITIATED UNDER PROP
SIXTY THREE AND WERE ASKING FOR
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR WHILE OSP IT
CREATES A VERY IMPORTANT FIVE
YEAR PLAN FOR THIS PROGRAM.
JUST QUICKLY A STUDY DONE BY FOR
THAT BY THE HEALTH FOR SENATE
UCS AB ESTIMATE THAT BY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT FEWER
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
THAT WE NEED TO START
REPUTATIONS THIS INCLUDES
PSYCHIATRISTS PSYCHOLOGISTS
ELEMENT TEETH LPC FEES AND
HEALTH VFW BUT EVERYBODY THAT WE
HAVE ON HAND. WERE ALSO MONEY
THAT THEIR LINGERING DISPARITIES
AND BEHAVIOR HOPE SERVICE ACCESS
BASED ON GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION AGE
LANGUAGE AND RATES NOTHING
ETHNICITY.
SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE PUT THE
STOP GAP FUNDING IN PLACE TO
ENSURE LOAN FORGIVENESS AND
EDUCATIONAL STIPEND PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED.
CONTINUING FUNDING BALL OUR FOR
CUT TO CONFUSE ME CONTINUITY OF
CARE FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS WHO
ARE MEMBERS PROVIDE NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO.
AND I CAN PERSONALLY INTO A
TOUGH TO THE IMPACT OF THESE
PROGRAMS AS I WAS THE RECIPIENT
OF BOTH THE STIPEND AND LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS WITH I
COMPLETED MY DOCTORATE IN
PSYCHOLOGY.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS FUNDING REQUEST IS ONLY FOR
ONE YEAR.
AND DURING THIS YEAR WERE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OXFORD.
TO CREATE A LONG TERM.
IF WE DON'T HAVE TO KEEP
COMING BACK EVERY FIVE YEARS.
THE CONTINUING THIS PROGRAM AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU FOR CHAMPIONING THE
CAUSE AND HIS COLLEAGUES WHO
ALSO FIND THIS LETTER. THANK
YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THREE TWELVE
AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RENTAL HAGER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION SO MANY WONDERFUL
PROGRAMS THAT NEED TO CONTINUE.
PARTICULARLY THOSE HAVE TO DO
WITH LOAN FORGIVENESS FOR SKY
INTERESTS AND OF THE RESIDENCY.
PROGRAM THAT IS THAT FUNDED TO
THE IMAGE IT'S A WHAT PROGRAM
WERE VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE BUT
THAT'S MEASURE THANK YOU. SIR.
RICHARD VAN HORN PRESIDENT
EMERITUS MIDDLE AMERICA OF LOS
ANGELES.
ON MY AGENCY YOU PARTICIPATED IN
WHAT PROGRAMS THE ENTIRE NINE
YEAR SO FAR. AND AS IT HAS BEEN
A.
REAL BOON TO ENGAGING PEOPLE
WERE CONSUMERS WHO WANT TO COME
INTO THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE.
AND IT'S.
WE ARE MAGICALLY INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY THAT'S AVAILABLE.
HI I AM DOCTOR OLIVIA LOUDLY I'M
REPRESENTING THE M. F. T..
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY
EDUCATIONAL CONSUMER SHIA.
THAT'S IN NETWORK OF. NINETY TWO
PUBLIC PRIVATE NONPROFIT
GRADUATE SCHOOLS.
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND ARE STIPENDS PROVIDE.
.
INCENTIVES TO MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPY STUDENTS TO
CONSIDER A CAREER. IN PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTICE.
WE HAVE OF OF THE SCHOOLS HAVE
AWARDED.
STIPENDS AS OF TODAY TO SEVEN
HUNDRED NINETY SIX.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES IN
FORTY COUNTIES AND NAVY
EMPLOYEE.
THE STIPEND RECIPIENTS UPON
GRADUATING.
MOST GRADUATES ARE EMPLOYED IN
HARD TO HIRE RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY RESIDE.
AND IN FACT IN SEVENTY FOUR
PERCENT.
OF THE RECIPIENTS PROVIDE CARE
IN A SECOND LANGUAGE.
AND EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT REMAIN
IN PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE.
I WE ARE.
VERY STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THE
PROPOSITION MAKING.
GOOD EVENING DANIEL MAILLET
CALIFORNIA LAND TO CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES REPRESENTING A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NONPROFIT
CHILD WELFARE AND.
CHICKENS BUT ALL WRITERS.
IN SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL THE
STIPENDS IN THE LOAN ASSUMPTION
PROGRAM REALLY HELP I'M SOCIAL
WORK STUDENTS MANY SOCIAL WORK
STUDENTS. COME FROM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES AND THEY
GO INTO THE PROFESSION BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO GIVE BACK IN THIS
IS A VERY VALUABLE PROGRAM THANK
YOU THINK MATH.
GOOD EVENING IN SHELVE AKA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BOTH A BUDGET REQUEST
AND WE WOULD LIKE
STATEWIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MERIT
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING ABOUT THE PROCESS
WITH APPLICANT WE SERVICES WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
KIRSTEN BARLOW ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
ACUMEN.
GOOD EVENING MARIE COLLINS CASA
PACIFICA CENTERS FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN BOTH SANTA
BARBARA VENTURA COUNTIES AND WE
ARE INSTRUCTS APART THANK YOU
BECAME.
WENDY* WITH PATHWAY
SYCAMORES WERE ON BASED IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BALLOT AND WANTED TO NOTE
THAT OUR TWO GREATEST I'M.
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE
IS TOLD PSYCHIATRIST AND
CLINICIANS AND. OMAR PRESENCIA
WANTED. ME TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
BEFORE THE ACA OUR TURNOVER RATE
WAS SINGLE DIGITS BUT AFTER THE
ACA IT'S BEEN DOUBLE DIGITS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VIRGINIA RUN BETTER HERNANDEZ
FROM A CATHOLIC I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT ONE WE SUPPORT
THIS INTO TO DO BASS WOULD BE TO
DISRUPT THE PIPELINE. ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT PROTECT BY COMES TO A
GENERATING A CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE
WORKFORCE.
THEY COMMIT.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TWELVE OF BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS.
I WANTED TO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THIS IS BOTH TIMELY
AND APPROPRIATE.
IF I MAY ASK JUST ONE QUESTION
I AM I THINK ABOUT IT IN PRIVATE
AND SO NOW I'D LIKE TO FIGURE
OUT WHY. I'M IN A FIVE YEAR PLAN
WHY WE RAN OUT OF MONEY AFTER
FOUR YEARS.
CAN DO WE EXPLAIN THAT SO THAT
WE CAN HELP TO FILL THAT.
GOODBYE TO ALL OF PIC OF HER
SHAUNA THAT YOU PUBLIC CAN.
BECAUSE IT WAS.
BUT GOOD THE ORGANIZATION TO
ADMINISTRATIVE.
ENTITY DOT ORG LIGHT LEAKING
CHANGE ON TO AND TWENTY THE
CONSULTANT TOWARD WHAT WAS
THIRTEEN.
SO THE KNEW ORGANIZATION DIDN'T
OF AND PICK IT UP.
UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND SO DO SO DO WHEN HE PICKED
PICKED UP IN.
IT WAS ONLY FOR YOUR LEFT.
AND THAT THAT'S WATER WORSHIP
SHORT OF ONE YEARS OF THE
FUNDING TO COMPLETE.
BOTH SUPPOSED TO BE A FIVE YEAR
PLAN SO I THOUGHT YOU SAID THERE
WAS A GAP YEAR OVER THE METAL
AND SO IT'S THAT YEAR THAN THAT
WERE. SO PLEASE.
MAN.
SIPPING AT THANK YOU SOME MEMBER
FOR THE QUESTION I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CONFUSION AND NONE OF US
SITTING HERE WERE WERE THERE
WHEN IT HAPPENED BUT.
RUSTY FELIX FELIX OUR SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER HAS PROVIDED SOME
INSIGHT TO THAT AS WELL AS
OTHERS.
.
I THINK IT'S AN ISSUE OF THE.
PLANS NOT MATCHING UP WITH THE
ALLOCATION YEARS RATE SO AS YOU
HEARD THE FIRST FIVE YEARS ARE
FUNDED THEM THERE WAS A GAP YEAR
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT GAP
YEAR WASN'T FUNDED IT JUST MEANS
THAT THERE WAS NO PLAN IN PLACE.
TO THE NEXT FIVE YEAR PLANS
STARTED AFTER THAT WHICH WAS
OWNED AND THE ONLY A LOT OF FOR
FOUR YEARS BECAUSE THAT WAS
REMAINING TO THAT MAKE SENSE IT
DOES SO WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
THERE WAS A GAP YEAR AND FUNDING
BUT THERE IS A GAP BETWEEN THE
PLANTS. WHICH LEADS US TO A FIVE
YEAR PLAN THAT REALLY ONLY HAS
FOUR YEARS OF FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO IMPLEMENT SO JUST SO I'M
MAKING SURE OUR. WERE FUNDING.
THE
FIFTH YEAR OF A FIVE YEAR PLAN
OF A SECOND FIVE YEAR BECAUSE
WERE BACK FILLING. THE GAP YEAR
WHICH WAS FUNDED WITH THIS FIVE
YEAR PLAN IS THAT. IT WITH
FUNDED WITHOUT A PLAN IN PLACE
AT THE TIME DUE TO THE
TRANSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND.
GOOD HAPPENING MISTER CHAIR NO
JOHNSON OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE PLAN IS TIED TO A SPECIFIC
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FROM
PROPOSITIONS
THE THREE FUNDS.
THE FIVE YEAR PLAN WHICH RUNS
FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN SIMPLY PARALLELS THE
TIME THE OFFICE BUT TOOK ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE SECOND
PLAN.
OF THIS PLAN IS FULLY FUNDED IN
THE FOR YOUR ALLOCATION IS
MERELY ALIGNED WITH THE INITIAL
COMMITMENT TO FUND WHAT PROGRAMS
FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
ALL ALLOCATE WHAT FUNDS ARE
BUDGET BE EXPENDED OVER THIS
DETERMINE TENURE PERIOD.
AND THE FINAL TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
NINETEEN PERIOD HAS
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING AS WELL
SO.
SEC.
ALL IN THE BUDGET.
WITH THAT I.
WILL HOLD ISSUE TWELVE OPEN AND
MOVED BACK TO ISSUE ELEVEN AND
THANK YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLYMAN TO
FOR. PRESENTING PARA THINK ABOUT
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR. MY
NAME IS MORAL ASPECT I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION WITH AN ARCH PAD IN
HERE TO PRESENT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ONE ASSUMPTION PROGRAM
SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
MON AS YOU KNOW OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH ONE ASSUMPTION PROGRAM
ALSO KNOWN AS AND LAP.
ENCOURAGES MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS TO PRACTICE IN
UNDERSERVED LOCATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING.
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN LOAN
REPAYMENT IN EXCHANGE FOR A
TWELVE MONTH.
SERVICE OBLIGATION IN A
DESIGNATED HARD TO FILL OUR
HEARTS RETAIN POSITION IN THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND LAP HAS SUPPORTED MORE THAN
EIGHT THOUSAND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE GRANT FUNDING FOR AND
LAP ENDS ON JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT THE END OF
THIS FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. APPROXIMATELY AT
TWELVE HUNDRED AND LAP AWARDS
WILL BE ISSUED FOR A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND AND
LIMITED TERM FUNDING WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT TO TWO POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES TO CLOSE OUT AND LAP
AWARDS FOR FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS FUNDING
FOR TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY.
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES TO CLOSE OUT THE
PROGRAM INCLUDE MONITORING
PROGRAM COMPLIANCE AND
PROCESSING PAYMENTS UPON
RECIPIENTS COMPLETION OF THE
REQUIRED SERVICE OBLIGATION.
THE CURRENT WHAT BUDGET DOES NOT
REFLECT THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO CLOSE OUT AND LAP THIS
FUNDING IS REQUESTED FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND.
THE PERMANENT PLANTS HELLO.
ANY COMMENTS ON ISSUE ELEVEN.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE ELEVEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ELEVEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY DR.
IF I MIGHT MET LEAST
ADJOURNMENT.
I'M RENTAL HAGER'S YOU KNOW
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION I JUST ONE OF THE.
INTRODUCED THE THREE
INDIVIDUALS WHO BE HERE TODAY
TESTIFYING IN THIS MATTER. TO MY
IMMEDIATE RIGHT IS DOCTOR ROBERT
MCCARRON WHO IS THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR TRAINING NEW
TRAINERS.
PUBLIC NOW SORRY.
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS.
TO HIS RIGHT IS DOCTOR SHANNON
SUE  WHO HAS A PROJECT
DIRECTOR FOR THIS UC DAVIS
DOCTOR. MCCARRON OF COURSE FROM
UC IRVINE AND THEN WE HAVE.
DOCTOR MICHELLE BURKE PARISHES
THE DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH FOR
THAT COMBINED PROGRAMS.
YEAH I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
LISTENING TO US.
IT UNITS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE AGAIN MY NAME IS ROBERT
MCCARRON.
VICE CHAIR OF EDUCATION AGREED
CARE SKYTREE AT UC IRVINE LAST
FOURTEEN YEARS AT UC DAVIS HERE
LOCALLY THOSE KIND OF MY HOME
AWAY FROM HOME. ADEQUATE
DISCLOSURE EMMA CURRENT AND
CURRENT THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT ELECT.
AND ALSO AS RENTAL MENTION CO
DIRECTOR OF THIS PROGRAM ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THIS BECAUSE THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS I THINK
WE'VE HEARD THIS SEVERAL GOING
TO AN IN DEPTH WE NEED TO EXPAND
THE MEN HEALTH WORKFORCE.
WHEN YOU DO WE NEED TO DO IN A
WAY THAT'S GOING TO BE
SUSTAINABLE AND EFFECTIVE.
PARTICULARLY DAVIS IT'S EVOLVED
OUT OF IT
TOO
SO THE CALIFORNIA UC IRVINE.
EQUALLY OF THREE PROGRAMS ABOUT
TWO TWO PROGRAMS ARE THIRD
PROGRAM. IN THE BOTTOM LINE IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING THIS RIGHT IT'S
WORKING RIGHT SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
MAKING HEADWAY WE ARE EXPANDING
THE SECOND WORKFORCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BILLY
PROBLEM IS THE DEMAND IS HIGH
THE RESOURCES FOR THIS ARE LOW.
SO WE REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR
RESOURCES TO EXPAND WE'RE ABLE
TO DO. IT.
BEFORE I TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PROGRAM I JUST WANT A
MINUTE OR SO TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
LED US TO THIS WHY DID WE'D WANT
TO DO THIS AS A GROUP OF MAINLY
PHYSICIANS. WERE LARGELY DUALLY
BOARDED NEITHER FAMILY MEDICINE
OR INTRO MEDICINE AND
PSYCHIATRY.
NUMBER ONE DEPRESSION IS A
LEADING CAUSE OF DISABILITY IN
THE WORLD.
NUMBER TWO.
SUICIDE AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER
HUGE PROBLEM RIGHT BETWEEN AGES
TEN AND THIRTY FOUR TO SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH THIRTY
YEARS EARLIER RELATIVE
TO THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE SEVERE
MY ILLNESS LARGELY. GOOD
CARDIOVASCULAR INFECTION
DISEASES.
ONE OUT OF FIVE TWENTY TO SIX
SUFFER WITH MENTAL ILLNESSES WE
LEARNED EARLIER THEY ARE
CURRENTLY. NOT ENOUGH MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
PSYCHIATRISTS DO A FEW QUICK
STATISTICS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE.
PROJECTED SHORTAGES
PSYCHIATRISTS WILL BE OVER FORTY
PERCENT.
AS OF NOW FORTY FIVE PERCENT A
PSYCHIATRIST IN ABOUT FORTY
PERCENT OF PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE
OVER. THE AGE.
SIXTY.
AND POISED TO RETIRE WITHIN THE
NEXT DECADE OR SO
SERIOUS PROBLEMS LIKE TO TELL
YOU THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR THE ANSWER WILL NOT AND
CANNOT BE TO BUILD MORE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS FOR MARRIAGE
OF REASONS.
THE SOLUTION SO WHERE DO YOU
KNOW THAT PCP IS ARE THE FACT TO
MY HEALTH PROVIDERS UP TO SIXTY
PERCENT OF ALL MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN THIS COUNTRY IS.
IN THE PRIMARY CARE SETTING TO
GET NOT BY PSYCHIATRISTS NOT BY
PSYCHOLOGISTS M. F. T. SOCIAL
WORKERS.
ABOUT FORTY PERCENT OF PATIENT
SEEN IN THE PRIMARY CARE SETTING
ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
SIGNIFICANT PSYCHIATRIC ISSUES
EIGHTY PERCENT OF ANTI
DEPRESSANTS WRITTEN BY NON
PSYCHIATRISTS.
PC PIECE HAVE A VERY LIMITED
KNOWLEDGE AND TRAINING. IN THIS
FIELD OF PSYCHIATRY THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF
ALL THESE PATIENTS FOR EXAMPLE
INTERNAL MEDICINE RESIDENT SPEND
THREE YEARS.
THREE YEARS LEARNING INTRO
MEDICINE ADULT MEDICINE DURING
THAT TIME.
THERE THERE'S NO SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENT.
TRAINING IN THEIR OF SKYTREE.
KEY STUDENTS AND STATE
CALIFORNIA TWO WEEKS.
TWO WEEKS TRAINING.
AND YET THESE ARE THE FOLKS OUT
THERE DELIVERING THE CARE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT P. CP'S
COLLECTIVELY.
TAKE CARE PATIENTS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS.
BUT THEY AT LEAST TREATING
TRAINING TO DO SO.
SO WE WANTED TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HERE WE WANT TO DIVE
INTO THIS AND MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESS IT SQUARELY. THIS
TRAINING NEW TRAINERS PRIMARY
CARE PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP IS AN
INNOVATIVE TRULY THIS POINT ONE
OF A KIND.
SASS FULL MODEL DESIGNED TO
SQUARELY ADDRESSES PROBLEM THE
FELLOWSHIP IS A ONE YEAR
MENTORSHIP BASED EDUCATION
PROGRAM WHICH REALLY TEACHES.
MAINLY TWO THINGS ONE HOW TO
PREVENT.
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT
COMMENTS PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS
NUMBER TWO.
HOW TO TAKE THIS INFORMATION AND
DISSEMINATED TO COLLEAGUES?
RIGHT WE'RE TEACHING THEM HOW TO
DO THIS
PARTICULARLY IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS ARE FIRST CLASS AT THIRTY
FELONS.
OUR SECOND CLASS ABOUT FORTY TWO
CURRENTLY SIXTY FELLOWS WE WANT
TO SCALE LISTA THREE HUNDRED
YEAR.
WE ONE SKILL LISTA THREE HUNDRED
YEAR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE DEMAND IS HIGH.
FOR THIS THE RESOURCES ARE NOT
AT THIS TIME.
QUICK SUMMARY OF OUR OUTCOMES
FOR THIS FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'S PAST MEAN EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACH.
WE FOUND THAT OUR GRADUATES HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
OVERALL KNOWLEDGE IN SKYTREE.
INCREASED COMFORT IN TREATING
DEPRESSION ANXIETY SUBSTANCE
MISUSE
INCREASED JOB SATISFACTION WHICH
IS IMPORTANT IN THE PRIMARY CARE
SETTING INCREASED RECOGNITION
AND PREVENTION OF DEPRESSION.
DECREASED MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
STIGMA.
WHICH I THINK IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND THIS IS KIND OF
NEAT EARLY DATA EARLY INDICATION
SHOWS THAT WERE SEEN A DECREASE.
WRITE A PRESCRIPTION OPIOID
MEDICATIONS WE SPEND ABOUT
TWENTY PERCENT OF OUR TIME. DOT
TALK NOR FELLOWS ABOUT PAIN
MANAGEMENT AS RELATES TO MIDDLE
OF CONDITIONS.
SO IN SUMMARY.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIRST.
THE FIRST TO SHOW A PATHWAY TO
EXPANDING AND IMPROVING
PSYCHIATRIC CARE.
TICKLING AND UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THE DEMAND FOR THIS TRAINING
AMONG PCP IS VERY HIGH BUT
RESOURCES AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
ARE LOW WE NEED THE RESOURCES TO
DO THIS TO EXPAND WHAT WE'RE
DOING. IN THE TNC PCP FELLOWSHIP
IS AN EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THIS NEEDS I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN REALLY A VERY
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS
INITIATIVE.
IS I THINK IT'S GONNA
MEANINGFULLY
SPAN OPTIMIZER MEDICAL TRAINING
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU SIR.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
THIRTEEN.
THE AFTERNOON ADRIN SOLD SOME OF
THE STEINBERG INSTANCE WRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
WE KNOW GIVEN THE DATA THE
DOCTOR MCCARRON JUST PRESENTED
THAT WE CANNOT GROW OUR WAY OUT
OF THE PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN.
AND ALSO ON ANY GIVEN DAY IN
THIS COUNTRY FORTY PERCENT OF
THOSE PRESENTED IN A PRIMARY
CARE SETTING HAVE AN ACTOR
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITION. I'M SO WE
NEED TO BE DOING A MUCH BETTER
JOB TRAINING PRIMARY CARE FOR A
PROVIDERS ON EARLY SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OF RECOGNIZING MENTAL
ILLNESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
WE UNDERCURRENT THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. IN GAME.
MICHELLE BAKA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WITH A SMALL INVESTMENT FOR THE
STATE TO MAKE.
WITH THE BIG PAYOFF AND.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE SOFTENING
REQUEST CONSIDERED THINKING.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND ONE WHERE
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY AND THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF PHYSICIANS
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND THEY
WANTED TO ME TO INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
WITHOUT A BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS AND.
AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
PROPOSAL I AM PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN. HOW YOU ARE
HELPING THE UNDERSERVED AND?
?
I'M MORE RURAL AREAS AS WELL AS
REALLY FOCUSING ON PRIMARY CARE
AND EMERGENCY MEDICINE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THIRTEEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FORTH. THANK YOU
WITH.
WHEN YOU'RE READY GREAT. US SO
WELL ONCE AGAIN JENNIFER CAN'T
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
YOUR AGENDA DOES A NICE JOB OF
LAYING OUT THE.
RATED FUNDING THAT WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE COMMITTEE HEARINGS I DON'T
WANT TO BELABOR THAT TERMS OF
THE NUMEROUS FUNDING SOURCES
THAT. I'M COUNTIES ARE ABLE TO
USE TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
I WOULD KNOW THAT THEIR AGENDA
ALSO.
AND I FORGOT TO MENTION THIS
EARLIER BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT
DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN WHICH I'M
INDIVIDUALS CAN RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SO OBVIOUSLY AND
THE BOOK OF THE DISCUSSION TODAY
HAS BEEN AROUND THE COUNTIES AND
PROVIDING SPECIAL TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS. BUT ALSO
WITHIN MEDI CAL.
ARE MEANT MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
MILD TO MODERATE I'M SERVICES
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY I'M IF
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT ENROLLED IN
MANAGED CARE THEY'RE ABLE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES IN FEE FOR
SERVICE. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS.
THAT WE BOTH OVERSEE AND
ADMINISTER.
.
I THINK I ADDRESS THE QUESTION
AROUND THE CARVING OUT OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND HOW THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF THE
HISTORY AROUND THAT. I'M I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO KNOW.
AND.
QUESTION FOR.
.
AROUND THE OIG AUDIT THAT WAS I
RECENTLY RELEASED IN DRAFT FORM
TO US AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
KIND OF HIGHLIGHTS THE ANSWER
FOR NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS THERE
pON YOUR AGENDA SO ITS FOREIGN
FOR.
.
WHERE IT TALKS ABOUT YOU KNOW
HOW CAN WE SEE IF SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN MORE FLEXIBLE LESS
DEPENDENT ON DIAGNOSES? ON THE
AUDIT.
THAT WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
WORKING THROUGH WITH THE YG.
IT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE IN WHICH
BOTH THE COMPLEXITY OF THE CASES
THE DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED AND THE.
REALLY CLOSE.
OVERSIGHT THAT IS INVOLVING
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL OFFICIALS
WHEN IT COMES TO CLEANING THOSE
SERVICES IS PROBABLY GOING IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION IN TERMS
OF THEY ARE INCREASINGLY. MUCH
MORE INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE
THAT ON THE SERVICES MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA THAT THOSE.
CRITERIA CLEARLY DOCUMENTED AND
THE.
IN THE FILE AND THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S A RECORD.
SAID THE AUDIT.
WE'RE HOPING WILL.
.
YOU KNOW BE FINALIZED BY THE
FEDERAL AWAY G. WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND WORKING WITH THEM TO READ
THREE REVIEWS SEVERAL OF THE
DISPUTED CLAIMS WHICH WERE
OBVIOUSLY LOOK I'M LESSEN THE
AMOUNT THAN THE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT IS AT THIS TIME THEY
WERE GOING TO BE TAKING IT
UNDER.
SUBMISSION AND AND ISSUING A
FINAL REPORT BUT I THINK YOU
KNOW WE WOULD ALL AND STIPULATE
THAT WE WISH THINGS WERE A LOT
MORE.
EASY AND FLEXIBLE BUT YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE PUBLIC
FUNDS IN THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
PUBLIC FUNDS THAT'S PROBABLY
NOT.
THE MOST
I REALISTIC AND HOPE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AND THEN I WILL
I'M DEFERRED TO MS GRAY LISTS ON
TO SPEAK MOST SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
CANS BUT I WANTED TO OPEN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE.
CANS DISCUSSION WITH.
YOUR COMMENTS EARLIER AROUND
METRICS.
AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US
AS A STATE TO HAVE METRICS THIS
HAS BEEN A VERY LONG PROCESS FOR
WHICH.
BRENDA HAS BEEN INVOLVED FOR
MANY MANY YEARS I'M WE FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT.
THE NEED TO HAVE A STANDARDIZED
TOOL ACROSS THE STATE WE ALSO
FELT.
STRONGLY THAT THERE NEEDED TO
BE.
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES THAT
WERE CAPTURED IN THE DATA SO WE
CHOSE TO TOOLS.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE INTEREST
OF HAVING PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS.
PROVIDING DATA ON THEIR
PERSPECTIVE OF HOW OUTCOMES WERE
BEING.
.
OVERSEEN AND THEIR PERSPECTIVE
OF HOW SERVICES WERE BEING
DELIVERED AND IF THEY THOUGHT
THEY WERE EFFECTIVE AS WELL AS
HAVING A DIFFERENT. DATA ELEMENT
THAT CAPTURED ON PROVIDER
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES AND SO
THOSE ARE THE TWO THAT WE CHOSE
AND THERE'S A LOT OF.
WORK THAT WENT INTO WHY WE
CHOSE THOSE BUT I JUST WANTED TO
YOU KNOW AND.
YOU KNOW STRESSTHE FACT THAT WE
FELT THE NEED TO HAVE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES THAT WE
CAPTURE DATA ON AND WE ALSO FEEL
REALLY STRONGLY THAT.
.
YOU AND OTHERS.
CONTINUE TO ASK WHAT HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS WORKING AND SO
WE NEED TO KIND OF CAPTURE DATA
IN A WAY THAT WE CAN. AND DO OUR
BEST AND I THINK THAT WE WOULD
NEVER STIPULATE THAT THERE'S A
PERFECT.
DATA MEASUREMENT TOOL THAT WE
THINK THAT THE PROCESS THAT WE
WENT THROUGH ITS I'M BOTH VERY
AND.
THOUGHTFUL IT WAS DRAWN OUT AND
IT INVOLVES A LOT OF DIFFERENT
EXPERTS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THEN.
FINALLY JUST TO KIND OF GET
THROUGH US SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAD ASSN THE AGENDA.
AS YOU KNOW I'M YOUR BILL AB
THREE FORTY AROUND.
TRAUMA SCREENING WE ARE
PREPARING TO KICK OFF ON THE
WORK GROUP AND PURSUANT TO THE
LEGISLATION.
AND NOT GROUP HAS BEEN COMPOSED
OF NOT ONLY.
.
CLINICIANS FOR WHICH I.
WAS VERY SPECIFIC IN WORKING
WITH OUTSIDE STAKEHOLDERS WHICH
IS I WANT TO HAVE.
CLINICIANS WHO ARE WORKING WITH
AFFECTED POPULATIONS BE ON THIS
WORK GROUP ON THERE'S A
COMPOSITION OF ADVOCATES COUNTY
WELFARE.
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
REPRESENTATION.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S GOING TO
KICK OFF AND I THINK THE GOAL OF
THAT IS TO LOOK AT THE TOOLS
THAT WE CURRENTLY USE AND TO
SAY.
ARE THESE THE RIGHT.
ASSESSMENT TOOLS DO THEY
CAPTURE THE INFORMATION IN A WAY
THAT IS HELPFUL ON IF THERE ARE
DIFFERENT ASSESSMENTS THAT CAN
OR SHOULD BE DONE WHAT WOULD BE
THE PROCESS BY US.
CHOOSING THOSE I'M AS THIS
DEPARTMENT WHAT WITH THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS BE OBVIOUSLY FOR
CHANGING SOME OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS AND SO I WE WERE
WILL BE HAPPY TO KIND OF COME
BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE AND LET
YOU KNOW BUT. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE A BOTH STAFF AND OTHERS
THAT ARE ON THAT WORK GROUP AS
WELL NOT BE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
SO. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DEFER TO.
BRENDA ON THE CANS IF THAT'S
OKAY BEFORE WE GET THERE.
DURING OUR ACES HEARING LAST
WEEK I ASKED A CLINICIAN WHO'S
ON THE FRONT LINES WHO WROTE THE
BOOK.
THE DEEPEST WHILE THAT HELPED
BRING ME TO A SAYS IF SHE WOULD
BE A PART OF THE WORK GROUP AND
SHE SHOWED A WILLINGNESS.
I WAS HOPING THAT I COULD WORK
WITH YOU ON THE DEPARTMENT TO
SEE IF WE COULD MAKE AN
INVITATION TO HER RUSSIA ABSENCE
I THINK SHE BRINGS QUITE A BIT
OF EXPERTISE ABSOLUTELY YES
THANK YOU.
SOMETHING.
DIRECTOR CAN THAT'S A PRETTY
GREAT ALICIA I'M A LOT OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
STEVE'S YES I THINK YOU DID A
GREAT JOB ON HOW LAYING OUT.
.
TURN WITH THE PERFORMANCE ARE
CONSISTENT LEGISLATION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE STARTED OF
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDER GROUP.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE HAD I A GROUP OF
FOLKS WHO WERE REALLY DEDICATED
TO TRYING TO FIND THE RIGHT TOOL
FOLKS CAME WITH THEIR DIFFERENT
TOOLS THAT THEY WERE INTERESTED
IN AND THAT THEY WERE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT. AND.
AND SO THAT THERE WAS A VARIETY
OF TOOLS AND.
THERE WAS A A DISCUSSION OR A
SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH TOOL OR COULD
WE COULD WE ALLOW FOR ALL TOOLS.
ANYTHING VERY QUICKLY THAT
THEIR GROUP JUST LEARNED THAT
THAT THAT WASN'T POSSIBLE SECOND
GETS TO DIRECTOR KANSEN YOUR
POINT ABOUT STANDARDIZATION.
AND THE GROUP RECOMMENDED THAT
WE.
DO STUDIES TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S THE BEST TOOL TO MEASURE
I'M CHILDREN YOU FUNCTIONAL
OUTCOMES AND SO I WE
COMMISSIONED A STUDY.
WITH THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
LOS ANGELES AND I AND.
WITH FUNDING FROM THEIR
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
EMBARKED ON A PRETTY RIGOROUS
PROCESS OMINOUS SIGNAL TO A FEW
STUDIES SO.
THE INITIAL PART HAD TO DO WITH.
I'M DOING A LITERATURE
ENVIRONMENTAL SCAN ON TRY TO GET
AS MUCH INFORMATION ON CHINA
WHAT'S THE STATE TO STAY IN THE
TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
AND THEN WE ALSO SURVEYED
COUNTIES TO FIND OUT WHAT
COUNTIES WERE DOING AND WHAT
THEY WERE USING. AND.
USING THAT INFORMATION.
UCLA HAD DEVELOPED PUBLIC ARE A
COMPILATION OF TOOLS THAT WOULD
MOVE TO A NEXT LEVEL WHICH IS A
MODIFY DEL FI PANEL WHICH SHOWS
A. GROUP OF DIFFERENT.
PERSPECTIVES AND EXPERTS SO I'M
IT HAD KIDS ARE CONSUMER FAMILY
MEMBERS POSE OUGHT WELLS
CLINICIANS AND ADMINISTRATORS SO
FRIDAY OF OF PERSPECTIVES.
AMENDMENT DID THE MODIFIED
DELPHI PANEL REVIEWED THE TOOLS.
.
ON THAT ARE.
THEY ON CERTAIN LIKE ELEVEN
CRITERIA SEVERAL CRITERIA.
INCLUDING PSYCHOMETRICS ON A
PERSONAL.
BUT THE PERSPECTIVES BEING
BEING.
.
CAPTURED.
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TOOK TO
ADMINISTER THE TOOL.
LANGUAGES THAT IT WAS TO
DEVELOP DAM UNAVAILABLE AND.
SO THROUGH THAT AND THROUGH
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS WHICH WAS
QUITE INVOLVED IN LENGTHY.
UCLA RECOMMENDED THAT PEDIATRIC
SYMPTOMS CHUCK WAS THIRTY FIVE.
SO I THINK THAT WAS A VERY
CLEAR RECOMMENDATION FROM THEM.
VERY CLEAR TOOL THAT MADE UP
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE TOP OF THEIR
CRITERIA WHEN THEY DID THE FINAL
RANKINGS.
AND THEN.
BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE A CLINICIAN
THOMAS LONG BEEN HAULED I'M NOT
EVEN IN OUR JOURNAL PERFORMANCE
OUTCOME SYSTEM WE'VE HAD
MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES ARE NOT
PERSON BUT SYSTEM RAN FROM
NINETY EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND TWO
I BELIEVE. WE DID MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES AT THAT TIME.
WE'VE ALSO CONTINUE TO USE
MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES THROUGH
OUR CONSUMER PERCEPTIONS SURVEYS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR. WELL
OVER TEN YEARS AND THEN.
.
AND THEN I ASKED. HIM.
I WAS SO SO WE CONTINUE THAT
VALUES TO HAVE MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVE SO WAS IT JUST
ABOUT.
MY APPEARING CARE GIVER
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO WITH THE
CLINICAL PART
THAT AS WELL.
AND WITHOUT UCLA YOU LOOKING UP
THAT MODIFIED DELPHI PANEL THAT
THE THE TOOL THEY RECOMMENDED
WAS ON CALL THAT A CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT FUNCTIONAL ASSESSMENT
SCALE. AND THE CALF IS.
.
WAS ACTUALLY THE ORIGINAL TO ALL
THAT WE HAD USED IN THE
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES SYSTEM IN
NINETY EIGHT TWO THOUSAND TWO
WHICH WAS KIND OF SURPRISING
THAT AFTER ALL THESE YEARS.
WE'RE KIND OF AT THAT SEEM TOOL
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE WERE.
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS WITH THOSE
THAT TORN OTHER TOOLS ON THAT
WERE OUT SELECTED AT THE TIME SO
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM WAS DISBANDED
ON IN TWO THOUSAND TWO.
SO THAT NOT BEING A REAL VIABLE
OPTION.
WE LOOKED ACROSS THE DATA THAT
UCLA HAD HAD CAPTURED AND LOOKED
AT THE SURVEY DATA ON THE
COUNTIES AND THIRTY THREE OF THE
COUNTIES HAD. BEEN USING THE
CANS IN DIFFERENT CAPACITIES AND
SO.
RATHER THAN STARTING SOMETHING
NEW WE CHOSE TO BUILD UPON WHAT
WE AT WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE WAS
ALREADY IN PLACE. SELECTED THE
CANS TO BE THAT PARENT
CAREGIVER.
ATTRACT THE THE CLINICIAN
PERSPECTIVE AND SO.
YOU KNOW WE WENT THROUGH THE
REGULAR BUDGET CYCLE AND SO ON
AND SOFORTH AND THEN.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE HAD SOME.
MOVEMENT FOR AS MANY FOLKS AS WE
HAVE HAD LIKE YOU GUYS ITS BOOKS
OF THEIR FAVORITE TOOLS ON AND
THEY REALLY FEEL VERY
PASSIONATELY ABOUT FIVE AND SO.
SO WE HAVE VERY STRONG
ADVOCATES FOR THE CANS AND WE
HAVE SOME THAT ARE ADVOCATES FOR
OTHER SCHOOLS ON THE MCAT.
THANK YOU MISS BARLOW WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF.
ISSUES CAPTURED IN THE SECTION
OF THE AGENDA SO I THOUGHT IT
WOULD ADDRESS THE TWO OR THREE
OF THOSE JUST REAL QUICKLY. AND
I WAS ASKED TO RESPOND TO OUR
VIEW ON THE QUALITY AND ACCESS
OF.
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AT PRESENT AND I THINK AS IS
WELL LAID OUT YOUR AGENDA YOU'VE
GOT A GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE
VARIETY OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
UNDER WAY OR SYSTEMS THAT
ALREADY EXIST. IN TERMS OF
ALLOWING PEOPLE.
INCLUDING YOURSELVES AS THIS
POLICYMAKERS TO UNDERSTAND THE
LEVEL OF ACCESS THAT PEOPLE
CURRENTLY HAVE SO THE
PERFORMANCE OUTCOME SYSTEMS AND
THE DASH BOARDS THAT ARE BEING
CREATED WILL ALLOW FOR STATEWIDE
STORY. AS WELL AS TO LOOK AT
EVERY INDIVIDUAL COUNTY ON A
VARIETY OF AREAS ONE OF WHICH IS
OUR SERVICES TIMELY PROVIDED NO
THAT THAT IS WHAT IS THAT ONE OF
THE COMMON I'M FRUSTRATIONS THAT
WE HEAR FROM. PROVIDERS AS WELL
AS ADVOCATES FOR CONSUMERS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT THEY'RE NOT
SATISFIED WITH HOW LONG IT MIGHT
TAKE TO ACCESS SERVICES AND SO
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENTS I AM.
EFFORTS TO ESTABLISH A STATE
WIDE SET OF STANDARDS AROUND HOW
LONG IT OUGHT TO TAKE AND TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS SERVICES
CURRENTLY COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ESTABLISH THEIR OWN
STANDARDS FOR WHAT'S TIMELY.
WILL BE MOVING TO A STATEWIDE
STANDARD.
ADDITIONALLY WILL BE ALSO
NEEDING TO FOLLOW
SO THOSE WILL BE REALLY GOOD
GUIDELINES AND WE'LL HAVE SOME
GOOD BASELINE MEASURES TO KNOW
HOW MUCH MORE WORK WERE LIKELY
THEY NEED TO DO YOU. I'M A
PARTICULAR AND COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE EVEN MORE IMPACTED BY
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES OR LACK OF
CBO PROVIDERS OR WHERE JUST THE
TERRAIN IS DIFFICULT TO TO
TRAVERSE FOR CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES TO GET TO CARE.
AND SO IN LIGHT OF THAT WE OFTEN
RELY ON THINGS LIKE JUST
PENETRATION RATE SO WE LOOK AT
THE CLAIMS.
CUMIN WHO GOT SERVED AND WHAT
DID THEY GET THAT'S NOT REALLY
TELLING US THE STORY QUITE YET
THOUGH.
POINT I WAS MAKING EARLIER
ABOUT THE MEDICAL SERVICES ACT
ARE PEOPLE GETTING HEALTHIER.
WHAT KINDS OF OUTCOMES ARE
REPRODUCING SO WE HAVE A LONG
WAYS TO GO IN THAT AREA?
I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE
RECOGNITION WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
WERE FACING A LOT OF CHALLENGES
AS IT RELATES TO QUALITY AND
ACCESS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES WHICH YOU JUST HURT
QUITE A BIT ABOUT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF FUNDING STREAMS THAT
THROUGH REALIGNMENT WERE ALL
MANAGING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
TRY TO MEET NEED. BUT THEY ARE
FAIRLY DISCONNECTED AS IT
RELATES TO THE RULES THE TARGET
POPULATIONS SO COUNTIES WHILE
THEY ARE MANAGING OF AN ARRAY OF
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH DEDICATED
FUNDING STREAMS THERE ARE.
SILOS IN WHICH THOSE THOSE
FUNDS COME WITH AND THAT IS THE
DIFFICULTY.
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT DESPITE
OUR BEST EFFORTS COUNTIES I'M
HERE THAT IT HARD IS HARD TO
NAVIGATE HOW TO GET HELP.
FROM A CONSUMER AND FAMILY
PERSPECTIVE KNOWING WHETHER
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO START WITH
THE DOCTOR A THERAPIST HAD EVEN
FIND ONE IF MEDI CAL IS YOUR
COVERAGE WHERE DO YOU BEGIN THAT
PROCESS WE RECOGNIZE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NEEDED AND HOW
HOW TO HELP PEOPLE NAVIGATE
CARE.
AND THEN ONE PHRASE THAT WE KNOW
WE'RE HEARING A LOT THAT'S NOT
WORKING WELL FOR OUR USERS OF
OUR SERVICES IS THE CONCEPT OF
YOU'VE SEEN ONE COUNTY YOU'VE
SEEN ONE COUNTY. AND WHILE ON
ONE HAND THAT'S A REAL ASSET
THAT WE HAVE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A
RESPONSIVENESS TO REFLECT.
THE LOCAL POPULATION AND YOUR
LOCAL PRIORITIES THAT THERE
OUGHT TO REALLY BE A STANDARD OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE THAT ANY
MEDI CAL AND ROLL YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO EXPECT TO GET. A
REGARDLESS OF ITEM WHICH COUNTY
THEY HAPPEN TO LIVE AND SO WE
KNOW WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO IN
THAT AREA. AND THEN I THINK WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE TO
ANSWER THE CALL TO EXPAND OUR
ACCESS TO SERVICES THAT WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH PUBLIC SAFETY
REALIGNMENT. ARE HOMELESSNESS
PROBLEM IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
THE NEED FOR BETTER CARE
ANYMORE.
QUICK CARE FOR CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM THAT THERE'S
AN ARRAY OF POPULATIONS THAT WE
KNOW WE'RE NOT SERVING TO THE
DEGREE WE OUGHT TO BE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR PENETRATION
RATES IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF
INTERESTING IF YOU LOOK BY
DIAGNOSIS WE SEEM TO BE DOING
BETTER IN THE AREAS OF
PSYCHOSIS.
AND AND BIPOLAR DISORDERS WHICH
YOU.
TEND TEND TO SEE BECAUSE OF THE
SYMPTOMS THAT COME WITH THAT
MORE SHIRLEY COMING INTO OUR
DOORS
AND I THINK.
ONE OF THE MYTHS IS THAT
DEPRESSION IS SOMETHING THAT
MOST PEOPLE CAN LIVE
SUCCESSFULLY WITH WHEN IN FACT I
THINK I'M.
INTERNATIONAL RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT DEPRESSION IS ONE OF THE
MOST DISABLING HEALTH CARE
CONDITIONS AMONG ALL HEALTH CARE
CONDITIONS AMONG THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE CHRONIC. AND CAN AFFECT
YOUR ABILITY TO WORK AND LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY SUCCESSFULLY. AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT YOU RAISED IN
YOUR AGENDA AROUND REEVALUATING
HOW WE DETERMINE WHO GETS IN THE
DOOR. OF THE COUNTY SYSTEM AND
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE MEDICAL
NECESSITY CRITERIA FOR SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH IS TWENTY YEARS
OLD AT THIS POINT. AND WE HAVE
ANY IDEA SAM WE HAVE NEW
THOUGHTS AND.
NEW VOICES IN OUR COMMUNITY
ABOUT WHO REALLY OUGHT TO BE
GETTING MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
AND HAVING IT BE BASED ON
DIAGNOSIS AND IMPAIRMENT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE THE BEST WAY FOR US
TO MOVE FORWARD. AND SEE BEACH
CA HAS DEVELOPED INTERNALLY SO
FAR.
SOMETHING WERE CALLING THE
TWENTY TWENTY INITIATIVE AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE FACT THAT
MANY OF OUR AGREEMENTS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT EXPIRE. I'M
IN A FEW YEARS FROM NOW AND
SEEING WHETHER THERE MIGHT BE
SOME REFORMS THAT WE COULD
PROPOSE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
TO RELOOK AT THE QUESTIONS OF
ARE WE SERVING THE RIGHT
POPULATION ARE WE OFFERING AND
THE RIGHT VALUE AND TO CONSUMERS
AND TO REALLY.
LOOK AT HOW WE TAKE OUR SYSTEM
WORD ASSOCIATION OF OVER NINETY
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH AND FOSTER CARE AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF WHAT
IS AT STAKE. THE WELL BEING OF
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS IN THE STATE.
AND THE NEED TO CORRECTLY
EVALUATE. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
BILLIONS OF STATE AND FEDERAL
DOLLARS SPENT ON THEM ANNUALLY.
THIS IS WHY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY TWELVE
SANCTION DH YES TO AN IN DEPTH
STUDY.
OF HOW BEST TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PST T.
FUNDED SERVICES AND
STATE.
AND WHAT A DEEP CS FIND AFTER
MORE THAN TWO YEARS OF ANALYSIS
BY ITS HIRED EXPERTS AT UCLA.
BUT THERE WAS ONLY ONE OUTCOME
TOOL AS THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THE PSE
THIRTY FIVE.
THAT MET ALL THE ESTABLISHED
CRITERIA FOR TOOL SELECTION
INCLUDING PROVEN RELIABILITY AND
VALIDITY.
IT DO YOU EACH YES WHEN I HAD
THE MANDATE NOT JUST THE PSE
THIRTY FIVE.
BUT A SECOND TOOL THE CANS
BUT YOU STILL A I BELIEVE AS IT
WAS IN THE CONSULTANTS ANALYSIS
SPECIFICALLY DETERMINED WAS
QUOTE.
NOT RECOMMENDED FOR OUT
COMMISSION.
WHAT ALL SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER?
AS TO THIS CRITICAL ISSUE BEFORE
YOU.
ONE.
THE EFFICIENCIES OF THE CANS AS
AN AGGREGATE OUTCOME MEASUREMENT
TOOL.
PARTICULARLY ADDED TO IT'S LACK
OF PROVEN VALIDITY FOR THIS
PURPOSE.
HAVE BEEN ACKNOWLEDGE NOT ONLY
BY UCLA IN ITS REPORT.
BUT ALSO BY EXPERTS IN THE HERO
HEALTH MEASUREMENT FEEL. WE HAVE
SPOKEN TO FROM UC DAVIS I
BELIEVE YOU HAD A LETTER FROM DR
NO NEED OF IT ALL MENTION IN A
MINUTE.
USC UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON
AS WELLS THE CALIFORNIA HAVE A
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
NUMBER TO HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT THE USE OF THE CANS
FOR OUTCOME MEASUREMENT.
DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE MUCH
BETTER SPENT ON DIRECT SERVICES
FOR CHILDREN WITH UNMET MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
THOSE ON THE CHART THAT YOU SAW
EARLIER TODAY.
TWENTY TO OF THE THIRTY THREE
COUNTIES THAT UCLA FOUND WERE
USING THE CANS.
WERE DETERMINED TO HAVE
EXPERIENCED A PROBLEM WITH THE
TOOL THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE
UCLA STUDY.
WITH OVER HALF OF THOSE COUNTIES
HAVING SPECIFIC PROBLEMS.
RELATED TO ITS ACCURACY OR THE
RELIABILITY OF ITS SCORES AND
RESULTS.
WE'VE SPOKEN TO AT LEAST EIGHT
OTHER COUNTIES AND THERE'S
OTHERS BESIDES LOS ANGELES WHO
EXPRESSED TO A SERIOUS
OBJECTIONS TO THE USE OF THE
CANS FOR OUTCOME MEASUREMENT.
INCLUDING FRESNO COUNTY.
ORANGE COUNTY CALAVERAS MONTEREY
NAPA SAN DIEGO SAN LUIS OBISPO
AND SANTA BARBARA.
BEFORE CLOSING I'D LIKE TO BREED
READ A BRIEF QUOTE FROM THE
LETTER THAT REFERRED TO EARLIER
THAT WAS SENT TO THIS COMMITTEE
BY DOCTOR CHAIR NEED THEM.
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AT UC DAVIS
WHO HAS WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
THE CANS.
QUOTE AS A RESEARCHER AND
PROGRAM DIRECTOR I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE CONSIDER THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT THIS DECISION WILL HAVE.
ON PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE
IN TERMS OF HOURS OF STAFF TIME
IN CANS DATA COLLECTION.
WHEN IT WILL SERVE NO PURPOSE
BEYOND INDIVIDUAL ASSESSMENT OF
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS.
IF PROGRAMS WISH TO USE THE CANS
FOR INDIVIDUAL ASSESSMENT.
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE THAT CHOICE.
DO NOT PRETEND THAT THE DATA
WILL BE USEFUL.
STATEWIDE EVALUATION NOW OUR IN
THE FUTURE
ONE OF REPEAT THAT DO NOT
PRETEND THAT THE DATA WILL BE
USEFUL FOR STATEWIDE EVALUATION
NOW OR IN THE FUTURE.
IN CLOSING WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS THE
FOLLOWING QUESTION.
WHEN WE MAKE WHEN IT MAKES A
FINAL DECISION ON THIS ISSUE.
CAN WE REALLY AFFORD TO THROW
ALL THESE PRECIOUS STATE
REVENUES INTO FUNDING EVALUATION
TOOL. THAT EXPERTS FROM A
VARIETY OF ACT ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS
SALES NOT BEEN PROVEN EFFECTIVE
FOR THIS PURPOSE.
WE SAY THE ANSWER IS CLEARLY NO
IT IS NOT TOO LATE TO STOP THIS
ILL CONCEIVED MOVED.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN WHAT IS AT
STAKE HERE AND IF I MAY AND I
HAVEN'T OTHER MINUTES IT TO TO
MENTION SOMETHING. VERY I'M
THERE WAS NO MENTION WHEN THE US
STATE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES MADE ITS PRESENTATION
ABOUTTHE REPORT. ABOUT THINGS
THAT WERE CITED BY THE INDIA
QUESTIONS THAT WERE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
HIGHER EXPERTS AT UCLA. FOUNDED
THE CANS MET ONLY FOUR OF THE
NINE MINIMUM CRITERIA FOR
SELECTION OF THE TOOL ACCORDING
TO THEM IN A FIGHT MODIFIED
DELPHI PANEL.
THE CANS RATE SEVENTH OF THE
ELEVEN TOOLS ON EFFECTIVENESS OF
CARE.
AND THIS IS DETERMINED TO BE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH IMPROVEMENT IN
THE OUTCOME AS ASSESSED BY THE
TOOL. IS AN INDICATOR OF
EFFECTIVE CARE.
MAYBE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT THING
YOU WANT TO KNOW. NINTH OF
ELEVENTH ON THE TOOLS ON
SCIENTIFIC ACCEPTABILITY. AND
NINTH OF THE ELEVEN TOOLS AND
FEASIBILITY.
ONE FINAL COMMENT IN THE LETTER
THAT WE GOT WERE COPIED ON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA VERA HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION THAT WAS
SENT.
THE SECRETARY DULY ON MARCH
SIXTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE
LETTER READS IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
POLICYMAKERS UNDERSTAND AND
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE LIMITATIONS OF
USING THE CANS TOOL FOR
EVALUATING THE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES OF SERVICES PROVIDED TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
AS A SCRIBE IN DETAIL IN THE
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH COALITION
LETTER TO YOU. THE LIMITATIONS
ABOUT WHICH CBO EACH DAY
SUBSTANTIALLY CONCURS INCLUDE
ONE INABILITY TO PROPERLY
REFLECT CHANGE AT AN AGGREGATE
PROGRAM LEVEL VERSUS AN
INDIVIDUAL CHILD LEVEL.
TWO CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
VARIABILITY OF THE CANS TOOL
PARTICULARLY IN RELATION TO
PROVING ITS RELIABILITY VALIDITY
AS AN OUTCOME MEASUREMENT TOOL.
AND THREE IMPACT OF EXCESSIVE
CLINICIAN BURTON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
SIR.
HI GOOD EVENING I'M DEBBIE IN
THIS GOMBERG IN THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND I'M HERE TODAY AS A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT ON
OUTCOMES.
OVER THE LAST TWELVE YEARS I'VE
LED A COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO
ANALYZE COLLECT AND REPORT ON
OUTCOMES IN THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
PARTICULARLY AROUND IMAGES SAY.
A I ALSO ON LED A COMPREHENSIVE
EFFORT WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. TO PRODUCE TO
COMPREHENSIVE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP OUTCOME REPORTS IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
OUTCOMES ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME BECAUSE THEY HOLD THEY HOLD
THE SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY
ALSO PROVIDE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND I'VE BEEN A PARTICIPANT ON
D. H. CS METRICS TASK FORCE THAT
WAS THAT WAS REFERENCED EARLIER.
AND WAS HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF OF.
THEY'RE CHOOSING UCLA TO DO THE
MODIFIED DELPHI IN THE IN THE
LITERATURE REVIEW. AND WE WERE
VERY HAPPY.
THAT THAT HAPPENED.
.
THE AND UNCERTAIN AS HIGHLIGHTED
IN YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF ANALYSIS
UCLA ULTIMATELY CONCLUDED THAT
THE CANCER IS NOT CONSIDERED TO
BE A GOOD CANDIDATE FOR
MEASURING OUTCOMES STATEWIDE.
A SIGNIFICANT ELEMENT IN THE
SUCCESS OF THE CANS AS AN
ASSESSMENT AND PLANNING TOOL
WHICH IS WHAT SOME OF THE
COUNTIES USE THAT FOR. AT THE
INDIVIDUAL CLIENT FAMILY LEVEL
IS ITS ABILITY TO ENGAGE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
IN THE COMMUNICATION PROCESS
WHICH TAKES THE UNIQUE NESS OF
FAMILIES INTO ACCOUNT. IN
DETERMINING HOW. UP IN
INDIVIDUAL CHILD HAS PROGRESSED
LET'S AT THE INDIVIDUAL CHILD
LEVEL.
THIS DOES NOT HOWEVER TRANSLATE.
TO AN APPROPRIATE MEASURE AT
THE AGGREGATE PROGRAM LEVEL
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF EVALUATING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF PROGRAMS
FOR THE P. STT POPULATION.
AND INSTEAD TOWARDS THAT END WE
NEED A MEANINGFUL STATISTIC
STATISTICAL METRIC THAT CAN BE
USED TO SUMMARIZE WHAT IS
HAPPENING. ON A BROAD POPULATION
LEVEL WHICH HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
BE BOTH EFFECTIVE RELIABLE AND
VALID FOR WHAT WE CALL SEX
PSYCHOMETRIC BELIEVE SOUND.
IN ADEQUATELY PEER REVIEWED.
OF THE PSE THIRTY FIVE FILLS
THAT BOTTOM STANDARD.
THE KANSAS NO ESTABLISH VALIDITY
BEYOND GUIDING CLINICAL CARE AND
TREATMENT PLANNING. AND BECAUSE
IT WAS NOT DESIGNED AS AN
OUTCOME MEASURE WAS DESIGNED AS
PROCESS MEASURE.
IN ADDITION THE COST OF THE CANS
WAS WAY ON UNDERESTIMATED BY DH
CS. IN LA ALONE.
A LAST FISCAL YEAR WE HAD EIGHTY
FOUR HUNDRED CLINICIANS SERVING
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND CLIENTS.
WE ESTIMATED THE CLINICIANS WILL
SPEND BETWEEN AN HOUR AND A HALF
TO SIX HOURS PER YEAR.
ADMINISTERING THE CANS FOR EACH
E. PST TO RECIPIENTS.
SYSTEM WIDE THIS CALCULUS IS TO.
CALCULATES TO A HIGH OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND HOURS ADMINISTERING THE
CANS.
AND THAT'S THAT'S TAKING AWAY
FROM CLINICAL CARE.
FROM THE ESTIMATED COST OF
ADMINISTERING THE KANSAS BETWEEN
FIFTEEN AND SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN LA COUNTY.
IF YOU ARE TRAINING COSTS THAT
COULD ADD AN ADDITIONAL THIRTEEN
MILLION TO THAT NIGHT DON'T GET
TO INTO THE WEEDS AROUND US BUT.
ON WHEN ALL IS SAID AND DONE
THIS COULD YIELD SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THE CANS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALONE.
TO CONCLUDE AS A SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT TO EVALUATE. ITEM TO
EVALUATION I URGE THAT THE STATE
NOT MANDATE THE USE OF THE CANS
TO MEASURE CHILDREN'S AKA
MEASURES.
BECAUSE BET THAT MONEY COULD
BETTER BE SPENT SERVING CHILDREN
AND DIRECT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KIMBERLY CHEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK US
EVEN LIKE TO THINK DOCTOR A BILL
FOR OFFERING.
AB FOR SEVENTY LAST YEAR WHICH
REQUIRE DEEP SIESTA ADD
DISPARITIES MEASUREMENTS OF THE
PERFORMANCE OUT CONSISTENT
SUPPORT AND DEVELOP STRATEGIES
FOR ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES. WE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH DH THE S. IMPLEMENT THE LAW
AND PROVIDE THE FIRST REPORT BY
THE END OF THE YEAR. TO THAT AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE MANAGED
CARE PLAN DID INTEGRATE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN DATA AND THE
PERFORMANCE OUTCOME SYSTEM TO
GIVE A BETTER PICTURE OF ACCESS
QUALITY AND OUTCOMES.
AND US SEPARATELY AND TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS ON THAT WERE SHARED
PREVIOUSLY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE DEPARTMENT WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEMS CAN
PROVIDE. MORE SERVICES WITHOUT
RELIANCE ON MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL
ILLNESS DIAGNOSIS.
THIS IS A PARTICULAR ISSUE FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ELLIE P.
AND IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WHO
MAY DESCRIBE THE SYMPTOMS WITH
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY MAY HAVE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND WHO MAY BE
IMPACTED WITH TRAUMA AND NOT BE
ABLE TO DESCRIBE THINGS IN A
PARTICULAR WAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS TERRY MANNERS AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO AT
HALFWAY SYCAMORES.
WE ARE A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WE ARE THE LARGEST.
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER FOR
CHILDREN AND LA COUNTY.
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING IN THE
FIELD AND LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS.
SO THE DECISION TO REQUIRE THE
SECONDARY TOOL WHICH WERE
DISCUSSING IS THE CANS IS HIGHLY
PROB PROBLEMATIC AS IT LACKS
SCIENTIFIC. PSYCHOMETRIC DATA TO
SUPPORT ITS VALIDITY THERE ARE
ALSO SERIOUS CONCERNS.
RELATED TO THE RIGOROUS TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS QUALITY CONTROL AND
VISIBILITY.
THE UCLA REPORT WHICH HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY.
REPORTS THE PANELISTS WHO HAD
EXPERIENCE WITH PRIOR MANDATES
OF CANS FELT THAT THE MANDATE
BECAUSE FEASIBILITY ISSUES. AND
THAT THE TOLL DID NOT LIVE UP TO
ITS POTENTIAL. IT ALSO QUESTIONS
THE TOOLS VALIDITY AS A MARKER
OF EFFECTIVENESS OF CARE.
THE CANS DOES NOT HAVE A GOOD
SENSITIVITY FOR.
RATING FOR THE USE OF AN
OUTCOME MEASURE THE TOOL TO BE
UTILIZED ACROSS A BROAD RANGE OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH VARYING
DEGREES OF FUNCTIONAL
IMPAIRMENTS.
MEANING KIDS EITHER ENTERING
INTO THE PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION IN OUR KIDS AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE AND
RESIDENTS TO CARE FOR EXAMPLE.
BUT THERE'S A SERIOUS INABILITY
OF APPROPRIATELY WITH TO REFLECT
THE CHANGE OUT AN AGGREGATE
PROGRAM LEVEL VERSES THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL TARA LEVEL.
SO IN OUR ORGANIZATION WE.
HAVE BEEN USING THE CANS IN THE
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS WHICH
REQUIRED IT. YEARS AGO IN THE
RESIDENTIALLY BASED SERVICES
PROGRAM AND WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
USING THE CAMPUS FOR ABOUT
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS.
SO WE'VE. UP PULLED A COHORT OF
DATA.
AND WE LOOKED AT A SUBSECTION OF
YOUTH THAT WERE IN THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF CARE. AND WE LOOK THE
SAME DATA FOR THE CANS.
CANCER DATA AND WILK THE SAME
DATA USING THE CALIPHATE'S
AND WHAT YOU COULD SEE IS THAT
THE CANS DATA ACTUALLY
COLLAPSED.
THE.
THE AGGREGATE MEASURES AND IT
SHOWED VERY LITTLE IMPROVEMENT.
WHEN YOU LOOKED AT THE CALPERS
DATA IT DID SHOW IMPROVEMENT A
IN THE YOUTH.
SO WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
IT'S AN INABILITY TO SHOW ANY
CHANGE AND HOW THESE YOUTH WERE
FUNCTIONING WHICH IS WHY WE
CONTINUE TO USE THE CAPS.
SO IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING OR
MEASURING CHANGE FOR THIS ENTIRE
STATE ADAM WITH A VERY
POPULATION.
WOULD BE SIMPLY UNUSABLE.
A THE JUST ANOTHER NOTE.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WAS LOOKED AT.
IN USING THE CANS WAS THAT
OTHER STATES HAVE USED THE CANS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND. OUR VICE
PRESIDENT OF RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION WAS OF FORMALLY A
PROFESSOR AT.
UNIVERSITY OF MONTANA DURING
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CANCER
THAT STATE. AND SHE IS RELATED
TO US THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
THAT MONTANA EXPERIENCE WITH ITS
ATTEMPTED USAGE FOR OUTCOME
MEASUREMENT. INCLUDING THE LABOR
INTENSIVE NATURE OF THE ONGOING
ASSESSOR TRAINING AND THE
INABILITY.
TO DEVELOP A PROPER SCORING
MECHANISM FOR CAPTURING AND
REPORTING BACK MEANINGFUL DATA
SO THE KANSAS NO LONGER BEING
USED UP IN MONTANA.
I JUST HAVE ONE OTHER COMMENT
ABOUT THE CAMPUS THAT WAS MADE
EARLIER. ON THE PROBLEM WITH THE
KAFIRS WAS NOT THE TOOL.
IT WAS THE COST IN IMPLEMENTING
THE TOOL AND THE WAY THAT THE
STATE OF WAS IMPLEMENTING IT AND
ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES. FROM
WHEN THE TOOL WAS ORIGINALLY
IMPLEMENTED WAS THAT THE.
DEVELOPER OF THE TOOL WAS
HIGHLY INVOLVED IN THE TOOL AND
SHE IS NO LONGER. INVOLVED WITH
THE TOOLS OF THE THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS ACTUALLY.
I CHANGED OVER TIME SO I JUST
WANT TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE. ON
CALIFORNIA NOT TO GO DOWN THE
SAME ROAD AS OF THE STATE OF
MONTANA THANK YOU THE HUMAN.
BY BILL CARTER.
.
MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTOR IN NAPA
COUNTY FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS
IN A LITTLE OVER THIRTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE IN THE CALIFORNIA.
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
TWENTY EIGHT CS CARD THE PROCESS
IMPLEMENTED OUTCOME SYSTEM.
THEY DID THINGS RIGHT THEY PUT
TOGETHER A PERCENT OF EXPERTS TO
LOOK AT THE FIELD BROADLY AND
THEY SELECTED THE TOOLTHAT HAVE
SCORED THE BEST AFTER THAT
REVIEW. THEN INEXPLICABLY THEY
CHOSE A SECOND TOOL THE CANS
WHICH US SCORED POORLY IN THAT
REVIEW AND IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE
AND COMPLEX.
TOOLKIT TO IMPLEMENT.
IN NAPA COUNTY THE KANSAS GONNA
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE NEGATIVE
IMPACT BOTH ON FUNDING AND
STAFFING I BELIEVE IT MAY TAKE A
FULL TIME.
EQUIVALENT POSITION TO MANAGE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CANS
OF MY LITTLE TEENY SYSTEM THAT
ONE POSITION THE BIG DEAL.
AND IT'S GONNA BE DIFFICULT TO
GET OUT OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO OKAY AND WHOSE.
POSITION AT THE TIME OUR
BUDGETS ARE CONTRACTING IN THE
GONNA BE LEERY OF PROMISES THAT
THE STATE'S GOING TO COVER THE
COSTS OF THIS.
IT'S ALSO A DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN ON CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
RIGHT NOW ACT A TOWN FAMILY
ENTERING OUR SYSTEM. HAS A TO
OUR INTAKE PROCESS AHEAD OF THEM
BEFORE THEY GET TO SERVICES
I CAN'T ADDS FORTY FIVE MINUTES
TO AN HOUR TO THAT. MUCH LONGER
THAN MANY OTHER ASSESSMENT TOOLS
SO WE.
HIM JUST INCREASE THE RISK THAT
WE'VE WHERE FAMILIES OUT BEFORE
THEY CAN THEY CAN GET TO
TREATMENT. AND SIMILARLY WE HAVE
SOME. CHILDREN IN SERVICES WHO.
ARE GONNA HIT THEY RECEIVE
MULTIPLE.
APPLICATIONS OF THE CANCER IN
THE YEAR GONNA SPEND MORE TIME
DOING THE CANS AND THEY DO AND
SERVICES THEMSELF.
AND LASTLY THIS APPEARS TO BE A
PROJECT THAT SET UP TO FAIL.
.
WHEREAS TRAINING FOR SOME TOOLS
CAN BE COMPLETED IN MINUTES THE
KANSAS HOURS.
WHEREAS APPLICATION OF OTHER
TOOLS WITH CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
CAN BE BRIEF THIS IS A VERY
EXTENSIVE PROCESS.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT.
WERE DOING PROPOSING TO DO THIS
AND MENTAL HEALTH CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES ALL IS ALSO DOING THE
CANS A CHILD WELFARE VERSION.
SO A FOSTER CHILD WHOSE
RECEIVING OUR CHILD AND
RECEIVING A WELFARE SERVICES.
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IS
GOING TO SIT THROUGH MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATIONS OF DIFFERENT
VERSIONS OF THE SAME TOOL. OUT
WHAT THE TIME OF WHAT THE KIND
THAT COULD BE SPENT IN
TREATMENT.
AND THEN LASTLY WHEN YOU CHOOSE
A TOOL THAT'S THIS COMPLICATED
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HOURS OF
TRAINING THE COMPLEXITY YOU AND
INVOLVED IN ASSURING PEOPLE ARE
DOING THIS WELL. THE AMOUNT OF
TIME IT TAKES TO GET THE DATA
THE FACT YOU'VE GOT TO ENTER THE
UC DATE THAT THAT REALLY WAS
NEVER DEVELOPED FOR AGGREGATE
OUTCOMES. AND YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THAT FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WHEN
YOU WORK TRYING TO COMEUP WITH
A STRONG STATEWIDE EVALUATION
YOU RUN A HIGH LIKELIHOOD OF
FAILING.
SO I WANT TO.
.
IT YOU IT POINT OUT THAT IN IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN NAPA.
ADOPTED THE CANS.
HOW WE FOUND IT TOO COMPLICATED
AND WE FOUND WE DIDN'T GET
INFORMATION OUT OF IT THAT?
I WAS VALUABLE TO US IT'S A
FINE TOOL FOR TREATMENT
PLANNING.
BUT IT'S NOT AN OUTCOME TOOL
AND IT WAS NOT A GOOD FIT FOR
NAPA COUNTY SO. I THINK THE
SELECTION OF THE PEDIATRIC
SYMPTOM CHECKLIST WAS A GOOD
MOVE ANCHORED YOU TO STICK WITH
THAT AND.
THAT WE MOVE AWAY FROM
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CANS
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIN CHILDREN
WITH STEINBERG INSTITUTE FIRST
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT. RIGHT UP OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE BEEN
RAISING.
ABOUT THE D. H. SALES DECISION
TO MANDATE THE CANS AS A AS A
TOOL TO MEASURE ON OUTCOMES OF
THE PS CITY FUNDED SERVICES.
I'M THE MANDATE CONTAINED IN THE
ENABLING LEGISLATION S. B. TEN
OR NINE WAS TO SPECIFICALLY
PRODUCE A STATEWIDE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES SYSTEM.
AND A STEINBERG STEINBERG
INSTITUTES CONCERNED THE REASON
THAT WE'RE SO INVOLVED IN THIS
POLICY DEBATE IS THE NEED TO
PRODUCE VALID OUTCOMES.
SO WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SELECTION OF THE PEDIATRIC
SYMPTOM CHECKLIST THIRTY FIVE AS
A SINGLE TOOL TO BE USED IN THIS
WAS IDENTIFIED BY THE UCLA
EXPERTS ARE AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. REPORT THE PS EITHER
IF I WAS THE ONLY TOOL TO MEET
ALL OF THE MINIMUM CRITERIA AS
DEVELOPED BY THE UCLA EXPERTS.
AND SO IT REALLY IS THE BEST
SUITED TOOL TO MONITOR THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
FOR THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE
SELECTING THE RIGHT MEASURE IS
CRITICAL THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
THE KANSAS AN EXCELLENT
ASSESSMENT TOOL. THAT IS USED BY
MANY COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS BUT
IT IS NOT AN OUTCOMES TOOL AND
HAS NOT BEEN VALIDATED AS SUCH.
EXAMINING REPORTING OUT COMES IS
A SIGNIFICANT AND ESSENTIAL
UNDERTAKING AND MUST BE DONE
RIGHT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
IMPLICATIONS FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE. AND FUNDING THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY EMPLOYMENT
CASE FUNDING IMPLEMENTATION OF
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW TO
DETERMINE OF PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING OR NOT SO WE STRONGLY
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO RETURN
RECONSIDER THIS DECISION AND TO
ONLY FOCUS ON THE PS THE THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU ACUMEN.
GOOD EVENING HOW I FEEL LIKE I
SHOULD BE SAYING GOOD MORNING
PRETTY DEFENDER WITHOUT AGAIN
I'M DOCTOR LENTIL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES I WAS ALSO A
MEMBER ON THE PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES SYSTEM WHERE THIS TOOL
WAS DEVELOPED. OR DID THIS
DECISION WAS MADE. I'M I COULD
RESPOND TO ALL THOSE COMMENTS
BECAUSE IT'S THEM. I HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT THEM BUT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY DONE THAT WITH
DOCUMENTATION MULTIPLE SOURCES
SO WE'LL MAKE SURE. THAT YOUR
OFFICE GETS THOSE IKE WANTED
TOUCH ON A COUPLE ITEMS.
AND THE CANS IT'S MORE THAN JUST
A PIECE OF PAPER THAT PEOPLE
FILL OUT.
IT IS AN ASSESSMENT AND
TREATMENT PLANNING TOOL DESIGNED
FOR A COLLABORATIVE
COMMUNICATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL PERSPECTIVES OF THE CHILD
ARE SEEN AT ONE TIME.
AND SO AS YOU KNOW FROM WORKING
WITH YOUR PATIENTS THERE'S
SOMETIMES THAT A PARENT MAY SEE
A CHILD IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT LIGHT AND THE CHILD
MAY ACT VERY DIFFERENT WITH
PARENTS AND THEY DO AND SAY. THE
SCHOOL SETTING
SO THE KANSAS DESIGNS TO HAVE
ALL THOSE PEOPLE TO COME
TOGETHER AND GIVE ACCURATE
RATINGS.
OF THE CHILD ON AN ITEM BY ITEM
BASIS.
AT THE OTHER UNIQUE FEATURE OF
THIS TOOL IS THAT ALSO INCLUDES
STRENGTHS
AND SO THERE AREN'T ANY
TRADITIONAL CLINICAL TOOLS THAT
LOOK AT THE STRENGTHS AND ITS.
FAIRLY EASY ASSN PSYCHOLOGIST I
KNOW IN A VERY CONTROLLED
SETTING TO DECREASE SYMPTOMS
IT'S NOT SO EASY TO IDENTIFY AND
BUILD UP THE STRENGTHS.
SO MUCH YOU BUILD UP THE
STRENGTH YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE A LASTING DIFFERENCE FOR
THAT CHILD WERE THAT FAMILY SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
HE REPORTS THAT OF THE MANY
MEMBERS IN FRONT OF ME OR
DISCUSSING IS NOT A PEER
REVIEWED REPORTS. AND THAT
SINGLE.
OPINION FROM A SINGLE PROFESSOR
UCD THAT'S NOT
A PEER REVIEWED OPINION THERE
ARE MULTIPLE CARE REVIEWED
REPORTS.
THAT ARE DONE NATIONALLY THE
MOST RECENT BY DUKE UNIVERSITY
THAT SAYS THE CANS IS HIGHLY
RATED. AS AN OUTCOME MEASURE.
AND AS FAR AS AGGREGATING UP A
MANY OF SPEAKERS THAT IT'S OKAY
TO IDENTIFY THE OUTCOMES FOR
INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN WELL IF YOU
CAN IDENTIFY. FUNCTIONAL
OUTCOMES IN IMPROVEMENTS FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL CHILD THAT
INFORMATION CAN BE AGGREGATED
UP.
TO GIVE YOU FUNCTIONAL OUTCOMES
ON A PROGRAM LEVEL IN A
STATEWIDE LEVEL SO IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE THAT SOME OF THE
FOLKS IN PREMIER SANG.
IT'S OKAY ON THE INDIVIDUAL
LETTERS LEVEL TO TELL YOU THAT
KIDS ARE GETTING BETTER BUT NOT
ON A GROUP LEVEL.
AND IT ALSO THAT THE MONEY THAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME EITHER THIS
IS A PUBLIC DOMAIN TOOL. SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS WITH IMPLEMENTATION
THAT THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT. IS
BECAUSE OF POOR IMPLEMENTATION
IMPORTER TRAINING NOT THE TOOL
ITSELF AND SO THAT'S THE REASON
D. H. YES IT'S TAKING A LOT OF
TIMEAND ATTENTION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CLINICIANS IN THE
COUNTIES AREREADY AND PROVIDED
WITH ADEQUATE TRAINING TO BE
ABLE TO USE THIS TOOL THE WAY IT
WAS DESIGNED.
AS FAR AS THE AMOUNT OF TIME.
ADD THIS TOOL IT'S NICE THAT IS
BOTH AN ASSESSMENT AND TREATMENT
PLANNING TOOL BECAUSE IT'S DONE
A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AND
MEETS ALL THE. MEDICAID
REQUIREMENTS
FOR.
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING HOW
WHICH REMOVING TO AND HOLLER
SYSTEMS OF CARE WHICH CAN BE
DONE ALL AT ONCE SO YOU'RE NOT
HAVING TO DO A SEPARATE PROCESS
IT IS THE PROCESS IT REPLACES
THAT PROCESS.
AND THEREFORE IT IS AN EP STT
REP REIMBURSABLE PROGRAMS ALL
THESE HOURS THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
CANDY FUNDED BY EPS DUTY EXCEPT
THE UP FRONT TRAINING.
AND.
IT IS USE STATEWIDE IN MORE
THAN.
FORTY STATE OF STATES I THINK AT
THIS POINT.
AND SO SOME OF THE STATE THAT
WERE REFERENCED WE'RE DONE YEARS
AND YEARS AGO WHEN THE. TOOL WAS
VERY NEW AND THEY HADN'T GONE
THROUGH THE TRIAL AND ERROR
PROCESS.
SO WE'D BE HAPPY TO MEET WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND TALKED TO YOU
MORE ABOUT THIS IN DETAIL.
I ONE LAST THING I DO WANNA SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT SAT
DIRECTOR CAN'T SAID AT THE VERY
BEGINNING. THAT.
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT MILD TO
MODERATE BENEFIT THAT IS TO IN
ADULTS BUT NOT IN THE CHILDREN
SYSTEM. THE CHILDREN'S ITEM
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH MEDICAL
NECESSITY CRITERIA IS MUCH
BROADER AND DEEPER AND SO IT'S
KIDS CAN HAVE A VERY VERY MILD
NEED. AND STILL MEET SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE CRICKETER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT BACK UP TO THE. YES
SIR DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
IF YOU'VE MADE A PUBLIC COMMENT.
ONCE ALL PROBABLY THAT THEY'RE
IF IT'S OKAY JUST BECAUSE WE'RE
APPROACHING SEVEN. I DON'T.
NORMALLY LIMIT.
.
IT'S. OBVIOUS THAT WE HAVE NOT.
APPARENTLY CAME TO A CONCLUSION.
DUE TO THE.
DIFFERENCES IN OPINION THAT WE
HEARD DURING PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WANTED TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AGAIN WHAT. OUR
THOUGHT PROCESS WAS.
BEHIND THE USE OF KANSAS AN
OUTCOME BASED. METRIC WHEN IT
APPEARS THAT.
THE.
ORGANIZATION THAT WE HIRED TO
HELP US HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
VALIDATE THE OUTCOMES.
BEFORE US.
I MEAN I'LL DO IT I'LL LET
BRENDA CHINA AS WELL AND BECAUSE
IT IS.
SEVEN AND WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
A PSYCHOMETRIC LEAVE VALID DATA
SHARING DISCUSSION.
PROBABLY AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
.
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS.
ASIDE FROM THE PSC YOU UCLA
LOOKED AT A VARIETY OF TOOLS AND
NONE OF THEM OBVIOUSLY STOOD
OUT.
IN AND THEY ALL HAD THEIR FLAWS
THEY ALL HAD THEIR BENEFITS.
AS BRENDA SAID.
WE HAD TRIED TO USE A DIFFERENT
TOOL YEARS AGO AND THAT KIND OF
STUFF COLLAPSED IN ITS OWN.
WAIT IN TERMS OF.
I THINK IT WAS EITHER DIFFICULT
OR TIMELY IT WAS OBVIOUSLY
EXPENSIVE. AND WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF FACTORS THAT WE NEED TO
CONSIDER WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS.
THE FACT THAT A LOT OF.
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY USING THIS
TOOL.
.
FOR INDIVIDUAL ASSESSMENTS ARE
INDIVIDUAL TREATMENT PLANTS WAS
CERTAINLY ONE.
THING FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT
COUNTIES WERE FAMILIAR WITH IT
WE ALSO HAVE A SISTER DEPARTMENT
THAT WAS NEEDING TO LOOK AT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A TOOL AS IT
PERTAINS TO.
THEIR CONTAINMENT CARE REFORM
AND THEIR CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS
I'M OBVIOUSLY IT DIDN'T MAKE A
WHOLE LOT OF SENSE AS TO
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT.
TOOLS.
I WOULD.
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT.
.
POINT OF PRIVILEGE AND SAY IT
IS.
CLEAR FROM BOTH DEPARTMENTS
WHEN WE HAVE ISSUED GUIDANCE
ABOUT USING HANDS ON CHILDREN IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM OUR CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. THAT I'M IF AN
ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN DONE BY
EITHER THE CHILD WELFARE SIDE OR
BY THE HEALTHCARE SIDE THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON CLEAR GUIDANCE
ABOUT HOW THOSE DATA.
POINTS ARE SHARED SO THAT YOU
ARE ASSESSED SEEN.
UNNECESSARILY AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY MINDFUL OF THAT.
I THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
AROUND.
OUR CONSIDERATION AROUND THE
TIME IT TAKES
THE EFFICACY CERTAINLY IT'S A
PUBLIC.
OPEN ARCHITECTURE IS.
.
DOCTOR FOLLOWS JUST SAYING SO WE
HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT POINTS
OF CONSIDERATION AND THAT I
THINK.
IT'S SIMPLY ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT THERE'S NOT ONE CLEAR.
CHOICE OTHER THAN THE PSE BUT
WE ALSO FELT REALLY STRONGLY
THAT.
THAT'S A PARENT PERSPECTIVE AND
TIME AGAIN AS DOCTORS ALL SAID
THERE'S OTHER I'M PERSPECTIVES
THAT WE NEED AND WANT TO CAPTURE
PARENTS ARE CERTAINLY ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT.
VOICES AND THEY KNOW THEIR
CHILDREN BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE
BUT THERE'S ALSO.
CLINICIANS AND OTHERS THAT WE
BELIEVE NEED TO BE.
BOTH PUTTING AND DATA AS WELL
AS HAVING US EVALUATE THAT AND
SO.
THERE'S MONEY IN THE BUDGET.
THAT WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE NOT.
MODIFIED OR CHANGED THE
PROPOSAL THERE'S APPROXIMATELY
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TRAINING.
FOR COUNTY STAFF BOTH ON THE
EIGHTEEN THE PROGRAMMATIC SIDE
THAT WE HAVE INCLUDED SO THAT
COUNTIES ARE FUNDED FORTHESE
ACTIVITIES. AND SO.
WE BELIEVE IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WE.
IMPLEMENT.
WE HAVE A DATE BY WHICH
COUNTIES HAVE TO BE PROVIDING
DATA TO US.
IN RECOGNITION OF SOME OF THE.
CONCERNS WE.
LAGGED LA TO THE START OF THE
NEW YEAR SO JANUARY.
SO WE HAVE DONE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN WE FEEL TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR BOTH CHOOSING A TOOL AND
CHOOSE AN IMPLEMENTATION. AND
THEN THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY
IS THAT.
WE'D ORIGINALLY WANTED CHILDREN
ASSESSED EVERY NINETY DAYS.
AND WE.
MODIFY THAT TO EVERY SIX MONTHS.
WHICH WAS ALSO IN RECOGNITION
OF BOTH THE CLINICIAN.
TIME AND EFFORT AS WELL AS
MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT KIDS
WERE OVERLY ASSASSIN SO YOU KNOW
WE FEEL I'M COMFORTABLE WITH THE
DECISION AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
IF WE WOULD HAVE CHOSEN ANY
OTHER TOOL YOU WOULD HAVE YOU
KNOW YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT SIDE
OF OF POPULATION BUT WE FEEL
THAT WE ALSO NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE.
PROPOSING TO DO.
I'M.
IS THERE ARE THERE ANY LESSONS
TO BE LEARNED FROM MONTANA.
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT MONTANA.
OTHER THAN I JUST HEARD IT.
AND SO IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
NINTENDO WAS USING IT FOR IT
DEPENDS ON A LOT OF THINGS AND I
THINK AGAIN. AND WE CAN LOOK AT
A LOT OF DIFFERENT STATES AND
SAY YOU KNOW WHICH SCHOOL DID
YOU USE WHAT THAT MEANT FOR THIS
PURPOSE ABOUT PURPOSE HOW DID
YOU FIND IT HOW DID YOU USE
THAT.
WHAT WAS THAT MANDATE INVOLVED
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ELSE ABOUT
HOW I COULD REACTED MONTANA?
I'M.
IT I THINK YOU'RE SEEING MY
HESITATION TO.
GO FORWARD WITHOUT FEELING AS IF
THERE'S A A.
CLEAR PLAN BEFORE US THAT
UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED EVEN BY
MEMBERS OF THE TASK FORCE THAT
WERE MEANT TO BE PUT TOGETHER
THAT YOU HAVE.
SEVERAL MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES
AND SO I'M. DONE THAT EXPRESSING
MY HESITATION AND.
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH A.
THE STAKEHOLDERS HERE TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY'RE SOME
RESOLUTION WE CAN COME TO.
BUT WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
FOR NOW AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FIFTEEN.
OKAY SO.
.
VERY QUICKLY.
WE ARE SEEKING.
TEN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF TEN
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR.
SEVERAL DIFFERENT ITEMS THAT
ARE EMBEDDED WITHIN THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
THERE'S
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT LAST
YEAR THAT WAS ACTION DOLLARS SO
THAT FUNDING WAS GIVEN TO US BUT
THAT POSITION AUTHORITY WAS NOT
SO. FOUR OF THOSE ARE JUST
LITERALLY NOT ADDITIONAL MONEY
BUT JUST GIVING US THE POSITION
AUTHORITY.
THERE ARE STAFF THAT HER ON THE
INSIDE AROUND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE.
FIVE A ONE BY A MISTER RIDLEY
THOMAS.
AS WELL AS.
FUNDING FOR OUR EXTERNAL
QUALITY REVIEW ORGANIZATION
WHICH IS A REQUIREMENT OF THE
FEDERAL MANAGED CARE RULE.
.
SO THE.
GENERAL OVERALL REQUEST IS FOR
TEN PERMANENT POSITIONS IN YOUR
AGENDA DID A REALLY NICE JOB OF
LAYING IT OUT THE ONE QUESTION
THAT WE WERE ASKED TO RESPOND
WITH WHICH. WAS YOU KNOW FOR
WHAT REASON ITS IMAGE AS A STATE
ADMIN FUNDING NOT PROPOSE FOR
PART OF THAT IS.
NONE OF THESE ITEMS THAT WE ARE
SEEKING ARE USING MHSAA FUNDING
OTHER THAN WHAT WAS FUNDED LAST
YEAR IN THE BUDGET FOR THE.
FOR POSITION SO WE JUST NEED
AUTHORITY FOR SO THE REST OF
THIS IS NOT RELATED TO MHSAA SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT PROPOSED.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EARLIER.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
FIFTEEN.
KRISTIN BARLOWE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
STAFF AND PERMANENCY FOR THE
STAFF THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN OUR ARENA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS VERY
MUCH DATING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ECHOING CBO CHEESE COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT.
EGGMAN.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FIFTEEN OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIXTEEN.
SURE SO THIS IS A BILL.
AUTHORED BY SENATOR MITCHELL.
LAST YEAR S. B. THREE TWO THREE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MORE.
COMPLICATED ISSUES FOR US TO.
SORT OUT IN TERMS OF WORKING
WITH ARE FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS OR RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS.
THAT ARE SEEKING TO PROVIDE I'M
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT SERVICES
OR SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO THE POSITIONS ARE.
BOTH PROGRAMMATIC AS WELL AS
STAFF SEEN OUR AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS SIDE THAT SETS
ALL OF THAT PPS SCOPE OF
SERVICE.
RATES FOR THE SERVICES AND SO
IT'S I'M FIVE PERMANENT FULL
TIME POSITIONS AS WELL AS SOME
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY EQUIVALENT
TO TWENTY ONE POSITIONS.
AS A RESULT OF THE DIFFERENT
CHANGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SPILL.
AND BUT DEFERRED TO MY
COLLEAGUES OF FINANCE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE THAT I MISSED ON
THE US DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ELIA.
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
SIXTEEN.
KRISTIN BARLOWE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL WE WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LEGISLATION
THAT I PUT THEM IN THIS
PREDICAMENT AND SO CERTAINLY
WOULDSUPPORT THEM GETTING THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO PUT IT
INTO PLACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL HOLD ISSUE SIXTEEN OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVENTY.
SO.
LAST AND I'M SORRY THAT DOCTOR
WOOD IS NO LONGER WITH US BUT
OUT OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE WHICH WAS
NO LONGER MECHANISM HE'S STILL
WITH US WELL RIGHT I'M SORRY HE
IS NO LONGER PHYSICALLY WITH US
IN THIS ROOM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE. CLARIFICATION.
.
SO.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR A BILLABLE SERVICES TO BE
PROVIDED BY A MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPISTS WITHIN AN FQHC
RHC.
THIS.
JUST AS AN ADDENDUM TO AND DISH
IN THE. REQUEST FOR STAFFING
THAT WE BELIEVE ALSO BECOMING
AND AS A RESULT OF.
CLINICS NEEDING TO CHANGE THEIR
I'M SCOPE OF SERVICE REQUEST TO
ALLOW FOR THIS NEW BILLABLE
PROVIDER IS.
THERE'S AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AND
THE AGENDA AROUND THE SUBMISSION
OF THE STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
WHICH WE SUBMITTED ON. ON FRIDAY
MARCH THIRTY FIRST I BELIEVE.
IT WAS.
.
IT IT IT BOTH NOT ONLY ADDS THAT
ENOUGH T. AS A BILLABLE PROVIDER
BUT IT ALSO HAD OTHER.
COMPLIMENTS RELATED TO
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND SO WE WILL BE
WAITING TO HEAR FROM CMS ON THE
SUBMISSION OF THAT STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT IF THERE'S QUESTIONS
OR ANYTHING. BUT THIS IS SEEKING
TO ESSENTIALLY.
BE PREPARED FOR THE WORKLOAD
THAT WE ANTICIPATE THAT WILL BE
COMING AND AS CLINICS.
SEEK TO PUT THESE BILLABLE
PROVIDERS AND.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EARLIER.
WELL.
OF BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA L. I
WOULD JUST QUICKLY NOTE THAT
WE'VE REVIEWED ALL THE BCP'S
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THAT HAS
SUBMITTED THIS YEAR AND THAT
OTHER THAN THIS ONE WHICH WE
HAVE NO ISSUES WITH ANY OF THEM.
HOWEVER ON THIS PROPOSAL WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A LIMITED TERM.
RESOURCES AND POSITION
AUTHORITY BUT ONLY FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OF THE. TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY RESOURCES ARE
ARE SOMEWHAT HIGHER THAN THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RESOURCES A
HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
SENSE OF OUT WHAT THE DEMAND IS
GOING TO BE FOR THE SCOPE OF
SERVICE REQUESTS. OUT WHEN THIS
WHEN THE SPA WILL ULTIMATELY BE
APPROVED AND SO WE FEEL THAT
AFTER WE HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WILL
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF HOW MANY
HOW MUCH OF NEW AUDIT RESOURCES
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD NEED AND
THAT THE DECISION COULD BE MADE
AT THAT. TIME.
WE'D JUST FINALLY NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T PLAN ON
HIRING ANY OF THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF UNTIL STARTING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. SO ARE
APPROVING THE RESOURCES AND
ANTICIPATION THAT BUDGET ARM
COULD DOES MAKE SENSE.
TOYOTA HUMPHRIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
.
YOU KNOW WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
TO WENT TO INCLUDE FUNDING
THROUGH NINETEEN TWENTY AS TO
ESTIMATED LEVEL OF RESOURCES IT
IS NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL. GIVEN THAT WORKLOAD IS
EXPECTED TO MATERIALIZE STARTING
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY AND
NINETEEN THERE WOULD BE LIMITED
DATA. BASED ON A FEW MONTHS OF
ACTUAL EXPERIENCE TO DEVELOP A
SPRING PROPOSAL IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET SO REACHED ONE
MAGNOTTA THOUGHT. AND NOT AS YOU
AS THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONS THAT
THEY HAVE SUBMITTED THE STATE
PLAN AMENDMENT SO.
REPUBLICAN ANTWONE ISSUE
SEVENTEEN.
KIRSTEN BARLOW ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE VIEW
THE FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CARE CENTERS AND RURAL HEALTH
CARE CLINICS IT'S IMPORTANT
PARTS OF OUR HEALTH CARE SAFETY
NET COMMUNITIES. MANY OF WHOM DO
OFFER MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
SERVICES SO TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL AND GET THE
MFT IS AS BILL PROVIDERS OF
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE WOULD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL KEEP ISSUE SEVENTEEN
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO FISH YOU
EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
HE CURLED THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES.
IT'S LATE I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF
FISH.
.
BUT WILL IT WE'RE ASKING FOR IT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR.
APPROPRIATION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN SUPPORT OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB TWELVE
NINETY NINE AB TOLD MY NINE
MISTER RIDLEY THOMAS IS BILL
FROM YEAR TO AGO.
IN THE.
ANSWER REALLY.
A DIFFICULT QUESTION AND
ACTUALLY SOLVE THE TWENTY THREE
YEAR OLD PROBLEM WHICH IS THE
PROBLEM. OF YOU WHEN CHILDREN OR
YOUTH ARE PLACED IN FOSTER CARE
AND THEN PLACED OUTSIDE THEIR
COUNTIES ORIGINAL JURISDICTION
THEY HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING. DE GETTING.
BUT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO GET A
SERVICES AT ALL WHEN THEY GET
SERVICES THERE MARK MORE LIKELY
GET FEWER SERVICES AND NOT AS
INTENSIVE. SO THAT WAS THE ISSUE
AND AND WHAT IT REALLY CAME DOWN
TO AS WELL WHEN A YOUNG PERSON'S
PLACE THAT A COUNTY. OR ALSO
PLACED OUTSIDE THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN
WHICH MAKES IT VERY VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN THAT TO A RANGERS ARE
EITHER PROVIDER RANGE OF
SERVICES.
AND WHAT WILL THEY NINE DID VERY
SIMPLY WILL SHIFT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FROM THE COUNTY
OF JURISDICTION. TO THE COUNTY
OF RESIDENCE
AND SAID OKAY WHERE YOU'RE
LIVING IS THE COUNTY THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE THEN FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE.
THE FUNDING THEN FOLLOWS THE
YOUTH THROUGH.
THE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY.
THE PROBLEM THE COUNTIES RUN
INTO IS THAT THERE'S ABOUT A
THREE YEAR LAG BEFORE THEY START
TO SEE THOSE FUNDS THAT THEY
HAVE TO PUT OUT IN YEAR ONE AND.
THEY START TO SEE THOSE FUNDS
ARE TO SHOW UP IN THEIR
ALLOCATION YOUR THREE.
.
PARTICULARLY A IMPACTED BY THIS
OR COUNTIES WHERE THERE EITHER A
LARGE NUMBER OF OF SD RTP SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC OF
PROGRAMS.
WHERE THERE ARE A LOT OF OF THAT
OF RESOURCE FAMILY HOMES WHO
RELIED CAN ARE EVER LET KIDS GO
OUT OF THE AT AND ABOUT OF
COUNTY CARE? THOSE KIDS MAY HAVE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT TO MIDDLE
HEALTH NEEDS.
WHAT PRO THE PROBLEM THAT IT
POSES A CASH FLOW PROBLEM IT'S A
IT'S A?
IT'S A AS A TEMPORARY CASH FLOW
PROBLEM.
BUT IT'S A REALLY ACUTE CRITICAL
CASUAL PROBLEM FOR THIS
COUNTIES.
WHAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT ARE
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
BASICALLY A THAT ACOSTA POOL BE
ESTABLISHED A THREE YEAR BECAUSE
POLL? ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO COVER
THOSE UPFRONT COSTS.
IF WE FIGURE IT'S PROBABLY
BASED ON THE BEST INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE.
WHICH COMES OUT OF THE.
THE DCS POS DATA AND IT COMES
OUT OF.
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT DATA IS
THAT IT'S PROBABLY ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR I SORT OF
UP FRONT BEFORE IT STARTS TO
CATCH UP.
AND THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS STATE FUNDS TO EVER
COUNTY REALIGNMENT DOLLARS AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
I'M SO WE THINK THAT IF THE
STATE PUTS UP THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. ASIDE THEN IN THOSE FOR
THOSE THREE YEARS ONE TWO THREE
BUT PUT IT UP FRONT THE SEVENTY
FIVE TO BE HELD US BECAUSE
PEOPLE. THAT BY THE END OF THOSE
THREE YEARS THING SHOULD BE
FAIRLY WELL A SQUARED AWAY.
THERE'S THAT THERE'S A QUESTION
OF WHETHER OR NOT THEN THAT
SHOULD BE PAID BACK.
AND AND I THINK TO THE IS THAT
THE ANSWER THAT'S WORRIED WHERE
AGNOSTIC ON THAT.
IF INDEED.
WE SEE KIDS ARE GETTING SERVE
TO ARTS ARE BEFORE IF THEY'RE
GETTING THAT ME MORE INTENSIVE
SERVICES ARE MORE SERVICES AND
AS YOU KNOW AS OPPOSED TO WHAT
WE'RE SAYING NOW. THEN IT MAKES
SENSE THAT THAT'S ADDITIONAL
MONEY THE COUNTIES WERE
PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED TO SPEND
SHOULD BE PAID BACK.
UP ON THE OTHER HAND IF IN FACT
NOTHING CHANGES THAT IS TO SAY
WE GET BASICALLY FLAT.
YOU KNOW FLAT.
PROVISION OF SERVICE ARE FLAT
THAT EXPENDITURE OF DOLLARS
INFUSION SERVICES THAT MAKE
SENSE IT WOULD BE PAID BACK.
THREE ASKING FOR THAT THE COST
POOL AND TO BE WORKED OUT
BETWEEN PART OF FINANCE AND THE
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS.
SIR.
ROTH.
CHRIS UMBRELLA ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU.
BUT WE DO WILL CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE SPONSOR OF
THE LEGISLATION AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE IS THINKING OF US.
AND IN TERMS OF THE COUNTY'S
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE THE
RECEIVERS OF OUT OF COUNTY
PLACEMENT SOME OF THEM ARE
SMALLER. AND MEDIUM SIZE
COUNTIES THAT DEBT DEFINITELY
WILL WILL FEEL I AM A CASH FLOW
CRUNCH TO THAT AND WE'VE TRIED
TO CREATIVELY IDENTIFY A METHOD
WITHIN COUNTY LAND.
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE I'M A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ESTABLISHED A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY OR A GPA. I'M CALLED
CAL MESA THAT.
ENTITY DOES HAVE EXPERIENCE.
BASED ON THE ADMINISTRATING
COMPANY THAT THEIR AFFILIATED
WITH AND SETTING UP BANKING
PULLS FOR JUST THIS KIND OF
SITUATION.
IT'S OUR SENSE THAT AB TWELVE
NINETY NINE MAY OR MAY NOT
RESULT IN INCREASED.
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES NEEDS.
STATEWIDE BUT MORE SO THAT THAT
NEED IS BEING TRANSFERRED FROM
ONE COMMUNITY TO THE NEXT
AND SO AND WE WOULD CERTAINLY
NEVER TURN DOWN THE STATE
GENERAL FUND DOLLAR. TO ADDRESS
OUR CASH FLOW NEEDS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BUT THE FACT THAT IT'S
DESCRIBED REALLY IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE REPAID OVER TIME.
OR ESSENTIALLY ALONE AND MAKE
SAID IN SOMEWHAT LESS
ATTRACTIVE.
AND SO JUST HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THE THE BANKING PULL THAT
COUNTIES ARE TRYING TO HAVE SET
UP WHEREIN.
EACH COUNTY WOULD ESSENTIALLY
I'M WITH THEIR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS APPROVAL CONTRIBUTE
SOME LEVEL OF FUNDING COUNTIES
THAT ARE RECEIVING COUNTIES
COULD MAKE WITHDRAWALS.
AGAINST THOSE FUNDS ROUND THEIR
PARTNER COUNTIES UMF MANY OF
WHOM IT'S IT'S A FAIRLY.
.
ESTABLISHED PATTERN THAT A
NUMBER OF TOGETHER COUNTIES ARE
BIG CENTERS AND BIG COW ANOTHER
SET OF COUNTIES BEING BIG
RECEIVERS AND SO UMPIRE JOHN
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY IS
WORKING. AND DOING A LOT OF
OUTREACH TO THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE REALLY MOST IMPACTED IN
EITHER AS A RECEIVER OR SENATOR
TYPE OF COUNTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE EIGHTEEN.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
FAIR ADVOCATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THIS WORD IS BEEN USED
SEVERAL TIMES BUT WE ARE
AGNOSTIC US TO THE SOLUTION. FOR
COUNTIES IN THE SITUATION WE
APPRECIATE THE ALLIANCE'S
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE AS WELL
THE CAL MESA SOLUTION WHICH IS A
COUNTY OPT IN. A CONCEPT OUT WE
ARE MONITORING THE ISSUE AND WE
WELCOME ANY HELPTHAT COUNTIES
CAN GET FOR.
ADJUSTING TO THE TWELVE NINETY
NINE POLICY CHANGE LASTLY JUST
WANNA PUT IN A NOTE THAT COUNTY
STRONGLY SUPPORTED AB TWELVE
NINETY NINE SO FIGURING OUT HOW
TO MAKE THE MONEY FLOW IS A
PRIORITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS MARIE
COLLINS WITH CASA PACIFICA ARM I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS FROM BUDGET REQUEST IT IS
SOME UNITS YOU THAT'S AFFECTING
US IN VENTURA COUNTY.
.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT TWELVE
NINETY NINE AND THE WHOLE
CONCEPT FOR ANY CHILD LET ALONE
A FOSTER CHILD BUT THE MONEY
FOLLOWS THE YOUTH TO WHERE THEY
NEED TO RECEIVE SERVICES
OBVIOUSLY. A NO BRAINER AND
NOTHING THAT ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WOULD DISAGREE WITH.
.
BUT IT BUT IT I DON'T EVEN
PRETEND TO UNDERSTAND
REALIGNMENT IN ALL OF THIS CRAZY
STATE FUNDING YES BUT.
.
THE REALITY IS THERE IS A LAG AT
THIS POINT IN TIME AND THERE IS
THERE ARE ON THERE ARE PRESSURES
BEING PUT UPON.
AND KIDS NEED THE SERVICES AND
THEY NEED TO RECEIVE THE
SERVICES WHEREVER THEY MAY BE IN
THE STATE AND SO THERE MAY BE
KID FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY OR
FRESNO COUNTY WHERE LA COUNTY
COME THAT NEED THE SERVICES THAT
WE PROVIDE OUR COUNTY AND.
THIS SHOULDN'T BE A BARRIER TO
THEM RECEIVING THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED SO I HOPE YOU CONSIDER
THE REQUEST THANK YOU MAKE HIM.
THE UNDERCUT CARBON THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEAVER HEALTH AGENCIES I'M
TRUSTING THAT BACKWARDS.
I.
WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WE
BELIEVE THAT IT'S A PRACTICAL
SOLUTION HELPING ACHIEVE THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF AB TWELVE.
WE CAN.
I KILLERS REPRESENTING A SPARE
ENOUGH ONE OF THE LARGEST FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES IN THE STATE
PROVIDING SERVICES TO NEARLY
THREE THOUSAND YEAR. AND THAT'S
PROPOSAL IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANCIA I'M OURSELVES AND
OUR OTHER FELLOW FFA IS AS IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE SUCCESS
OF CCR. AND GETTING TIMELY
ACCESS TO SERVICES AND FOR KIDS
IN OUR CARE AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE DO IN A TIMELY MANNER AND SIR
AS WHERE STEPPING DOWN YOUTH
FROM ASK YOUR KEY PIECE THAN
GIVING HIM AND TO YOU OUR.
FAMILY HOMES WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO DELIVER THE SERVICES THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR THEM SAID THE
ABILITY TO BE. FUNDED AND NOT
RISK NOT GOING REIMBURSED FOR
SERVICES THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING
AS I CAN BE A CHALLENGE FOR
PROVIDERS TO FLOAT THAT. KIND OF
RESOURCES THAT WERE THREE YEAR
PERIOD OF WAITING FOR
REIMBURSEMENT AND SO. APPEAL
GIVE THEM SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
THE THANK YOU.
WE CAN.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
TO BRING IT UP THE DYESS AND.
.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR FINANCE
AND I GET MYSELF IN TROUBLE FOR
BRAINSTORMING ON THE DYESS.
BUT THE IT IT'S NOT LOST ON ME
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS HERE AND IT
WAS EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
INTEREST.
THAT WAS ON COUNTY FUNDS.
IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO USE THOSE FUNDS AS A
PLACEHOLDER.
UNTIL THE COUNTIES ARE ABLE TO.
REPAY AS THEY HAVE SUGGESTED
HERE TODAY.
BEEN FOR THE GENOCIDE CARE THANK
YOU CHAIR OF CHRIS COOK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I THINK GENERALLY THE THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T SUPPORT.
THE AUGMENTATION OF THE SEVEN
FIVE MILLION.
AND AS WE'VE HEARD.
DELUDE SPIN DIRECTION GIVEN TO
THE COUNTIES ON HOW TO NAVIGATE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND IT WAS
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT IT.
BUT THEY'LL FIND WAYS IN HOW TO.
.
COMMUNICATE BETWEEN THE COUNTIES
AND AND MAKING IT WORK WITHIN
THEIR OWN.
CASH FLOW.
AND I MIGHT JUST NOTE THAT THE
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IS MHSAA
FUNDING THAT AT LEAST WITH HOW I
THINK DIRECTOR KENT'S
CHARACTERIZED THAT. SHE WOULD
ENVISION USING IT AND SORT OF A
SOMEWHAT CONSISTENT WITH THE ACT
THE FUNDING.
THE INTEREST WHAT KIND OF A
CREW TO THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS.
THAT IT'S FUNDED THAT THAT AT
THAT FUNDING IS FROM SO IT WOULD
GO TO IT THE PREVENT AND FAN
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES OR
THE INNOVATION FUNDING WHICH.
THIS PROBABLY WOULDN'T QUALIFY
UNDER THAT WAS GENERAL SERVICE
LABELS.
COM.
FINAL QUESTION IS YOU HAVE
MENTIONED FEDERAL MATCHING OR
COMPONENT OF THIS CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THAT FURTHER SO WHEN
THE.
WHEN THE CHILDREN AT WHEN THAT
WHEN THE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
AND THAT THE SERVICES ARE
BILLED.
IT'S A MEDICAL SERVICE MEDICAL
BILLABLE SERVICE AND SO THE THE
SHARING RATIO FEDERAL SHARING
RATIO ON THAT'S FIFTY PERCENT.
SO WHAT'S WHAT'S REQUIRED IS IS
BASICALLY THAT ALL THE MONEY
GOES OUT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THEN THEY GET REIMBURSED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT A FIFTY
PERCENT.
IS SO THE THE THAT THE TWENTY
FIVE YOU KNOW THAT THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT WOULD BE THAT
THE LOCAL SHARE IN ANTICIPATION
THE FEDERAL SHARE WHICH USUALLY
COMES BACK PRETTY QUICKLY.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
EIGHTEEN OPEN AND THANK YOU ALL
FOR COMING HERE TODAY THIS WILL
CONCLUDE TODAY SOMEONE HERE